with the rise of data usage in the
business world the need for managing
databases has also grown significantly
as data storage is critical to Growing
businesses now there is no question of
one size fits all answer to the question
of which database management system is
best because the choice of the dbms
depends on various factors like the
requirement of application or system
being developed be its Hardware or
software and scalability and performance
whether the system has the ability to
expand or contract the capacity of
resources in order to support the
ever-changing usage of your application
which will ultimately result in
performance now different dbms have
their strengths and weaknesses and what
may be the best dbms for one application
may not be suitable for another although
there are many popular database
Management Systems like Oracle SQL
Server posture SQL and sqlite but one
such dbms which stands out from the rest
and widely used by many as MySQL so what
could be better than staying head of the
curve and getting trained in MySQL well
subscribing to Simply learn of course
since we published degraded content
every day to help you master various
emerging Technologies and programming
languages and also make sure to hit that
Bell icon to never miss an update from
us now MySQL is a popular open source
relational database management system
that has been around since 1995. the
future of MySQL looks promising as it
continues to be widely used and is
constantly evolving to meet the
ever-changing needs of the users as more
businesses move to the cloud there is
likely to be a greater demand for
cloud-based MySQL deployment this
includes both MySQL as a service and
running on cloud-based virtual machines
so learning MySQL can add Great Value to
your array of skills now this MySQL full
course is designed to provide a
comprehensive overview of mySQL database
covering everything from the basics of
installation and understanding what is
SQL and using various types of commands
operators Clauses joints to Advanced
topics such as joints stored procedures
and because so whether you are new to
mySQL or experienced developer looking
to expand your knowledge this course
will provide you with the foundational
knowledge and practical skills that is
needed to work with mySQL effectively
throughout this course you will learn
how to create and manage MySQL databases
how to query and manipulate data using
SQL statements and how to optimize
performance using indexes and other
techniques so I've got to be further Ado
let's get started with today's session
over to our training experts
and I welcome you all to this
interesting session or introduction to
SQL
learning SQL isn't an uphill task
because unlike other programming
languages SQL is quite simple and uses
common English words in its usage
even a non-technical professional with
no prior experience in programming can
easily learn and understand it according
to a survey by stack Overflow in 2020
SQL ranked as the third most used
programming language
also every 9 out of 10 companies in the
world uses SQL so without any further
Ado let us dive straight into today's
topic on introduction to SQL
firstly let us discuss the agenda for
today's session I'll start this tutorial
by understanding what a database is and
look at some popular databases next
we'll understand the need for databases
after that we look at the evolution of
SQL and how it grew over the years
then we'll discuss what exactly is SQL
followed by some of its unique features
next we'll go to the working of SQL
types of SQL commands
towards the end we'll discuss the
advantages and disadvantages of SQL
and finally we'll see some applications
of SQL in real life
what is a database data in today's world
plays a vital role in our everyday lives
be it a work related data in your laptop
your bank account details or even your
Gmail password so it's necessary to
store this data safely and in an
organized way that's where database
comes into picture which holds and
manages the data
a database can be defined as a
collection of information or processed
data that can be stored and accessed
whenever needed for example we can use a
database to store the complete details
of an employee working in an
organization
the primary goal of a database is to
store and return information efficiently
popular databases some popular open
source and commercially available
databases are MySQL Oracle database
Microsoft SQL server mongodb and post
clear SQL
why we need a database now that we have
understood what a database is let's
understand the use of database and the
need for it
database came into existence in the
early 1970s but all the data was stored
in computer files before that as the
technology kept advancing it became
difficult for computers to handle when
the number of files increase and the
volume of data grew
the so-called traditional file system
was no longer able to store and retrieve
data efficiently
let us now see some of the limitations
and drawbacks caused by traditional file
system
data redundancy and inconsistency
redundancy means when the same data is
getting duplicated and repeated in
different locations this leads to access
and unwanted storage which eventually
results in inconsistency where the data
in separate files do not match with each
other
data isolation data is isolated because
it is scattered in various files in
different locations and the files may be
in different formats as well at any
point writing the application programs
to retrieve the appropriate data becomes
difficult as the files are separated
from each other
limited data access file storage systems
usually do not have access for multiple
users this means multiple users at
different places cannot access the data
simultaneously it becomes difficult to
access important data if multiple users
are searching at the same time
security and integrity issues data
stored in files can easily be accessed
and tampered so it's essential to
prevent unauthorized users access to
hold the data's integrity
in order to limit all these drawbacks we
use a database that is controlled by a
database management system
let us now look at the history of SQL
SQL was developed by IBM in the year
1970. Dr Cod boys and Donald Chamberlain
proposed a paper on usage of relational
database management they came up with
SQL which can be used to perform
operations on data stored in the
databases
SQL was made publicly available and was
accepted for the use of relational
database in year 1974.
initially the language was known as
Structured English query language
pronounced as SQL which was later
changed into SQL in the year 1978.
The American National Standard Institute
ANSI and other International
organizations have standardized SQL as a
language for database communication in
the year 1986.
no companies use a different version of
SQL nowadays the latest version of it
was released in 2019 by Microsoft
what is SQL SQL is defined as a
structure query languages
it allows the user to manage and
manipulate the database
so you might have got a doubt in your
head that we have discussed databases
earlier and why we are discussing SQL
now well you got it right both database
and SQL are interconnected to each other
SQL allows you to perform operations
like insert update modify and delete in
the database
in a nutshell SQL is used to communicate
with the database systems to retrieve
the information
features of SQL
SQL is one of the most demanding skills
nowadays with the ever increasing amount
of data SQL serves as a powerful tool to
provide insights to businesses while
handling databases
SQL is used to define the overall schema
that is the complete structure of the
database by managing and manipulating
the data accordingly and retrieving the
information whenever required by the
user
SQL also allows flexibility as it uses
simple English words in its queries like
create delete
Etc
SQL can handle large amounts of Records
stored in databases with utmost
efficiency
let us now see how SQL Works a typical
SQL database engine includes a storage
engine which is a database server and a
query processor within the SQL engine
to understand simply let us take an
example suppose Jon is an HR Manager
working in an organization he wants the
information of all the employees who
have joined last year
John writes an SQL query in his laptop
to retrieve the data in order to execute
the query it must interact with
relational database management system
within the database server
and the request should be a valid query
before the SQL engine can process it the
SQL engine then writes to and retrieves
data from the database server
both database server and SQL engine work
hand in hand together to process the
required data the system process the SQL
request and sends it to web server
to access the information via SQL
database and if the information is found
in the tables the database server sends
the information back to the user
in this way John can retrieve the
information from the database using SQL
types of SQL commands SQL commands give
instructions to database to perform
specific actions to retrieve the data
SQL commands are broadly classified into
four types the first one is data
definition language or ddl ddl allows
the user to define the table and change
its overall structure
commands that are used in ddlr create it
is used to create a new table
alter it is used to modify the existing
table by adding unique attributes drop
it is used to delete the whole table and
the data stored in it truncate it is
used to delete the rows in a table
the next one is data manipulation
language or DML DML is used to access
and manipulate data in tables commands
that are used in dmlr select it is used
to extract data from the tables update
it is used to update a value in the
existing table delete unlike the drop
command the delete command is used to
delete a specific Row in the table
insert it is used to insert a new value
into the table
the next one is data control language or
DCL
is responsible for maintaining the
security which gives control access and
permissions to the database commands
that come under DCL are Grant it is used
to Grant permission to user to access
the database revoked it is used to
cancel or take back the earlier granted
permission
the last one is transaction control
language or TCL
TCL has three commands namely commit it
is used to permanently save the
transaction
rollback it is used to restore the
transaction that is not saved
save point it is used to hold a
transaction temporarily it can be rolled
back to its previous state at any point
let us now look at some of the
advantages of SQL
one of the main advantages of SQL is
that it provides access to data stored
in database with its high speed and fast
acquiry processing quickly and
efficiently
SQL is open source that means it is
publicly available and can be accessed
from the internet it is also
straightforward to implement as well
SQL also provides the user to have
multiple views of their content stored
in the database
SQL is efficient in retrieving vast
amount of data using simple queries
and also it is portable as well which
means you can perform all these
operations at your home or your
workplace through your laptops and PCs
disadvantages of SQL there are two sites
to every coin and similarly SQL also has
few advantages which are not that
significant
initially one may find it challenging to
work with SQL due to its complex
interface
since it's a platform based languages
most of the commercially available SQL
servers costs are relatively higher
SQL is constantly working on these
massive amounts of data stored in the
databases and hence maintenance costs
are also high as well
let us now look at some of the
applications in real life of SQL SQL is
widely used in various sectors nowadays
some of them are education schools and
universities use SQL and databases to
store and retrieve information about
their students
faculty and staff
Healthcare hospitals and other medical
centers use SQL to store the retails of
the patients without any hassle it also
helps in maintaining all the documents
and bills as well
retail and e-commerce with its vast
presence in the market retail and
e-commerce companies store their
customers data to improve their shopping
experiences by providing special offers
which will in turn help their businesses
to grow
is one of the significant components of
banking sector as well Bank story
Account Details of customers and the
transactions done on day-to-day basis in
the database
Finance Finance is another massive area
where SQL queries are used regularly in
managing the assets Revenue details
shares of the companies Etc faster
execution and retrieval of data are key
for all the businesses to make
strategies and derive insights from it
companies using SQL
SQL is used extensively every day by
some big Tech gen companies like Google
Microsoft Oracle Amazon
Facebook
Etc even small companies and startups
heavily rely on SQL to make better
decisions and provide Solutions and
service to customers
with that we have come to the end of
this session on introduction to SQL by
now you must have got some idea of what
SQL is over the years SQL has evolved
and is widely used nowadays worldwide it
is one of the most efficient database
languages out there it can perform
various operations on the database to
retrieve the data instantly
SQL is very simple to understand and
easy to learn as well as all the
commands and queries are written using
English words
unlike other programming languages SQL
requires almost no coding it does not
require thousands of lines of code the
syntax is also user friendly and easy to
implement everyone welcome to another
interesting video tutorial on how to
install MySQL server on your Windows
system so in this session uh we'll go
through the complete installation
process of MySQL workbench as well as
MySQL shell which is basically a command
line used to create tables with the help
of physical language
so without any further delay let's get
started
but before we begin make sure you have a
good internet connection so that at any
point you won't find any issue or
difficulty with the installation process
so let's go ahead and start with
installation firstly go to Google and
type MySQL
you'll find MySQL official website page
on the search result click on that
once you reach the official website page
you'll find download section click on
that
now scroll down a bit and you'll find
MySQL Community GPL downloads click on
that link
now you'll find various options for
download such as various repositories
MySQL shell MySQL workbench Etc but
since we are installing it for the first
time on our Windows system and we are
only concerned with the MySQL workbench
and shell I will go with mySQL installer
for Windows click on that link
now you'll find two options for download
uh the first one is Windows 86 32-bit
MSI installer it is showing here 32-bit
but it will work for a 62-bit systems as
well so don't worry and you can choose
either of the two and I'm going with the
first one click on download
now you'll find this page where you will
have login and sign up uh for the Oracle
account for time being just ignore that
and click on no thanks to start my
download
save it on your system
once it's downloaded open the file
give all the necessary permissions
now you will find a setup page where
you'll have different options such as
developer server client full and custom
uh we'll choose custom because we want
MySQL workbench and MySQL shell so click
on next
now we have to select the products which
we want to install in our system uh you
can find MySQL server click on that and
expand it you'll find MySQL server 8.0
click on that we'll find the latest
version of it uh click on that and
select the arrow and send it to the
other side now scroll down a bit and
you'll find applications click on that
you can see MySQL workbench
expand it and you'll find the latest
version of it as well click on that and
click on the adder and send it to the
other side scroll down a bit and you'll
find MySQL shell as well click on that
expand it select the latest version
click the arrow and send it to the other
side now we are good to go and click on
next
now it will ask for the path where you
want to install all these files we are
saving this on our C drive
just check all the necessary parts and
click on next
now all the three products are ready to
download click on execute
again uh now depending upon your
internet speed this may take a while so
don't worry just sit back and wait for
it to get downloaded
you can see all the three are
successfully downloaded uh click on next
now we need to install all the three
products click on execute
so you can do the installation process
simultaneously with me or just take a
note of it and perform it later as well
on your PCS and laptop this might take a
while so we'll wait for it to get
installed
as you can see all the three of them are
successfully installed click on next
click on next again
I'll find the server configuration type
you'll find different port number and
protocol Port just leave as it is
because it is set by default by the
system click on next
I will have the authentication method
you'll be provided with two options I
will choose the recommended one which is
given by the system
click on next again
now we have to set a root password so by
the way guys the root is basically the
default user which will have who will
have the access to all the files and
programs so enter a password of your own
choice
and make sure you take a note of it
because uh we'll have to use it at a
later stage and also by logging into the
MySQL server you will use the same
password
so click on check
so as you can see there's a blue tick
mark which means it's verified so you
can go ahead click on next
now I'll find the windows service which
is the standard system account
choose that and click next
now you have to apply all the
configuration for the system files for
that just click on execute
and the system will automatically
configure itself
so this might take a while so we'll wait
for it to complete
as you can see the all the files are
successfully configured click on finish
click on next
so once you click on finish uh MySQL
workbench and MySQL will automatically
launch
so workbench and shella started in the
background uh as you can see there's a
local instant mysql80 click on that
will ask you to enter the password which
you've said earlier click on that
so that's it guys we have successfully
installed MySQL workbench on our system
but before you get started there's
another little process that will with
that we are left behind with uh now you
have to connect all the files and
packages to the server before you start
working on the tables so for that we
need to locate where the where the MySQL
files are stored for that we'll go to
file manager
since we have saved the files on local
disk D local disk C uh click on C drive
go to program files
click on MySQL
open MySQL server 8.2
click on bin now these are all the files
and packages that you have to connect to
the server for that double click on
location path
copy the whole address
and open command prompt
on the command prompt you'll have to
type CD that is the current directory
and uh paste the address that you have
copied earlier and click enter
now type MySQL space my U root
minus P here minus U is the user which
is the root user which you have taken
minus p is the password click on enter
now it will ask you to enter the
password that you have set earlier type
the same
so if you find what you are seeing in my
system that is Oracle is registered
trademarkov Oracle Corporation and all
this thing that means you have
successfully downloaded and install all
the files and packages into the MySQL
server and you are good to go and start
working on your tables right away
learning a new programming language and
its syntax can be quite difficult
sometimes whereas SQL syntax is very
simple to learn and easy to execute as
well more on that soon so without any
further delay let's get started with
today's topic
firstly let us discuss the agenda for
today's session we'll start the tutorial
by understanding what SQL syntax is and
why we use it next we'll understand what
are SQL expressions and SQL statements
then we'll discuss about SQL data types
followed by SQL operators next we'll go
through SQL commands and its types
after that we'll discuss the syntax of
ddl commands followed by DML commands
and finally we'll have a look at the
syntax of DCL commands as well
what is SQL syntax
just like other programming languages
SQL follows a unique set of rules and
guidelines called syntax we use Simple
English words in SQL syntax in order to
execute various queries
SQL syntax is by default case
insensitive that means the system allows
the user to write the queries in both
uppercase as well as lowercase but if
you are working with mySQL server then
you need to give table names exactly as
they exist in the database
we know that rdbms is the basis for all
modern database systems including SQL
which manages and performs various
operations on the tables like insert
update modify and delete so in order to
retrieve the data stored in the database
it is necessary to learn SQL syntax
first
before we move ahead with the topic if
you want to learn more about the basics
of dbms and SQL make sure you check out
our previous playlist videos on
introduction to dbms and SQL on our
Channel we'll leave the link in the
description below
SQL Expressions SQL expression is a
combination of one or more keywords and
values operators data types and other
SQL functions these SQL expressions are
like a formula which are similar to
mathematical formulas which we generally
use to solve a problem and in this case
the written in a query language using a
proper syntax
SQL statement SQL statements are
basically collection of SQL expressions
for example let us consider an employee
table to understand it in a better way
the table is having attributes like
employee ID name age City and salary
now if I want to fetch the record of all
the employees and their IDs I'll write a
simple SQL query
that is Select ID comma name from
employee here select is the database
object or the keyword that is used ID
and name are the columns from employee
employee is the name of the table when I
execute this query this will be the
output it will display the ID and name
of the employee
let us look at another query now I want
to display uh the salary of employees
having uh more than 30 000. for that I
am using the query as select ID name
from employee where salary is greater
than 30 000. here where is the
conditional statement that I'm using or
it is a SQL clause also we are using
greater than symbol which is an SQL
operator
so with the help of sketch statements we
can fetch uh the records
of all the information from SQL tables
SQL data types SQL data type specifies
which type of values is stored in the
database tables SQL data types are
mainly classified into three categories
the first one is numeric numerical data
refers to the data that is in the form
of numbers a numerical data type we have
different uh types as well for example
int int hole's values of integers and
whole numbers without any decimal point
further they are again divided into
small end and begins also the difference
between them is the size and range of
the value they can store and operate
bit data type is an integer data type
that can only take values of 0 1 or any
null value SQL optimizes storage of bit
columns if a table has eight or fewer
bit columns SQL stores them as one byte
if a table has 9 or up to 16 bit columns
SQL stores them as two bytes and so on
float float stores the numbers having
decimal values depending upon the number
of digits after the decimal point SQL
gives the size accordingly in its range
Boolean it is used to specify Boolean
values that is true and false 0 is
considered as false and non-zero values
are considered as true
string data type string data types
allows us to store fixed or variable
character values they are again further
divided into various types the first one
is care car is used to specify a fixed
length string that can contain numbers
letters and special characters its size
can be 0 to 255 characters
similar to care but it stores variable
length strings and size of wire care is
also more than the car data type with a
range of 0 to almost 60 000 characters
so if you're storing strings with a
widely variable lens such as name
address email ID then we have to use a
Barca
text text data type stores any kind of
text Data it can hold string value that
can contain maximum length of 255
characters
date time in SQL daytime data type is
used for storing values that can contain
both date as well as time
the first one is date it is used to
specify date format that is year month
date in this data type we can store only
the value of date
and the next one is date time it is used
to specify the combination of both date
and time the format is year month date
Hearts minutes and seconds for instance
I have taken the example as 2022
3 that is the month 20 is the date 23
hours 59 is the minutes and 59 is the
seconds
timestamp it is also similar to daytime
data type the format specification is
also the same as well the only
difference is it has less a range of
values to store it is also used to
convert current time into various time
zones like UTC GMT Etc
we also have XML and Json data types
which are not that significant and we do
not use as frequently as other data
types in SQL
SQL operators SQL operators are used to
specify certain conditions in an SQL
statement SQL operators are broadly
classified into five categories the
first one is arithmetic arithmetic
operators perform mathematical operation
on numerical data on the SQL tables
these operation performs addition
subtraction multiplication and division
operations on the numerical operands the
next one is logical The Logical
operators in SQL perform Boolean
operations which gives two results
either true or false these operators
provide True Value if both operands
match The Logical condition some logical
operators are and not are between
Etc
comparison the comparison operator is in
SQL Compares two different data
in the SQL tables and checks whether
they are same greater or lesser the SQL
comparison operator are used with a
conditional Clause where in the SQL
queries
equal to is highly used uh comparison
operator in SQL
bitwise bitwise operators perform bit
manipulations between two expressions of
any integer data type category bitwise
operators convert two integer values to
Binary bits and perform and or or not
operation on each bit which finally
gives the required result
final one is set the set operators in
SQL combine a similar type of data from
two or more SQL database tables
basically it merges the result which is
extracted from two or more SQL queries
into a single result SQL Union intersect
and minus operators are some of the
examples of set operations
SQL commands we know that SQL commands
are broadly classified into four types
the first one is data definition
language ddl ddl allows the user to
define the table and make changes to its
overall structure commands that are used
in ddlr create it is used to create a
new table
alter it is used to modify the existing
table by adding new attributes drop it
is used to delete the whole table and
the data stored in it
truncate it is used to delete the rows
in a table
now that we have got the idea and
understanding of various operators data
types and commands let us look at the
syntax of all these commands
the first one is SQL create statement
perhaps one of the most important and
used SQL statement because if you want
to create a table you have to first name
the table and then specify the columns
and the columns data types
so let us look at the syntax of create
statements
the syntax is followed as a create table
which is the keyword that is used
followed by table name that you want to
create and within the parenthesis you
have to mention the column give space
and add the data type
so in this way you can add a number of
columns and mention the data types but
make sure guys you have to give the
appropriate data type for the columns
that you have taken because there might
be a chance there might be an instance
where you have you have given the column
such as age and you are mentioning data
type as character care which is
basically a mismatch the computer
doesn't accept it because generally age
is basically a numerical value but you
are mentioning care but it should
ideally be int to store the data so just
keep an eye on it when you are creating
new tables so let us now look at an
example of create statement so I want to
create a table name employee for that I
am writing as create table space
employee and within the uh parenthesis I
am mentioning employee ID as my first
column space int which is the data type
and I'm giving name worker address
worker close the parenthesis and put a
semicolon and if you execute this
statement this will be the following
result it will display uh the table with
different columns with the First Column
as employee ID the second column is name
and the third column as address
easy right
the next one is SQL alter table
the SQL order statement is basically is
used to add a modify or even delete you
know certain columns from the existing
table let us look at the syntax of SQL
law order command
so the SQL alter command is altered
table space table name that you have to
mention
add and within the parenthesis you have
to mention the column and the data type
similarly you can add a number of data
types as per requirement
let us now look at one of the example
now I wanted to add the date of birth of
the employee in a new column for that
I'll write as altar table employee at
and within the parenthesis date of birth
and I'll mention the data type as well
which is the date and if you execute
this it will show the result like this
it will add another column date of birth
in the already existing table
now due to certain reasons if you want
to drop or delete the date of birth
column for that we have to write syntax
as alter table give the employee
table name drop column which is the
keyword we use and date of birth so this
will be the final output when you
execute the query it will completely
drop the date of birth from the table
next we'll look at SQL drop statement
a skill drop statement basically removes
all the data and it changes the overall
structure of the table by deleting the
records in the table so let us look at
the syntax the syntax followed is a drop
table followed by the table name that we
want to create
let us look one of the example uh the
syntax followed is a drop table employee
and when I execute this it will show an
error stating that table employed does
not exist which means you have
completely deleted all the records uh
from the employee table
SQL truncate statement
let us look at the SQL truncate
statement syntax the syntax is truncate
table which is the keyword that is used
and we have to specify the table name
for example if you want to truncate the
values in employee table we have to
write truncate table employee so this
will be the output where it shows null
that is uh there are no values in the
employee table and you can further add
values of your own choice
let us now look at data manipulation
language data manipulation language or
DML
is used to access and manipulate data
tables commands that are used in DML are
insert it is used to insert new values
into the table
select it is used to extract data from
the tables
update it is used to update values in
the already existing table delete unlike
the drop command delete command is used
to delete a specific row or all the rows
on the table
let us first look at the SQL insert
statement
the syntax followed in SQL in search
statement is insert into which is the
keyword that we use space table name
that we have created values and inside
the parenthesis you have to mention the
values
there is also another method to insert
the values where we specify the column
name as well as the values
now if you execute this
so but before executing we'll take an
example uh we are creating a table
student and we are inserting values such
as roll number name age and City so the
roll number uh is given as one uh the
name is given as Rohan the age is given
as 22 and the city is given as Hyderabad
for the first row similarly we do the
same for the next two rows as well and
if you execute this query this will be
the final output where you'll have four
different uh columns having the First
Column as rule number the next one
having name age city with the lower roll
numbers as one or Rohan 22 Hyderabad and
the second row consists of the Roll
number two anjana uh age being 20 and
the City Bangalore and the third one is
roll number three the name is kaushal
age 21 and the city is Mumbai
SQL select statement let us now look at
the uh syntax of SQL select statement
the SQL is followed the syntax is
followed as select column one column two
and a number of columns from the table
name
and if you want to uh display all the
names from the table you have to use
asterisk that is Select star from table
name let us look at the example
so I want to display the roll number
name age from the student table for that
I'll write select roll number
comma name comma H from the table that
is student and if I execute this it will
only display roll number name age of the
students and it will not display the
city of the students
and if you want to display uh even the
city uh
to which they belong we have to write
select star from student then it will
display even the city in the uh table
SQL select condition statement
consider employee table uh with having
ID name age City and salary
and if you want to specifically uh you
know display uh the employees name uh
who live in city New Delhi you have to
write select star from employee where
city is equals to New Delhi here we are
applying a condition that is where which
is a SQL clause and we are using an
operator as well which is equal to and
if you execute this statement it will
show this as output where you will find
the ID of aloxyn Ravi Patel who belong
to the city New Delhi
SQL update statement
it is used to update already existing
values in the statement for example if
you consider the syntax it is followed
as update space table name that you have
created set column name equals to new
value that is the updated value that you
want to keep into the new table and you
have to keep a condition as well that is
where condition
let us look an example now if you want
to update the student table and if I
want to insert uh if I want to change
the city of the Roll number three that
is kaushals uh City uh I'll write as
update student set CT equals to Chennai
where roll number is equals to 3 and
when you execute this it will show like
this
so the city uh which is Mumbai has been
changed into Chennai
SQL delete statement
SQL delete statement is is used to
delete a specific row or even all the
rows from the table the syntax is delete
from table name
for example if you want to delete all
the records from the student table we
will write it as delete from student
semicolon so this will be the output it
will only display the column names and
the data inside it will be completely
erased
and if you want to delete only a certain
number of rows we have to use Query as
delete from student where roll number is
equals to 1 and when you execute this
query it will show like this it will
completely erase the records of the Roll
number one student
and the final one is data control
language or DCL
DCL is responsible for maintaining the
security which gives control access and
permissions of the database commands
that come under dclr Grant it is used to
Grant the permission to user to access
the database revoke it is used to cancel
or take back the permissions that were
earlier granted
let us now look at SQL Grant statement
sometimes user is restricted from
creating or making any changes within
the table but with the help of Grant
statement we can give privilege to the
user to create or modify the records in
the table
let us now look at the syntax of SQL
Grant statement it is followed as Grant
space privilege list that is basically
the set of commands that you are giving
access or permission to the user to
perform certain operations on the table
that you have created to user we have to
mention the username example Grant
insert select on employee to Rahul that
means Rahul is able to access the
employee table and can perform a command
such as insert and select
SQL revoke statement SQL revoke
statement is basically the opposite of
Grant statement it is used to take back
the permissions that were earlier
granted the similar the syntax is also
similar to the grant statement instead
of Grant keyword you have to replace it
by revoke let us look at the example
revoke insert on employee from Rahul
that means Rahul is no longer able to
insert new values into the employee
table
Ado let us dive straight into today's
topic on SQL operators
firstly let us discuss the agenda for
today's session we'll start the tutorial
by understanding what SQL operators are
then we'll go through different types of
SQL operators and finally we look at the
syntax of various operators and execute
them in MySQL workbench
what are SQL operators SQL operators are
basically reserved words or special
characters that are used to query a
database
SQL provides us with many such operators
to ease the process of data manipulation
SQL operators are used to perform
various tasks including complex
mathematical operations like arithmetic
and binary
to query a database using operators we
use a where Clause operators are
necessary to define a condition in SQL
as they act as a connector between two
or more SQL statements based on the
operator functionality it manipulates
the data accordingly and gives the
result
types of SQL operators SQL operators are
mainly classified into three types the
first one is arithmetic operators the
arithmetic operators perform the
mathematical operation on numerical data
of SQL tables that further classified as
addition operator the addition operator
is used to perform addition or numerical
data using this we can add values of
single or multiple columns in the table
subtraction operator subtraction
operator in SQL performs the subtraction
on the numerical data of the database
table
multiplication operator multiplication
operator in SQL performs multiplication
on the data items in SQL we can easily
multiply the numerical values of two or
more Columns of the same table by
specifying both the column names as the
first and second operand
and finally division operator division
operator in SQL divides the operand on
the left side by the operand on the
right side we can also divide the
numerical values of one column by
another column of the same table by
specifying both column names as the
first and second operand let us now look
at the execution part of the arithmetic
operations on MySQL workbench
as you can see workbench has started but
before we proceed to the syntax of SQL
operators we have to first create a
database and then we have to create a
table within the database so for time
being I've already created a table named
employee so let us just briefly go
through the syntax of create table
so the syntax is followed as create
table space now we can declare the
employee that is the table name in two
ways that is you can directly mention
the table name that is employee or else
you can mention database dot table name
that is employee and after that in the
parenthesis you have to mention the
column names followed by its appropriate
data types
so as far as this table employees
concerned I have taken a
column names as ID name age City and
salary
and also have chosen primary key as ID
as it uniquely identifies each and every
record in the table
close the parenthesis and put a
semicolon
now that you have created a table you
have to insert values into the table and
for that we use insert command so the
Syntax for insert command is insert into
space table name that is employee and
within the parenthesis you have to
mention all the column names that you
have taken in a single quotes
after that close the parenthesis and you
have to write values which is the
keyword and mention different values as
per your choice accordingly that you
have taken into the columns so in this
way you can insert n number of Records
into the table using insert command for
this employee table I have taken out
values total of 10 values
now that you have created and inserted
values into your table and if you want
to display all the records of the
employees you have to uh write you have
to select the query as
select
star
from
the table name that is employee
and when you execute this
it will show the records of all the
employees that you have taken that is
their ID their name age City and salary
so we have taken total 10 values and it
will be displayed
now that we have understood all these
let us proceed with the SQL operators
first let us look at uh addition
operator
uh let us understand this with an help
of an example suppose you want to add 10
000 to the salary of each employee
specified in the table then we have to
write the query as
select
salary
plus 10 000.
as I'm taking a new column that is
employee new salary
to specify all these values into the
column
as employ new salary
from the table name that is employee
now when you execute this you
it will show the result like this that
is uh it will add 10 000 to each and
everyone's uh values that is 30 000 has
been changed into forty thousand twenty
eight thousand has been changed into 38
000 and so on
now if I want to display their ID name
their previous salary and the final
salary simultaneously I'll write the
query as select ID
comma space name space
salary
space salary plus 10 000 as employees
new salary from employee
now if I execute this
it will display like this that is it
will uh mention the ID name the previous
salary and employee new salary
simultaneously
so in this way you can add two or more
columns in the same table using addition
operator
let us now look at subtraction operator
subtraction operator is also similar to
that of addition operator the only
difference is you have to replace the
plus sign
with the minus sign so again for this
example uh let us say uh if you want to
subtract 2000 from salary of each
employee given in the employee table
then we have to write the query as
select
ID
comma space name
comma space salary
minus two thousand
as
employee new salary
from the table that is employee
so let us execute this
and it will show the new values that is
2000 has been deducted from the salary
of each and every employee as you can
see 30 000 has been reduced to twenty
eight thousand twenty eight thousand has
been reduced to twenty six thousand
thirty five thousand has been reduced to
33 000 and so on
so next let us look at the
multiplication operator
again let us take the same example uh if
you want to multiply the salary of each
and every employee
uh then you have to write the query as
select
ID
name
salary
into two we are using asterisk operator
as the multiplication sign here
as
employ
new salary
from the table name that is employee
now if you execute this
it will show the values like uh in this
way that is the salary has been doubled
if you as you can see the uh employer
Rahul salary 30 000 has been multiplied
uh and has changed into 60 000 that is
doubled 20 000 has been doubled to fifty
six thousand and so on
so in this way you can apply
multiplication operator and finally let
us look at a division operator
let us take the same example uh suppose
let's say if you want to divide the
salary of each and every employee then
you have to write the query as select
ID
name
salary
divided by two
as employing your salary
from the table name that is employee
and put a semicolon let us now execute
this
and as you can see the salary has been
divided uh into half uh Rahul salary 30
000 has been changed to fifteen thousand
Kiran salary 28 000 has been changed to
forty fourteen thousand and so on so in
this way you can use automatic
operations to perform various uh
operations on your table that is
addition subtraction multiplication and
division
the second type of SQL operators are
comparison operators the comparison
operators in SQL Compares two different
data of SQL tables and check whether
they are same greater and lesser the SQL
comparison operators are used with a
conditional Clause where in the SQL
queries they are again further divided
into various types the first one is
equal to SQL equal to operator is one of
the popular and most frequently used
operators in SQL queries it shows only
that data which matches the specified
value in the query
less than the less than operator in SQL
shows only those data from the database
tables which are less than the value of
the right right hand side operand
greater than the greater than operator
in SQL shows only those data which are
greater than the value of right hand
operand
we also have less than equals to and
greater than equals to operators as well
which basically shows the data in the
tables which are less than and equals to
as well as greater than equals to the
value of the right hand operands
let us look at the syntax and execute
them in the workbench
firstly let us look at the equal to
operator
let's say if you want to access the
records of all those employees who are
having salary uh equals to 40 000 so for
that we'll write the query as select
star
from the table
that is employee
we have to use the conditional statement
where
salary
is equals to forty thousand
and put a semicolon when you execute
this
it will show the records of all those
employees who are having salary equals
to 40 000 as you can see it is showing
three IDs uh pranay Anusha and Prem who
are having surgery says forty thousand
next let us look at uh not equals to not
equals to is basically the opposite of
equal to and uh
to understand this let us take an
example suppose if we want to access the
records of all those employees whose
salary is not equals to uh 35 000 so for
that we'll write the query as select
star
from the table that is employee
where
uh let us put the keyword in the upper
case where salary
not equals to 35 000.
let us execute this and let us see the
output
so as you can see it will display the
records of all those employees who are
not having the salary uh 35 000 so it
will display the record such as rahul's
Kiran pranay Anusha varsha who are
having salices thirty thousand twenty
eight thousand forty thousand twenty
three thousand and so on which are
basically not equals to thirty five
thousand
next let us look at a greater than
operator
uh for this let us take an example for
instance if you want to access the
records of all those employees from the
employee table uh whose ID is greater
than one or four so for that we'll write
the following query as
select
star
from the table that is employee
where
ID greater than one or four
for a semicolon and let us execute this
so as you can see it will display the
records of all those employees uh who
are having ID greater than 104 that is
it will display from one not five and up
until 110.
similarly uh we have the less than
operator as well
which is basically the opposite of
greater than operator for that
uh
we'll take an example such as if you
want to display the records of all those
employees who are having ID less than
1.5 so for that we'll write the query as
select
car
from the table that is employee
where
ID
is less than 1.5
let us execute this
so as you can see it will display all
those records of the employees who are
having less than one or five that is it
will display the records of the
employees 1.1 one or two one not three
and one not for IDs
next let us look at greater than equals
to
foreign
but the thing is we are also mentioning
the equal to operator as well
so for instance let's say if you want to
access the records of all those
employees in the employee table who are
having salary greater than or equals to
40 000. so for that we'll write the
query as select star
from the table employee
where
salary
greater than equals to forty thousand
let's execute this
and this is will this will be the output
it will show the records of all those
employees who are having salary greater
than or equals to forty thousand so in
this case it will display a total of
four records of the employee table
similarly let us look at the less than
equals to operator as well
which basically uses less than and equal
to operator
so suppose if you want to access the
records of all those employees from the
employee table who is having salary or
let's say less than or equals to 30 000.
so for that uh we'll have to write the
following query as select
star
from employee
where
salary
less than or equals to thirty thousand
so let us execute this
and the output will be like this that is
it will display all the employer Records
who are having salary less than or
equals to thirty thousand a total of
three records that is ID employee ID is
one not one one or two one or six are
being displayed because they are having
salary is thirty thousand twenty eight
thousand twenty three thousand which are
basically less than or equals to thirty
thousand
so in this way you can use comparison
operator to perform various operations
on your data
and finally we have logical operators
The Logical operators in SQL perform
Boolean operations which Give two
results either true or false these
operators provide True Value if both
operands match The Logical condition and
vice versa
various logical operators in SQL are and
are not and between let us understand
their syntaxes and execute them in the
workbench now
firstly let us discuss about the and
operator and operator in SQL will show
the records from a database table if all
the conditions separated by the and
operator is evaluated to be true let us
understand with an example let's say if
you want to access the records of all
those employees from the employee table
whose salary is greater than 25 000 and
the city that they belong to is
Hyderabad so for that we'll write the
following query as select star
from table name that is employee
where
salary
is greater than 25 000
and
the city that they belong to is
Hyderabad
so when you execute this statement
the following output will will be
this that is it will display the uh
total three records of the employees
that is Rahul Kiran and Chinmay who are
having salaries more than 25 000 and the
city that they belong to is Hyderabad so
in this way and operator in SQL is used
to compare data with more than one
condition if and only if all the
conditions return true then only it will
display the records otherwise it won't
next let us look at the or operator
our operator in SQL shows the records
from the table if any of the conditions
separated by the or operator evaluates
to be true
let us understand with an example for
instance if you want to display the
records of employees from the employee
table or whose salary is greater than 30
000 or the city that they belong to is
Bangalore so the following query would
be select
star
from the table that is employee
where
salary is less than 30 000
or the city that they belong to is
Bangalore
let us execute this statement now
so this will be the following output
where you can see a total of four
records of the employees uh followed by
Kiran pranay varsha and Rohit who are
having Salis less than 30 000 or else
they belong to the City Bangalore
so in this way we can use our operator
which basically compares the data with
more than one condition and unlike and
operator if either of the condition is
true it will return the data otherwise
it won't
next let us look at the between operator
between operator in SQL shows the record
within a specified range mentioned in
the SQL query if there is no value in
this given range then this operator
shows null value
suppose if you want to access the
information of all the employees from
the employee table whose salary is in
between 25
000 and 35 000 then we'll write the
following query as select star
from table name that is employee
where
salary
between
25 000
and 30 35 000.
let us execute this query now
so following is the output where it will
display the records of all those
employees who are having salaries in
between 25
000 and 35 000.
and finally let us look at the not
operator
not operator in SQL shows the records
from the table if the condition
evaluates to be false that means the not
operator is also called as a negation or
a negate operator which shows data for
the opposite of the conditions that we
mentioned in the SQL statement
let us understand this with the help of
an example let's say if you want to
access the information of all those
employees from the table who are not
having salary as 40 000 so for that
we'll write the syntax as
select
star
from table name that is employee
where
not
salary
thank you
equals to forty thousand
so let us execute this query now
so as you can see it will display all
the records of those employees who are
not having the salary as 40 000.
I'll start this tutorial by
understanding what SQL expressions are
then we'll go through different types of
SQL expressions and finally we look at
the syntax of various SQL expressions
and execute them in MySQL workbench with
examples
so what are SQL Expressions SQL
expressions are composed of one or more
keywords or values such as operators
operands and various other functions
that evaluate to a single value or a set
of values for a given SQL statement
these SQL expressions are like a formula
which are similar to that of
mathematical formulas we use to solve a
problem
and in this case they are written in a
query language using a proper syntax to
perform operations on the data we have
stored in our database table for example
consider the basic syntax of the select
statement here expressions are used in
many contexts such as to retrieve any
value from the table we use select
command and for comparison we use where
Clause so in this case all these are SQL
Expressions only
types of SQL Expressions SQL Expressions
can be classified into following
categories the first one is Boolean
expression SQL Boolean Expressions fetch
data based on one-to-one matching in
other words we can think of it as a
query that fetches one result at a time
it will fetch the condition against uh
the single value when the query is
executed
the second one is numeric expression SQL
numeric expression is used for
performing mathematical operations in
SQL query besides automatic operations
there are several built-in functions
like average sum count as well
date expression SQL date expressions are
used to compare and get date according
to its various date and time related
query and conditions they give date time
value as the output it can also return
current system date and time values also
now that we have understood what exactly
SQL expressions are let's execute them
in MySQL workbench with the help of
examples
as you can see SQL workbench has started
and before we get to the execution part
of various SQL Expressions we have to
first create a table so for that I've
already created a table named student
within the database simply code the
student table consists of various
columns such as roll number name of the
student age the city they belong to date
of birth the stream that they have
chosen and the total marks that they
have scored in the final exam and here
the primary key is roll number which
basically uniquely identifies each and
every record of the students in the
table
so now that we have created the table if
we want to retrieve the information of
all the students we'll use select
command so the following query would be
select
star
from the table name that is student
and semicolon
let us execute this
and as you can see all the records of
the students are being displayed that is
the name their age the city they belong
to the stream and also the total marks
that they have scored in the final exam
now that we have created table and
inserted values into the table let us
understand various SQL Expressions
firstly let us discuss about Boolean
expression
for that we'll take a simple example
from the table itself
suppose let's say you want to display
the records of those students from the
student table who belong to the city
Kochi for that we'll write the SQL query
as
select
star
from the table name that is student
where
CT
equals to Kochi
now let us execute this statement and
see the output
so as you can see there's a student
named Divya whose ages 21 Who belongs to
the city Kochi similarly you can find
for another cities as well so let us
take for Pune and execute this query
so the output would be uh it will show
the records of two students named Aman
and Indra who's having age 22 and 25 who
belong to the city Pune and having our
streams is triple and MBA and the total
Marxist 922 and 972.
so the Boolean expression not only
executes the values against the
character values which is in this case
is Pune but it can also take the values
of numerical values as well for example
let's say uh the university has got to
know the highest marks scored by an
individual in the final exam is 988 and
it wants to retrieve the details of that
student so for that the following query
would be
select
star
from table name that is student
where
total marks
is equals to 988
let us execute this query now
so as you can see a student named pratik
Who belongs to the stream CAC has scored
the highest marks 988 so in this way
Boolean expressions are used to perform
various operations which basically
evaluates a given condition to a
particular value or you can say a single
value and if the condition is true it
will return the output and display all
those records otherwise it won't
up next we have numeric Expressions
numeric expressions
so numeric expressions are basically
used to perform various mathematical
operations so let us understand this
with an example for instance let's say
the university has decided to change the
total marks weightage from 1000 to 500
and I'll specify a condition where I'll
take the total marks and divide them
into half and check all the students who
have scored more than 480 out of 500 for
that the following query would be select
star
from the table that is student
where
total marks
divided by 2
is greater than 480.
put a semicolon and let us execute this
so as you can see there are total four
students who have scored more than 480
when that when the total marks are
divided into half for instance if you
take the record of Rohan who has scored
total marks 977 and if you divided it by
2 that is approximately 488.5 which is
satisfying the condition which that is
greater than 480.
and if you look at this SQL statement
carefully there are a lot of SQL
Expressions here firstly the student
table name that is the student itself
because uh it is used to retrieve the
values from the columns that is uh here
the total marks is the column and we
also have the operands that is total
months divided by 2 and the right hand
operand that is 480 which can also be
considered as an SQL expression here
similarly we have other inbuilt
functions as we discussed earlier like
some average count minimum and maximum
let's say if you want to calculate the
average of total marks of each and every
student's code in the final exam the
following query would be
select
average which is the SQL function
and within the parenthesis
mentioned total marks
total marks
from the table that is M student
let us execute this
as you can see it is displaying the
total average of total marks that is 954
4.375
similarly you can calculate the sum of
all the marks of the students as well so
the query would be select sum
total marks
total marks from the student table
let us execute this
and this will be the following output
so there is a bit error in the code let
me check it once
so as you can see it is displaying the
sum of total marks that is
7635. so in this way you can use numeric
Expressions to perform various
operations on the SQL tables
and finally we have date expression
which basically returns date and time
values of the table say let's say if you
want to uh display the records of those
students who are born after 1995 January
so for that the following query would be
select star
from the table name that is student
where
date of birth is greater than
January 1st
so let us execute this query and see the
output
as you can see there are total of five
records of the students who are born
after January 1995.
similarly you can also display the
current date and time as well using the
current timestamp function that is
Select
current timestamp
current times done
and let us execute this query
so as you can see it will display the
current
year uh the date and the month format
similarly it is also displaying the your
time which is in the format of hours
minutes and seconds
so in this way you can use various
Expressions to query the database for a
specific set of data to retrieve the
information from the SQL firstly let us
discuss the agenda for today's session
we'll start the tutorial by
understanding what SQL databases are and
look at some popular SQL databases after
that we'll discuss how to create an SQL
database in MySQL workbench next we'll
see how to select the database in MySQL
and finally we'll discuss how to delete
the already created database as well
what is SQL database a database in
general is a collection of organized
data for easier access so that it can be
managed and stored effectively as far as
SQL databases are concerned a relational
database is used to store and manage all
the data in the form of tables simple
SQL queries are returned to retrieve the
data from these SQL database tables in a
nutshell you can see that SQL is used to
connect with the databases as it
directly interacts and communicates with
the database to retrieve the information
stored in tables
popular SQL databases some popular SQL
databases are MySQL Microsoft SQL Server
Oracle database postgro SQL and mongodb
these are some databases that are being
widely used nowadays by many companies
each of them function in their own way
and also the syntax of queries that are
written can also slightly vary from each
other as well
let us now discuss the first topic of
today's session that is SQL create
database in SQL creating a new database
is the first and foremost step to store
the data in the tables so in order to
create a database users must use create
database as a keyword in the syntax so
the syntax is followed as create
database that is the keyword that we are
using here followed by the name of the
database name
in the syntax database name specifies
the name of the database which you want
to create in the system also make sure
that the database you're creating has a
unique name and it does not match with
other databases as well for example if
you look at the following example I am
creating a database named student so the
syntax would be create database followed
by the database name that is student so
let us now run the syntax on MySQL
workbench and see how it is executed in
real time
as you can see MySQL has opened and if
you look carefully at the interface of
MySQL workbench on the left hand side
you will find schemas or the various
databases that are available in the
system at the center you'll find the SQL
editor where the queries are written and
at the bottom you will find the console
where you can see the status or the
output of the query that has been
executed so firstly let's go ahead and
discuss the first topic that is how to
create a database let's say if you want
to create a new database a project so
the create database statement would be
as followed
create database
that is the keyword that is used to
create a new database followed by that
we have to specify the database name
that is Project
put a semicolon and let us execute this
as you can see our database project has
been successfully executed and if you
refresh the schema you will find the
database name as project so in this way
you can create a new project and just
for confirmation if you want to check
the databases created or not you can
check it in the list of databases by
using show databases
keyword so let us see and execute this
so as you can see these are the various
databases that are available in the
system including our database project
that we have created earlier
let us now discuss our next topic that
is how to select a database
now that you have created a database now
the user wants to perform some
operations like creating a new table and
inserting values onto the existing
database in SQL for that firstly they
have to select the database on which
they want to run the database queries
without selecting the database they
cannot create a new table for instance
if I want to create a new table
that is student and when I execute this
query
it will throw an error stating that no
database selected select the default
database to be used so in this way you
won't be able to create a new table
without selecting the database any
database user can easily select the
particular database from the current
database server using the use keyword in
the SQL statement so the following
syntax would be use
followed by the database name
that you want to select for example let
us take for instance if I want to work
on the database project so the following
query would be
use
project which is the
database name here let us execute this
so as you can see the query has been
successfully executed and
also you can find the database name
project is highlighted in a bold that
means you have successfully selected the
database and you can start creating your
new tables
so in this way when you have multiple
databases in your SQL schema before
starting your operations you have to
select a database where all the
operations would be performed also keep
in mind that the database that you are
selecting should be unique
finally let us look at how to drop the
database
in other words dropping a database is to
delete a database the SQL drop database
statement deletes the existing database
permanently from the database system
that means the statement deletes all the
data and the tables that are stored in
the database so let us now look at the
syntax of the drop database the syntax
is followed as drop database
followed by the database name that is
Project
here in SQL syntax we have specified the
name of the database which we want to
delete permanently from the database
system after the drop database keyword
and let us execute this and see the
output
as you can see the database has been
dropped and even at the left hand side
if you look at the schemas uh database
project has been deleted successfully
so in this way you can delete a database
using drop database statement but be
careful before using this operation
because by deleting an existing database
it would result in complete loss of
information stored in the database we'll
understand how data is stored in the
form of tables in SQL and also discuss
some basic SQL queries related to these
tables firstly let us discuss the agenda
for today's session we'll start the
tutorial by understanding what is SQL
table and then we'll look at how to
create a table after that we'll see how
to drop a table followed by that we'll
see how to insert a new value into the
table and then we look how to delete a
table after that we'll see how to
truncate a particular table and then
we'll discuss how to alter an existing
Table after that we'll see how to rename
an existing table finally we look at how
to copy a new table
what is SQL table tables are the
essential elements of a database and in
particular for relational databases as
it is one of the most used data models
to store and retrieve data from tables
tables are basically an organized
collection of data that consists of rows
and columns another point to be noted is
that a table has a specified number of
columns but can have any number of rows
let us understand this with an example
here the name of the table is taken as
an employee and in SQL naming a table is
very important because before performing
any operation you have to specify the
name also the name of the table should
be unique and it should not match with
other tables in the database the
horizontal values represented in the
tables are called as rows or tuples and
each row represents a unique record
similarly the vertical values represent
columns or the attributes of that
particular table and each column
represents a unique field in the record
as we can see in the table employee ID
employee name job department number
salary are the various fields or the
column names the data in this multiple
columns such as the employee name Rohan
who's having employed 2011 who is
working as a data analyst belong to the
department three and having salary 50
000 is stored in the form of rows
I hope you've understood what is an SQL
table now so let us now discuss some
basic SQL queries that are performed on
these tables and execute them in MySQL
workbench as well
SQL create table
SQL create table is foremost thing to do
in SQL if you want to create a table you
should name the table and Define its
columns and each columns data type let
us now look at the syntax of create
table the syntax is followed as create
table which is the keyword used here
followed by that we have to mention the
table name and within the parenthesis
you have to mention the column names
followed by that you have to mention the
data type in this way you can add a
number of columns as per your choice now
that we have understood the syntax let
us jump into MySQL workbench and execute
this
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scaleup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and on the left side you can see
that simply code is the database which
we are working on and in that database
we are going to create a new table so
let us now look at the syntax of create
a table so the syntax is followed as
create table which is the keyword we are
using followed by that we have to
specify the table name that is we have
taken employee in this case and within
the brackets or the parenthesis you have
to mention the column names followed by
that you have to mention the data types
here I have taken column names as ID
name City job and salary
and finally I have chosen the primary
key as ID because it uniquely identifies
each and every record in the table
in the end you have to close the
brackets and mention semicolon let us
now execute this query and see the
output
as you can see our table is successfully
created so in order to display the
values or whether or not our table is
created or not we have we have the query
as select
star
from the table name that is employee
let us execute this and see the output
as you can see the table is created and
it is showing the column names as ID
name CT job and salary so in this way
you can create a new table
next let us discuss about dropped table
drop table in other words is basically
is to delete a table the SQL drop table
statement is used to remove the table
definition and the overall structure of
the existing table be careful that while
using this command because once a table
is deleted then all the information
available in the data will also be lost
forever the Syntax for the drop table is
drop table and then you have to mention
the table name
so let us now look at the example now
for some reasons if I want to delete the
employee table so the syntax would be
drop table
followed by that the name of the table
that is employee let us execute this
as you can see our table is completely
dropped and let us now see if it is
actually deleted or not for that we'll
use select statement
select star
from the table name that is employee
let me execute this query
as you can see it is throwing an error
stating that table simplyco.employ does
not exist this means you've successfully
deleted the existing table employee
let us now discuss the next topic that
is SQL insert table SQL insert statement
is used to add new rows of data into a
table this can be a single or multiple
records into the database the Syntax for
the insert table is insert into which is
the keyword followed by that table name
and within the parenthesis you have to
mention the column names values and
again within the parenthesis you have to
mention the values so here the column
one column two column 3 and in number of
columns are the names of the columns in
which the table you want to insert the
data into you may not need to specify
the column names in the SQL query if you
are adding values for all the columns of
the table but make sure the order of the
values is in the same order as the
column in the table
let us jump into the execution part now
I'm taking the same name that is
employee table to insert the new values
so the Syntax for inserting new values
into the table is followed as insert
into table name that is employee and
within the brackets we have to mention
the columns that we have taken earlier
that is ID name City job and salary
after that we have to mention the values
using the values keyword So within the
brackets I'm mentioning the ID name
as101 name as Rohan the city that he
belongs to is Hyderabad and the job that
he does is Da that is data analyst and
the salary that he earns is 40 000 so
let me execute this query and see the
output
so as you can see our query has been
successfully implemented now let us
display the results by using select
query again let me select this whole
query and execute this
as you can see the details of employee
name that is Rohan whose ID is for not
one and is the CD he belongs to
Hyderabad his job data analyst his
salary 40 000 is being successfully
displayed so in this way you can insert
new values into the table
up next let us discuss about delete
table in SQL delete table in SQL is used
to remove rows from a table this can be
a complete Row from an existing table or
a specific row if you want to remove a
specific Row from a table you should use
where condition but if you do not
specify the where condition here it will
remove all the rows from the table the
Syntax for delete statement is delete
from the table name
so let us take an example now suppose if
I want to delete the records of the
employee who is having employee ID as
102 in the table employee so the
following query would be
delete
from table name that is employee
specify the where condition
keyword that is where
ID is equals to 1.2
let us execute this statement now
as you can see our statement has been
successfully executed now I'll display
the records by using select statement
as you can see the employee ID who's
having uh one or two has his employee ID
has been successfully deleted from the
table so in this way you can use direct
statement to delete a particular record
from the table
foreign let us now discuss about
truncate table in SQL trunkey table
statement is used to remove all the rows
from the table that means it deletes the
complete data from an existing table it
is similar to that of delete statement
but here we do not use the where Clause
trunky table is faster and uses lesser
resources than the delete table command
as it deletes the records at a single
time drop table command can also be used
to delete the complete data but it also
deletes the structure of the table as
well truncate table does not delete the
structure of the data so the Syntax for
truncate table is truncate table
and after that you have to mention the
table name
so if I want to delete all the records
from the employee table the following
query would be
truncate
table
followed by that you have to mention the
table name that is employee
let us execute this and see the output
so the query has been successfully
executed so let me use the select
statement to display the records
as you can see uh all the information of
the employee has been successfully
deleted from the table but if you look
at uh the output closely the structure
hasn't been deleted here the column
names of the table that is ID name City
job and salary have been retained but
only the values in the table have been
deleted so in this way you can use
truncate statement to delete all the
records from the table at a single time
make sure that uh you use this statement
carefully because the rollback process
is not possible after using truncate's
table statement that means if the data
is once deleted it is completely deleted
uh permanently
next let us discuss about SQL alter
table the order table in SQL
is used to add modify and delete Columns
of an existing table
in many situations you may require to
add columns in the existing table so
instead of creating a whole table again
and again you can easily add single or
multiple columns using alter table
statement with the help of a keyword add
let us now look at the syntax of alter
table the syntax is followed as alter
table table name add and within the
parenthesis you have to mention the new
column and the data type so let us now
jump into the execution part
consider the same table employee again
suppose if you want to add a new column
that is date of birth of the employee in
the above table for this you have to
type the following query as
alter table
mention the table name that is employee
after that mention the keyword add
and within the brackets mention the new
column name that is date of birth and
the data type of the date of birth is
date so I'll be mentioning the date data
type
close the brackets and put the semicolon
let us execute this statement now
as you can see our statement has been
successfully implemented and I'll use
the select statement to display the new
records
as you can see there's a new column
named date of birth has been
successfully added to our existing table
employee in this way you can use alter
table to add or delete the columns from
the table
let us now discuss about SQL rename
table
SQL rename table is used in SQL to
change the name of the table so in some
situations the database user might want
to change the name of the table so that
they want to give a more relevant name
or the updated name to the table any
database user can easily change the name
of the table by using rename table and
alter table statement in SQL let us look
at the syntax now the syntax is followed
as alter table
current Table name rename to new table
name
let us now execute this in MySQL
workbench
consider the same table employee again
and suppose if you want to change the
name of the above table employee into
let's say employee new for this you have
to type the following query that is
Alter
table
old table name that is employee
rename to is the keyword that you have
to use here
and mention the new table name we are
taking employee
new Azar new table name so let us
execute this and see the output
as you can see our statement has been
successfully executed so let let us
update the schema here and see whether
or not the name of the table is changed
so as you can see our table employee
which we had previously has been changed
into employee new in this way you can
use rename statement to give a new name
to your existing table
finally let us now look at SQL copy
table statement if you want to copy
the data of one sqlt will into another
SQL table in the same SQL database then
it is possible by using the select into
statement in SQL the select into
statement in SQL copies the content from
an existing table into a new table SQL
creates the new table by using the
structure of the existing table the
syntax is followed as select star into
new table name from the old table name
let us now execute this in MySQL
workbench and see the output
consider the same employee table again
and suppose you want to copy the content
of the employee table into a new table
let's say employee details now as far as
MySQL workbench is concerned there is a
slight change in the query now the
syntax that we've discussed earlier is
applicable to some other SQL databases
like Microsoft SQL server and Oracle
database but for MySQL workbench there
is a different syntax to copy a new
table so the syntax is followed as
create
table
mention the new table name that is
employee details
now select
star
from the old table name that is employee
let us now execute this and see the
output
now it will throw an error stating that
the employee table doesn't exist that's
because we have renamed our previous
employee name table into employee new so
instead of employee change it to employ
new and let us execute this statement
now
so
to in order to display if the employee
table is created successfully or not in
the database let us use select statement
to display the records select star from
the table name which is the new table
name that is employee
details
let us execute this now
as you can see uh the details that we
had earlier in our employee new table
has been copied into another table that
is employee details in this way you can
copy the content from one table existing
table from another new table by using
copy statement in SQL
and with that we have come to end of
today's session these were some of the
queries that were related to SQL tables
if you want to learn more about SQL make
sure to check out our previous playlist
in our Channel also we have a dedicated
video SQL full course 2022 for beginners
wherein we have discussed SQL and
various Concepts from the scratch
firstly let us discuss the agenda for
today's session we'll start the tutorial
by understanding what is SQL select
statement and then we'll discuss the
syntax of SQL select statement and
finally we'll go through some different
functions in SQL select statement
what is SQL select statement SQL select
statement is used to fetch the data from
a database table which Returns the data
in a form of a resultant table in simple
words we can say that it is used to
access the information from one or more
database tables within the database
let's look at the syntax of SQL select
statement the syntax is followed as
select column from table name in the
select syntax you can see column name 1
column name 2 and N number of columns
are the name of those columns in the
table whose data you wanted to read
and if you want to access all the rows
from all the fields of the table you can
use the select star operator in the
database by using select star from table
name command
let us look an example if you want to
retrieve the information of the student
who is having roll number name and age
we can write a simple query as select
roll number name age from student in
this way we can display the details of
the student
SQL select condition
select statement is used with various
Clauses as well that means it also
retrieves the selected data that follows
a particular condition with the help of
a where Clause by using this command we
can access a particular record from a
particular column of the table let's
understand this with an example consider
the employee table here which is having
ID name age City and salary as its
column in the table
let's say if you want to access the
information of those employees who's
having age as 29. for that we'll write a
simple query as select star from
employee where age is equals to 29 and
if you execute this this will be the
following output which shows the
information of those employees whose age
is 29 so in this way you can use SQL
select condition by specifying a where
statement which is used to filter the
data in a particular table
now that we have understood the basics
of SQL select statement let us now jump
into MySQL workbench and execute this
and understand it in in a more better
way
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and for timing I've already
created a table employee which is having
column names as employee ID employee
name age designation date of birth city
that they belong to and salary and I've
chosen primary key as Employer ID
because it uniquely identifies each and
every record in the table
now that we've created a table in order
to display all these records we have to
use this select statement ultimately so
to display all the values from each
column of the table that is the employee
table we have to write the following
query as select
star
from table name that is employee
let us execute this and see the output
as you can see it will display all the
values of the employees their employee
ID employee name age designation date of
birth the city and their respective
salaries
so if you want to display a particular
column so for that you have to write the
query as let's say if I want to select
employee ID employee name and the city
uh of the employees so for that I'll
write select
employee ID
comma
employee name
comma let's say I want to display the
salary so I'm taking a salary
from
table name
that is employee
let us execute this now
foreign
so as you can see only the employee ID
employee name and the salary of the
employees in the table are being shown
here because we have only specified a
particular column in this case
now similarly we can use where clause
also the where plus is used with select
statement to return only those rows from
the table which satisfy the specified
condition in the query
for example uh if I want to show the
salary of the employee who is having uh
more than thirty thousand so for that
I'll write the query as select
star
from employee
where
salary
is greater than 30 000.
so let us execute this statement and see
the output so as you can see it will
display the records of all those
employees who's having salary more than
30 000.
similarly you can see uh you can also
check
whether the city that they belong to is
Mumbai so for that we have to take the
SQL query as
so let's start from employee where city
is equals to suppose I want to display
the employee who belongs to the city
Mumbai so for that I'll take the city as
Mumbai and execute this statement
okay uh you have to mention Mumbai in a
single quotes so that's the reason it is
showing error here
so let us now execute this and see the
output
so as you can see there are only two
employees who belong to the city uh that
is the employee kavya and Pavan who's
having the employee ID 103 and 109. so
in this where you can use select
statement uh to display a particular uh
record by using work loss
now that we've got an idea on how SQL
select statement works let us now
discuss some select statement functions
the first one is Select
distinct
the select distinct in SQL is used to
fetch identical or distinct column
values from existing table without any
duplicate values now suppose in a
particular table there might be a higher
chance that there exists a duplicate
value and if you want to retrieve only
unique values in such scenario you use a
SQL select listing statement I know it
might be a bit confusing so let me make
it clear to you guys uh consider the
same employee table again here
and uh if you look at the table
the values in the column City the
Hyderabad has been repeated more than
once year and not just Hyderabad Chennai
has also been repeated twice so in this
case in a broader sense if I just wanted
to know from which city the employee is
from I'll just use the distinct select
statement so using this uh
instead of multiple uh values that are
being displayed the SQL distance
statement make sure that the value is
retrieved only once and there is no room
for any repeated or distinct value so
let us now understand this syntax with
an example the syntax is followed as
select
distinct
now let's say if I want to fetch a
distinct designation of all the
employees of the company so for that I
am specifying the column name here as
designation
from the table that is employee
let us now execute this
uh there is a bit error in the code let
me just check it
foreign
so let us execute the query now and see
the output
so as you can see this is the output
that is being displayed where the unique
values
of the designation of all the employees
have been displayed that is business
analyst manager HR SD and so on so in
this way by using SQL select distinct
statement we can fetch distinct values
from the existing table
let us now discuss about select count
statement in SQL the select count is
used to get the total number of rows
from a table basically it Returns the
total number of Records present in the
database table let's take a simple
example consider the same employee table
now if you have a record in the table
and if you want to count the total
number of uh Records in the table for
that the following query would be
select
count
star
from the table name that is employee
let us execute this and see the output
now
so as you can see there are total 15
records present in the employee table
similarly you can use the where
condition as well if you want to get the
uh total number of rows of the employees
who are having salary equals to 50 000
in the employee table so for that the
following query would be select
count
asterisk
from employee
specify the condition here now where
salary
is equals to fifty thousand
let us execute this statement now
so as you can see there are total three
employees who are having salary equals
to fifty thousand
similarly you can get the total number
of rows in a table by using the distinct
statement as well let's say if you want
to retrieve a unique count of the city
of the employees from the table the
following query would be select count
which is the keyword that we are using
and inside the bracket mentioned
distinct keyword
followed by the column name that is City
from the table that is employed
now let us execute this statement and
see the output
so as you can see there are total uh
eight employees who are belong to
different cities so in this way you can
use a select con statement to retrieve
various number of Records in a
particular table
next let us discuss about select top or
limit
statement in SQL the select top
statement in SQL shows The Limited
number of Records or rows from the
database table the top clause in the
statement specifies how many rows we
want to display from our table this
Clause is used when there are thousands
of Records stored in the database table
now all database systems do not support
top keyword now as far as MySQL is
concerned it supports the limit keyword
so let us now look at the syntax of
Select limit statement the syntax is
followed as
select
star
from
employee table
limit is the keyword that we have to use
and I want to display the first three
records of the employees so I'm
specifying three here
so let us execute this statement
so as you can see the first three
records of the employees who are having
ID employee ID as one not one one or two
one or three are being displayed
let us consider another scenario here if
you want to fix the first three
employees who got highest salaries from
the employee table then the following
query would be
select
star
from
the table name that is employee
ordered by
is the condition that I am using to
display the employee details
salary
desc that means descending now I want to
display the records in the descending
order and I am limiting the value up to
2.
limit three
so let us execute the statement now
so as you can see it will display a
total of three Records who are having
the salary uh who got the highest salary
in the descending order that is Kamal
who got the salary as 60 000 Sindhu
having 50 000 and Kiran who is having 50
000. so in this way you can use limit
statement to display the specified rows
that is the top rows in the table
next let us discuss about select random
statement in SQL as the name suggests
SQL select random statement is used to
return a random Row from a table present
in the database it has many real life
applications for example if a HR manager
wants to send uh 10 random mails to his
employees then he can use random
function in SQL to send the email it is
also used to display random questions
during an online exams for students so
the syntax for select random is followed
as
select
column name now I want to display the
records of all the employees so I am
choosing star operator
from the table that is employee
order by is the conditional Clause we
have to use
followed by that we have to mention Rand
which is the function
let us execute this statement
so as you can see the details of the
employees are being displayed in a mixed
manner that is they are displayed in a
random way as you can see the employee
details of employee who is having ID 1
114 is being displayed your first and
then one to well and then one for note
3. so in this way you can display the
values randomly using random function in
SQL similarly you can limit the values
as well if you want to show the top
three random values of the employees you
can use limit statement here so limit
and if I want to display the first four
records of the employees so I am
choosing four
let us execute the statement now
so it will show the details of the
employees randomly up to uh four that is
the top four details of the employees so
in this way you can use a random
statement to display uh random values
within a database table
next let us discuss about select in
statement in SQL the select in function
is used to fetch specific rows or values
from an existing table with multiple
conditions the conditions are specified
within Clause the operation of Select in
is same as R operation select in is used
to reduce the multiple or operators in
select statement let us understand this
with an example so if I want if I see
details of employees who are having
employee ID as let's say one or two or
one not four or one or seven from the
employee table then the following query
would be select
star
from the table that is employee
where
employee ID
now we have to mention the in keyword
here and within the brackets mention the
IDS so I am taking one or two
or not 4
and 1.7
so let us execute this statement and see
the output
so as you can see it is displaying the
values of the employees who are having
ID either one or two or one not four or
one not seven
next let us discuss about select date
statement in SQL SQL select date is used
to retrieve the values of date from a
database if you want to find a
particular date from a database you can
use this statement so let us understand
with an example let's say if you want to
display the records of all those
employees who are born before 1995 Jan
first so the following query would be
select
star
from the table that is employee
where
date of birth
is less than
Jan first
make sure you incorporate the date in
the single quotes otherwise it will
throw an error so let me execute this
statement
so as you can see it is displaying the
records of all those employees who are
born before 1995 Jan first similarly you
can use uh greater than operator as well
to show the employees who are born after
1995. similarly uh if you want to fetch
the employees who have bond between a
particular date let's say who are born
between 1996 and 1998 then the foreign
query would be select start from
employee where date of birth
between is the keyword we have to use
between let's say I'm using
1996 Jan first
and 1998.
1998 Jan first
so let me execute this statement and see
the output
so as you can see it is displaying the
records of all those employees who are
born in between uh the particular date
that we have given that is in between
1996 and 1998. so in this way you can
use the select date statement to
retrieve the date values in the database
next let us discuss about select some
statement in SQL select sum is used to
return the sum of all the values in a
specified column now you have to make a
note here that some sum function is
applied only on numeric or numeric
related fields let us consider the same
employee table again and if you want to
get the sum of all the employee salaries
in the employee table then the following
query would be select
sum as the keyword and within the
brackets mentioned the salary column
from the table that is employee
let us execute this statement and see
the output
so as you can see it is showing the sum
of the service of all the employees here
that is 6 lakh 5000 is the total value
of the combined salary of all the
employees similarly you can use the
where condition here as well uh to get
the sum of the salaries of employee by
specifying a condition let's say if I
want to get the total salary of all
those employees who belong to the city
Mumbai so for that I am writing the
query as select some salary from
employee where is the conditional clause
City
equals to Mumbai
make sure Mumbai is in single coach
otherwise it will throw an error so let
us execute the statement now and see the
output
so as you can see it is displaying the
uh sum of all the salaries of those
employees belonging to Mumbai as 80 000.
so in this way you can use the uh some
select sum statement in SQL to display
the sum of values in a particular column
and finally let us now look at the
select null statement in SQL null in a
table represents that the field has no
value these null values are used to
represent the missing data in a
particular table now a null value is
different from a zero value that means a
field with a null value is the one that
has been left blank during the record
creation Now to verify the column value
is null or not we can use the keyword is
null or is not null now we should make a
note here that null value can't compare
with operators like equals to greater
than or less than so let us take an
example to understand the syntax now if
you want to fetch the details of the
students uh whose marks Arnel that means
the marks that they have scored in the
final exam are yet to be assigned to the
students so for that the following query
would be
uh select
select
star
from the table that is student
where is the condition
marks
is null which is the keyword we are
using so let us execute this statement
and see the output
so as you can see there are two students
whose marks are yet to be updated and it
also means that their marks are not
equals to zero it's simply that their
marks have been left out and kept as
null at the tutorial by understanding
what SQL Clauses next we'll go through
different types of SQL Clauses and
finally we'll discuss about SQL where
clause and execute MySQL workbench
what is SQL Clause SQL Clause are
basically inbuilt SQL functions that use
a certain conditional expression which
helps to access a particular set of
records from the database table Clauses
help us to restrict and manage the data
using valid constraints on the data in
our database now since we have large
amounts of data stored in the database
we use Clauses to query the table to get
the desired data only so the complexity
is reduced when condition is applied to
an SQL statement
SQL Clauses use filters and analyzes the
data quickly because it is used to
extract only those records that fulfill
the specified condition
types of SQL Clauses SQL Clauses are
divided into three types the first one
is the basic clause which uses a
condition the second one is order by
which is used to sort the data in tables
in either ascending or descending order
and the last one is Group by which is
used for organizing similar data into
groups
SQL where Clause SQL where Clause is the
most used and integral part of any query
to specify a condition in SQL statement
which retrieves only those records which
satisfy the given condition the where
Clause is not only used in the select
statement but it is also used in the
update delete statement Etc using
logical and comparison operators like
greater than less than and equal to
operators let us now look at the syntax
of where Clause the syntax is followed
as select column 1 column 2 and up to n
number of columns from table name where
condition here column and column 2
represents the columns which we want to
fetch the data from the table and the
condition here represents the required
condition to fetch rows based on the
requirement it contains column name
operator user defined value comparison
and logical operators are also used in
this condition
so in this way we can use where clause
let us now execute some statement which
uses where clause in MySQL workbench
as you can see the MySQL workbench has
started and before we write queries
using a wire Clause we have to first
create a table so I have created a table
here employee which is columns employee
ID employee name age destination date of
birth the city they belong to and their
salary and I've taken primary key here
as employee ID because it uniquely
identifies each and every record in the
table
now that we've created the table let us
now look at the simple and basic query
using the where Clause now let's say if
I want to display the details of all
those employees who belong to the city
Mumbai so for that the following query
would be select
star
from the table that is employee
now we have to mention the condition
that is the where Clause where
City
is equals to Mumbai
mention Mumbai in single quotes
otherwise it will show an error so let
us now execute this statement and see
the output
now when you execute the statement it
will show me the output of two employees
who belong to the city so let us now
take another example now we'll use the
greater than operator using the where
Clause now let's say if I want to
display the details of all those
employees whose salary is greater than
30 000 so for that the following query
would be select star
from table that is employee where
salary is greater than 30 000.
so let us execute the statement
now when we execute the statement it
will show me the records of all those
employees who are having salary more
than 30 000 now I think here we have
around uh
15 since we have 15 uh Records in the
table we have a total of eight employees
whose salary is more than thirty
thousand so in this way you can use a
greater than operator similarly you can
use the less than operator as well and
let us see the output
whose salary is less than 35 000 will
take 35 000 here
and now see the output
so there are uh total three employees
who are having the salary less than 35
000 that is uh Aryan Preeti Akil who are
having salary as thirty thousand so in
this way you can use less than operator
as well now let us make another scenario
now if I want to mention a range of
salaries of how much they earn let's say
if I want to display the records of all
those employees who are earning salary
between 35 000 and 50 000. so for that
the following query would be select
star
from the table
that is employee where
salary
between is the keyword we have to use
here
and
50 000.
let us now execute this statement and
see the output
so now these are all the uh records of
the employees who are having salary in
between 35 000 and 15 000. so in this
way you can use uh various comparison
operators to perform uh queries using
where Clause similarly uh you can also
update the values in the table as well
using the update command let's say if I
want to update the salary of employee
whose employee ID is uh one not four so
for that the following query would be
update
table name that is employee
set is the keyword we have to use here
salary
now I want to change the salary as uh 25
000 so I am choosing twenty five
thousand
specify the condition where
employee ID is equals to uh one not six
so let us execute the statement and see
the output
so as you can see our query successfully
implemented and the employee who ID 106
who's having salary like before he used
to have some salary now his salary is
changed into 25 000. so let us see
whether it is changed or not we'll use
the select command again to display the
details of all the employees so for that
the query would be select star
from the table that is employed
let us now execute the statement
so 106 uh employee name is varsha who's
working as a software developer and
salary has been changed to 25 000 so in
this way you can use where Clause to
perform various operations using certain
conditions
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now that we have understood how to write
a query using the where condition let us
now look at some other conditional
statements which uses where Clause first
let us discuss about SQL and condition
SQL and condition is used to specify
multiple condition in where clause and
condition basically Returns the rows or
those values that satisfies both the
conditions that are written after the
where clause in simple terms you can say
that it will only return those values
when both the conditions are met let us
now understand this with an example
let's say if I want to access the
records of all those employees whose
designation is business analyst and
their salary is 35 000. for that the
following query would be select star
from the table that is employee
where I am specifying the condition here
designation
is equals to
business analyst
and
is the keyword that we have to specify
here
salary
is equals to 35 000.
let us execute the statement now
so as you can see it is displaying the
records of two employees whose
designation is business analyst and
their salary is 35 000 but if you look
at the uh employee table carefully let
me just display the values uh there is
the employee ID 101 Who belongs to the
designation business analyst and then
similarly we have another employee who's
employed is one not nine and whose
employed is 111 here we have three
records but instead it is displaying
only three or two records that's because
there's an employee ID 109 who's having
Who belongs to the designation business
analyst that is having forty thousand so
in this case he is not meeting the other
condition that is why it is being
displayed only two values
so in this way you can use and statement
to filter the records from the table let
us now look at the next statement that
is R SQL or condition is used to specify
again the same multiple conditions in
where clause which is used to fetch the
rows or values which satisfy any of the
condition now unlike uh and statement if
any of the condition that is provided is
true then it will return all those
values so let me just uh
execute this with an uh example let's
say if I want to access the records of
all those employees whose designation is
manager and the city that they belong to
is Chennai so for that I'll write the
query as select star
from the table that is
employee
where
designation
is equals to manager
or
the city that they belong to is Chennai
so let me just execute this statement
and see the output
so when execute this statement it will
show a total of three records of all
those employees whose designation is
either manager or the city that they
belong to is Chennai now we have uh the
records of employee who belongs to City
Bangalore indoor as well but it is
showing here because the designation is
manager that is here it is satisfying
either one of the condition that is
either the designation that is manager
or the city that they belong to is
Chennai so in this way you can use our
statement to filter the records
next let us discuss about the limit
condition in SQL the limit condition is
used to fetch those records that have
only limited number of values let's say
if I want to access the records of first
five employees from the table then I'll
write the following query as select star
from the table that is employee
now we have to mention the keyword limit
now I want to access the records of
first five employees so I am specifying
5 as the condition here so let me
execute this statement so it will
display the first five records of the
employees from the employee table now
this limit condition is used like when
you have thousands of Records in a table
and if you want to access the first 100
records of the employees then you can
use the limit condition here with the
example
next let us discuss about SQL as
condition statement now SQL as condition
is used to rename a column temporarily
in a given table now in simple words we
can say that SQL as keyword is used to
given Alias name to the table or column
name in the query and in this way we can
increase the readability and
understandability of the query and call
and also the column headings in the
table so let us understand with an
example let's say if I want to change
the column name of salary to the total
salary then I would write the following
query as select
salary
as
within the single quotes mention the new
column name that is total salary
from the table that is employed
so let us execute this statement and see
the output
so as you can see salary has been
changed into a total salary in this way
you can use the and condition statement
to change the column of the table
temporarily
and finally let us discuss the like
statement in SQL the like condition
statement is used to fetch matching rows
or values from the table that satisfies
the wildcard operator now the Wild Card
operator in SQL uh basically have two
types the first one is percentage sign
the percentage sign represents a single
or multiple character and the second one
is underscore underscore represents a
single number or character now you might
be a bit confused here so let me just
explain with an example let's say if you
want to access the records of all those
employees whose name starts with k so
for that I'll write the query as select
star from the table that is
employee now specify the condition where
employee name
like is the keyword we have to use here
and within the single quotes now we are
displaying the records of employees
whose name starts with k right so I am
taking K and mention the percentage
symbol
so let us execute this statement and see
the output
foreign
details of all those employees whose
name starts with k so there are total uh
three employees in the table whose name
starts with care similarly if you want
to display the records of those
employees whose name ends with a so for
that we have to mention percentage a so
let me just execute this statement and
see the output
so it will display the values of all
those employees whose name is ending
with the letter A so there are total uh
five employees in the table whose name
is ending with a so in this way you can
use the like operator which also uses
the where Clause I'll start the tutorial
by understanding what is SQL order by
and then we'll discuss the syntax of SQL
order by and finally we look at some
order by statements and execute them in
MySQL workbench
so what is order by Clause the SQL order
by Clause allows you to sort the results
of a query based on a specific column or
group of columns that means it helps you
to reorder the data that is present in
the tables in one or more columns now
this sorting can be either ascending or
descending order let us now understand
the syntax of SQL order by Clause the
syntax is followed as SQL select column
1 column 2 up to n number of columns
from table name where condition order by
column AC or DAC so let me just explain
the syntax the column specified after
the order by keyword specifies the name
of the columns that are used to sort
data and after that we use two keywords
that is AC to represent the data in
ascending manner or dese to represent
the data in descending order
now the reason for using the order by
Clause is that the order that the data
shows in a database table is completely
random and sometimes this might not be
the order in which you would like to see
when we run our queries in the database
so for that purpose we use order by
Clause now that we've understood what
the SQL order by Clauses let us jump
into the execution part
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and on the left side you can
view the database simply code which has
two tables that is employee and student
we are going to work on the employee
table now so first let me display the
records of all the employee details
present in the employee table for that I
am going to use this select statement
select star
from the table name that is employee
let me just execute this statement
so it will show me the results of
details of all the employees with their
employee ID employee name age
destination date of birth CT they belong
to and the salary they have so let us
just understand the basic query of order
by Clause now so the syntax is followed
as select
star
from the table that is employee
order by
salary
now this is a basic statement related to
order by and let us execute this so it
will display the output and in a
particular order of the salary and if
you look at carefully it is displaying
in the uh ascending order now if no
keyword is specified after the column
based on which we have sorted the
records in our table the Sorting will be
done by default in ascending order so
with that uh that brings us to the to
our first order by statement that is
order by ascending
statement now the order by ascending
statement is used to sort the data in
ascending order so let us consider
another example here now if I want to
fetch the details of all the employees
uh and their employee names in ascending
order for that the following query would
be select
star
from the table that is employee
order by
employee name and mention the keyword
ASC
so let us execute this statement and see
the output so it will display the
results the employee names in the
ascending order that is in alphabetical
order starting from aakash
and up until V so in this way you can
use the order by ascending statement to
display all your records in ascending
manner
similarly you can specify the where
condition here as well
let's say if I want to fetch the details
of all the employees from the employee
table in ascending order of their uh
employee name whose age is greater than
26. so for that the following query
would be select start from employee
where age greater than 26 order by
employee name as an ASC so let me
execute this statement so it will
display the records of all those
employees whose age is more than 26 and
it'll this uh it will sort the data of
employee names in ascending order
so in this way you can use the order by
ascending
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now let us discuss about order by
descending statement the order by
descending statement is used to sort the
data in the descending order let us
understand this with an example let's
say if I want to display the details of
all the employees from the employee
table in descending order of their
salaries for that the following query
would be select star
from the table that is employee
order by
salary
and mention the keyword Des
so let us execute this statement and see
the output
so this will be the following output
wherein it will show the salaries of all
the employees in the descending order
that is from highest to lowest in this
case the first employee who is having
the highest salary is 65 000 and up
until the lowest salary 25 000. also
similarly you can specify the wear
condition here also so if you want to
display the details of employees whose
employee ID is greater than let's say
one or six and want to sort their
service and descending order for that
I'll use the query as select start from
employee so mention the keyword where
employee ID
greater than
106.
so let us execute this statement and see
the output
so it will display the records of all
those employees uh who's having employed
in more than one or six and it will sort
the data of their salaries in descending
order that is from highest lowest again
so in this way you can use the order by
descending statement to display all your
records present in the table in an
ascending manner
let us now discuss the next order by
statement that is SQL order by random
and as well as limit statements the
order by random statement is used to
display the records uh present in the
table randomly and the Syntax for the
order by random is Select
star
from the table that is employee
order by mention the keyword
random is the function we are using here
so we have to mention R A indeed
and let us execute the statement now so
it will display the records present in
the table in an in a random order
similarly we also have a limit statement
which is used to display only a specific
number of columns in the database table
so let us now look at the syntax of
order by limit
now let's say if I want to fetch the
first uh six employee details from the
table in descending order of their
salaries so the following query would be
select star
from employee
order by
salary I want to display the salaries in
descending order so I'm specifying the
desc keyword
and uh I'm limit I'm using the limit
function here
so let us display the output of this
query
so it will show me the random uh six
details of the employees in order of
their salaries from highest to lowest
that is in a descending order so in this
way you can also use order by random and
limit statement in your SQL queries
and finally let us now discuss about the
order by multiple statement in SQL till
now we have discussed only how to uh
fetch the records from only a single
table and sort them out but you can
fetch the rows by sorting multiple rows
in either ascending or descending order
using order by multiple statement so let
us understand this is an example let's
say if you want to fetch the details of
all the employees from the table in
ascending order of the designation as
well as descending order of their salary
then the following query would be select
star
from employee
order by
so we're taking the designation as
ascending order so designation
mention the keyword ASC
comma
and their salary
in descending manner so let us display
the uh
statement
so as you can see it will display the
designation in ascending order that is
business analyst and then customer care
data analyst HR and so on and their
respective salaries in descending form
so in this way you can fetch the our
data from multiple rows using the
multiple statement in SQL
firstly we'll start the tutorial by
understanding what is SQL insert and
then we'll understand the syntax of SQL
insert statement and finally we'll go
through some of the SQL insert
statements and execute them in MySQL
workbench
so what is SQL insert statement SQL
insert statement is widely used command
in SQL which is a part of data
manipulation language DML used by
various relational databases the insert
command is used for inserting one or
more rows into a database table with
specified table column values let us now
understand the Syntax for insert
statement
now we have two types of syntaxes the
first method is insert into table name
values and within the brackets you have
to mention the values in this first
method there is no need to specify the
column names where the data will be
inserted you need to only insert their
values the second method specifies both
the column name and the values which you
want to insert and the syntax is insert
into which is the keyword we are using
after that we have to mention the table
name and within the brackets we have to
mention the columns and then values
values one values to values three and so
on up to our requirement so this was the
syntax let us take an example now let's
say I've created a table students and I
want to insert values into it so the
Syntax for inserting the values is
insert into table name I am taking here
it as students and I'm mentioning The
Columns row number name age City and I
mean inserting the values as roll number
as 1 name as Rohan age as 22 and CTS
Hyderabad so in this way you can insert
values up to n number of rows into your
table so now that we've understood and
got an idea of what SQL insert statement
is let us jump into MySQL workbench and
do the execution part choose from over
300 in-demand skills and get access to
1000 plus hours of video content for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and
create a table and the syntax is
followed as create table which is the
keyword that we use and I am creating a
new table that is customer and which is
column names as customer ID customer
name their age address the product they
have purchased on the purchase date of
the product and I'm taking primary key
here as customer ID because it uniquely
identifies each and every record so let
me just use the select statement to
display whether the stable is created or
not select star
from the table that is customer
so as you can see our table is
successfully created with the column
names that we have specified
now that we've created a table let us
see how to insert the values into it for
that first let us discuss the insert
into value statement the insert into
value statement is used to insert either
all the column values or a specified
number of column values in the table
inserting only specified column data in
the row requires the column name should
be specified in the insert statement so
let's say if I want to insert all the
columns into the customer table the
following query would be
insert
into
table name which is the customer
now within the uh brackets we have to
mention the column names so the columns
that we have taken are customer ID
customer name
their age
address
product that they've purchased
and the purchase date
close the brackets now mention the
values keyword and again within the
brackets specify the values for each of
the columns so I'm taking a customer ID
as let's say 1011
comma customer name uh let's say Rahul
now make sure you uh mention the
character values inside the single
quotes and for integer values you need
not mention the single quotes
next their age let's say 25
comma address let's say uh the
City they belong to is the address so
I'm taking you know as Hyderabad
comma next the product that they have
purchased let's say they have let's say
Rahul has purchased the phone
as the product
and finally purchased it let's say 2022
March
and let's take data as a 25
so close the brackets and put the
semicolon so let us execute this
statement and see
so as you can see our query has been
successfully executed now to display the
values I'll use the select command again
so let us execute the statement so as
you can see the values have been
successfully inserted into our table
with respect to their columns as
customer ID customer name age address
product and the purchase date
so here we've inserted a row with all
the column values using the insert
statement similarly you can insert a row
with only specified columns values as
well let's say if you want to insert
data for only the columns customer ID
customer name and the product they've
purchased and leaving the rest of the
columns as such the following query
would be
insert
into
table name
maintain the table name that is customer
and within the brackets mention the
columns that you want to enter the
values so I'm only entering the values
for customer ID
customer name
and the product that they have purchased
and mention the keyword values
open the brackets and the specify the
values as accordingly so I'm taking
customer IDs uh 1000 and 12 customer
name let's say kavya
and the product that they've purchased
is let's say uh as AC
close the brackets mention the
semicolon and let us execute the
statement
so as you can see our query successfully
executed so let me display the values
and I'll use the select statement to
display the values so as you can see
only the customer ID customer name and
the product that they've purchased is
being displayed here and leaving the
rest of the columns that is age address
and the purchase date as null values so
in this way you can also insert values
into only the specified Columns of the
table next let us discuss about insert
multiple row statement
we can insert multiple rows in a single
insert statement at a time we can insert
multiple row values by grouping row
values with open and close brackets and
separating each row with a comma Now if
you want to insert let's say hundreds of
records and insert values into it it
will take a lot of time and it in the at
the same time it will become hectic if
you specify the column names each and
every time so in order to reduce that uh
and insert the values quickly we use
this multiple statement
so let's say if I want to insert uh new
values insert two rows of employee ID
1013 and 1014 so the following query
would be insert
into
customer that is the table name
and within the brackets uh
so before entering the values you have
to mention the keyword values
and you can directly enter the values
now without mentioning the column names
so as you can see I've inserted two rows
and the data into into the table so let
me just execute the statement and let us
see the output
so I said our query has been successful
executed uh let me use the select
statement to display the new values
so as you can see the customer ID 2013
and 2014 details uh has been displayed
so in this way you can use the uh insert
multiple statement uh to insert uh
multiple rows into the table so just
keep a note that make sure you insert
the values accordingly in the order of
the columns that you have taken in the
table the tutorial by understanding what
SKT delete statement is and then we'll
understand the syntax of SQL delete
statement and finally we look at some
SQL delete statements and execute them
in MySQL workbench
so what is SQL delete statement SQL
delete statement is one of the data
manipulation command DML that is used to
remove rows from a table that means you
will able to delete the existing records
from the table now you can either delete
a single row multiple rows or values
from the existing table depending on the
condition that is specified that means
this statement with where condition is
used to delete the rows that satisfies
the condition with where clause and the
remaining rows are not changed also
delete statement without where condition
is used to delete all the rows from the
table let us now understand the syntax
of SQL direct statement the syntax is
followed as delete from table name where
condition here where condition is
optional that means you can either use
it or you cannot use it
so let us take an example let's say if I
want to delete uh the details of the
employee from the employee table whose
employee ID is but not one so for that
the following syntax would be delete
from employee where employee ID equals
to 1.1 now if you execute this query it
will delete the details of that employee
who's having employed yes or not one in
this way you can use delete statement to
delete one or more rows from the
existing table now that we've got an
idea on what SQL delete is let us jump
directly into the MySQL workbench and
get into the execution part as you can
see MySQL workbench has started and on
the left side you can view the various
tables that are present in our database
simply code so let us consider uh
employee table first as an example table
to frame SQL queries to perform various
operations using the delete statement
firstly uh so let me display the values
that are present in the employee table
for that I am using the select statement
select star from the table that is
employee
so let me just execute this statement so
it will display the records of all the
employees their employee ID employee
name is destination date of birth city
and salary
so firstly uh let us see how to delete a
single Row from the given existing table
for that let me take an example let's
say if I want to delete one of the
employee details uh from the employee
table whose employee ID is let's say one
not eight for that the following query
would be
delete
from table name that is employee
where specify the condition
employee ID
equals to 107.
so let us execute the statement and see
the output
so our query has been successfully
executed let me use the select statement
to display the records and see whether
or not our record is deleted or not so
as you can clearly see one or seven uh
record of the employee is missing from
the table that means we have
successfully deleted the record of that
employee who's having employee ID 107.
let us now understand how to delete
multiple rows from the existing table
before that let me display the total
number of Records present in the table
so that we will have a clear idea on how
many records have been deleted after
executing the query for that I am using
a count statement select count
foreign
use the star operator
from the table that is employee
so we have total 14 records in the table
so let us now execute this statement uh
for that we will take an example let's
say if I want to delete multiple
employee details from the employee table
whose designation is let's say business
analyst so for that the following query
would be delete from
table that is employee
where
designation
equals to business analyst
[Music]
so let us execute the statement and see
the output
so as you can see our query has been
successfully executed let us again use
the account statement to see the values
that are deleted
foreign
so as you can see the total count of the
employees in the table has been changed
to 11 that means there are total of
three employees whose designation as
business analyst and since we have
specified the condition where we want to
delete only those records from the table
whose designation is business analyst so
in this way you can delete multiple rows
by using the where condition statement
now similarly you can delete multiple
records from the table using multiple
conditions as well this can be done
using various operators like and or
between
Etc so let us take an example for that
uh suppose let's say if I want to delete
the employee details uh from the
employee table uh whose designation is
let's say data analyst and their salary
is less than 30 000 by using or operator
for that the following query would be
delete
from table that is employee
specify the condition where
designation
equals to data analyst
or
their salary
is less than 30 000.
so let us execute this statement now
so our query has been successfully
executed and let us see the output for
that I am using the select count
statement as well again
so as you can see only one record has
been deleted from the table that means
there is only a record of the employee
whose designation is either data analyst
or their salary is less than 30 000 so
in this way you can use uh multiple
conditions to delete the records from
table as well
let us now take another scenario let's
say if I want to delete a multiple
employee retails from the employee table
whose salary is in between let's say 30
000 and 45
000 for that I'll use the between
operator and the following query would
be delete
from the table employee
where
salary
between
is the operator that we have to use 30
and 45 000.
so let us execute this statement and see
the output
so our query has been successfully
executed let me use the count statement
to display the number of Records now so
as you can see previously we had uh 10
records in the table now it has been
changed to four that means a total of
six records has been deleted from the
table wherein uh the salary of the
employees uh ranging between thirty
thousand and forty five thousand so in
this way you can use the uh Delete
statement to delete multiple records
from the table by specifying the
multiple conditions
now we have seen how to delete a single
record or multiple or records or even
multiple records using multiple
conditions in the existing table
sometimes there might be a requirement
to delete the entire table data to free
up the memory or to allocate new data
into the table for that we use the
delete statement to delete the uh hold
record from the table as well for that
executing delete statement without the
where Clause uh deletes the entire table
data so make sure you are careful while
using the delete statement because
you'll end up deleting the whole table
if you are using without wear cloth
let's say if I want to delete the
remaining records of the table from the
employee table I'll simply write the
query as
delete from table that is employee so
let me execute this statement and see
the output our query has been
successfully uh executed so let me just
display the records uh in the table for
that I'll use the select statement so as
you can see only the columns are being
present but the records that were
present in these columns have been
completely deleted uh using the delete
statement so in this way you can delete
all the records from the table without
specifying the condition using the where
Clause the column operations play an
important role because sorry even for
data analysis or even if you're
performing queries on your database
table it is quite essential because
let's say for instance you have created
a table as per required with requirement
with a set of different columns now
later at a different stage you might
need to add some additional requirements
where the table might need to have some
additional columns or even some columns
might require to be deleted or some
column names need to be changed into a
new columns within that existing table
now there are mainly two different ways
to satisfy this condition first is you
have to delete the table and recreate a
new table as per your new requirement
now this is possible and advise only
when the table is empty right now if the
table is not empty you have to copy the
data and then delete the table or create
another table and then copy or load the
data into the new table now this is time
consuming and also not advisable the
other way is to add delete or modify the
columns and the data present in it to
the current Table without touching the
existing columns and its corresponding
data now this is done by using the alter
table statement which fulfills the
requirement of adding new data within
the existing columns
now the alter table statement is used to
change the structure of the existing
table by adding deleting or modifying
The Columns without modifying the data
in it
so let us discuss what are the different
operations that are performed in SQL
firstly let us discuss the add column
operation in SQL
for for that let me consider the
employee table so let me just display
the values in it select star
from employee
so as you can see uh the employee table
has various columns like employee ID
employee name age designation City
salary date of joining Department ID
now let's say I have an additional
requirement where I want to add another
column let's say if I want to add the
other number details of the employees
for that I'll use the alter statement
and the query is Alter
payable
employee
add column
aadhar number
and mentioned the column data type I am
taking varker
and we'll specify not in a laser
constraint that means uh it must have a
other number for every employee in the
table
so let me just execute the statement so
as you can see our query has been
successfully executed so let me just
display the values
so as you can see uh there is a new
column other number uh that has been
created in our existing table without
disrupting any columns and its values in
the uh employee table
now similarly you can add multiple
columns to your existing table as well
and the query is Alter table
employee
add column
and within the brackets mention the
different column names now let's say if
I want to add the part number as well as
the UN that is the universal account
number of the employees so the query
will be add column
number
mention the column data type I'm taking
marker again
comma
UA number
you mention the data type
as what care
so let us execute this statement and see
the output
so our query has been executed
successfully let us see the output now
so as you can see uh we have two other
columns part number and UN number in our
employee table since we have not
mentioned mentioned any constraints here
as uh null or not null so it by default
it is taking here as null values so in
this way you can use the alter table
command to add multiple columns in your
table as well
now similarly you can even modify or
update the column values as well uh
let's say if I want to update the
existing column name into a new name now
for that I'll use the alter table
statement again now consider the
employee table again so let me just
display the values
[Music]
now if I want to change the salary
column name into total salary so for
that the following query would be alter
table
employee
change column is the keyword we use in
MySQL so mention the keyword change
column so we want to change the salary
column into total salary
and also mention the data type as well
so let us execute the query and see the
output
so our query has been successfully
executed so let me just display the
records again so as you can see a salary
name of the column salary has been
changed into the total salary here
so in this way you can update the column
values as well now similarly you can
also modify the existing uh column type
in the table as well for that the
following query would be alter table
employee
modify is the keyword
now let's say if I want to change the
age data type so let's see what the
initial or the previous data type was in
for age so I'll use the describe
employee
query here
so we basically have varcare as our data
type for the age now if I want to change
into int so I'll just basically mention
the in keyword here
so let us execute this statement and see
the output
so there was a bit error I forgot to
mention the column keyword here so
that's how it is showing an error so let
me just again describe the table
employee so as you can see the data type
of the age column has been changed from
barcap to int so in this way you can use
the alter table to modify the column
data type as well
now similarly we can also modify a new
column or an existing column with a
default value as well let's say I want
to take a new column uh bonus that is
the bonus salary for all the employees
so for that the following query would be
alter table
employee
alter column is the keyword we use here
bonus is the column that I'm creating
set default
is the keyword and I'm keeping the bonus
salary default as let's say 15 000.
so let us execute the query and see the
output
so I forgot to add the column of the
bonus so let me just first add the
column so Alta table employee add column
bonus
20.
so our bonus column has been
successfully created here so now we can
see our query will be successful here as
well
so let me just describe the table again
now if you scroll down you can see the
bonus column uh the field which it has
the default salary as fifteen thousand
so in this way you can add the uh
default value to your existing columns
or uh to your new columns as well
and finally we can also drop the columns
uh the drop column is basically is used
to delete the unnecessary or unwanted
columns in our database so let's say if
I want to delete the query already
created a
columns such as other pan uin on bonus
so I'll use the drop statement here to
delete the columns that were created
earlier so drop
so the query would be alter table
employee
drop column now first let us delete a
single column here so let's say if I
want to delete the other number column
so I'll use the other number column here
so let us see the output our query has
been successfully executed let me just
select the records so as you can see uh
other number column has been
successfully deleted and similarly you
can also delete multiple columns as well
all you have to do is just write the
same query and put a comma
and write again the column drop column
keyword here and let's say if I want to
delete the pi number as well so
pan number as well as the UN number here
now so I can use this query here
so let me just execute this and see the
output so our query has been executed
let me just display the records
so as you can see the UN number as well
as the part number has been successfully
uh deleted from the employee table as
well
and similarly the alter statement table
statement is also used to add and drop
various constraints on an existing table
like which we have discussed earlier if
you want your column uh a null value
then you can mention the null as the
constraint there and if you don't want
any null values for your columns then
you can use the not null keyword in your
uh alter table statements so in this way
you can use the
uh alter table statement to perform
various column operations in SQL so that
was all about the SQL column operations
guys where we have discussed about how
to add how to delete and how to update
or modify the existing columns in the
database start the tutorial by
understanding what is SQL join and then
we'll discuss why we use SQL join and
then we'll go through different types of
SQL joints such as sqlena join SQL Auto
join SQL left join and finally SQL right
joint so without any further delay let
us dive straight into today's topic so
what is SQL join in relational databases
the information you want to retrieve is
often stored in various different tables
in such scenarios you'll need to join
these tables to view data in a much
better way this is where SQL join comes
into picture SQL joins is widely used
clause in SQL essentially to combine and
retrieve data from two or more tables
based on related columns or you can say
common fields between them now consider
two tables here table one has three
columns ABC and three records let's say
for reference we'll take them as one two
three similarly table 2 also has three
columns BCD and three records three four
five here I have taken a different color
combination to represent values that are
present in various columns now instead
of querying each table every time to
retrieve data I'll simply join these two
tables and this will be the following
result 10 table also make sure when you
are joining two tables it should
compulsorily have a common column here C
is the common field which forms the
basis to join these two tables here
why we use SQL join flexibility SQL join
allows the user to access and manage
records from more than one table easily
let us understand with an example
consider Mercedes-Benz which is one of
the leading car manufacturers in the
world and let's say they want to access
the records of the customers from the
database now in the database let us take
they have various different kinds of
tables such as customer table order
table vehicle table now if they want to
get the vehicle details of so and so
customer XYZ for that they have to first
query the customer table to get the
customer ID now if once if they get the
customer ID they have to query the order
table to get the order ID and finally
with the help of order ID they can get
the vehicle details now as you can see
this is a time taking process and hectic
at the same time now instead of that
I'll just simply join these tables which
will allow the users to combine rows
from two or more tables based on
different types of conditions in this
way you can access and manage your
records easily
data redundancy SQL join allows the user
to maintain data residency as much as
low as possible so that we can maintain
the amount of data anomalies that is the
duplicate values that are repeated in
various tables in the database
finally efficiency SQL join executes the
query faster and shows the result much
more quickly because instead of using
various sub queries for each and every
table individually we can just simply
join uh two tables using us a simple
single query
types of SQL joints SQL joints are
broadly classified into four types they
are inner join outer join left join
right join and additionally we also have
cross joint which is not that
significant uh in its usage because most
of the times we use the first four
joints now that we have gone through
different types of SQL joints let us
discuss each of them in detail
firstly let us discuss about SQL inner
joint SQL inner join joins two tables
based on a common column and selects
records that have matching values in
these columns now when the condition uh
is applied for these columns the query
checks all the rows of table 1 and table
2. only the rows that satisfy the join
predicate are included in the resultant
table let us now understand the uh
syntax of the SQL inner joint the syntax
is followed as select table one dot
column one table1 dot column two table2.
column one and so on from table 1 in a
join table 2 on table one dot column
equals to table 2 dot column now inner
join syntax basically Compares rows of
table one with table two to check if any
anything matches based on the condition
provided in the on clause and when the
condition is met it returns matched
arrows in both tables with the selected
columns in the select clause
let us now discuss about the SQL outer
join SQL outer join or else it is called
as SQL full join or full outer join is
used to get all the rows which are
present in both the tables that means it
will return all the records which are
present in either left table that is the
table one or the right table that is
table two even if there are no matching
records present in both the tables let
us now understand the syntax the syntax
remains same that is Select table one
dot column one table one dot column two
and so on up to table 2 dot column 2
from table 1 full outer join is the
keyword that we use here table two on
table1 dot column equals to table two
dot column now here we have to mention
the uh the same or the similar column
name in the uh after the on predicate
statement
next we have SQL left join left outer
join also known as left join results in
a table containing all the rows from the
table on the left side of the join that
is the first table and only the rows
that satisfy the joint condition from
the table on the right side of the joint
that is the second table any missing
values uh for the rows from the right
table in the result of the joint tables
are represented by null values let's
look at the syntax the syntax is
followed as select column list that is
the column that you want to display in
your table now make sure you maintain
the syntax of the columnist that is the
table name dot column name otherwise it
will throw an error so let me just
repeat the syntax the syntax is Select
column list from table 1 the keyword
that we use here is left join table 2 on
table one dot column equals to table2
dot column so in this way you can use
the left join to display the records
next finally we have the SQL right join
now right join or right outer join is uh
opposite to that of the left outer join
now it follows the same rules as the
left join and the only difference is
that all the rows from the right table
and only the conditions satisfying the
rows from the left table are present in
the resultant table that means it will
return all the rows from the right table
and all the matching records that are
present in the left table the syntax
Remains the Same that is Select column
list that you want to display in your
table from table one right join is the
keyword we use table 2 on table one dot
column equals to table2 dot column now
to sum up all these different SQL joints
and how they work I've taken a graphical
representation of two different tables
here which will help us visualize the
real time working of SQL joins now
consider table 1 here which is columns A
and B and Records uh two different
records let's say record zero record one
and see similarly we have table 2 which
have columns A and C and two records
that is record zero and record two now
if you apply left join and by the
definition of left join it will only
return those values which will which are
present in the left table and the
matching records that are present in the
right table now here the uh matching
value that are present in both the
tables is 0 and the require values that
are present in the left table is one and
if you consider the right join it will
match the request from both the tables
and it will display the only you know
values from the right table that is the
reason it is being displayed uh the
record 0 and the record two and if you
look at the inner join it will match the
values from both the tables now the
common value that is present in both the
tables is record zero and if you finally
look at the outer join it will return
all the values from both the tables
irrespective if they are matching or not
that is the reason uh all the records
that is record 0 record 1 and record two
are being displayed and with that we
have come to the end of today's session
that was all about SQL joints stay tuned
uh for more upcoming videos awaren will
execute all these types of joins in
MySQL workbench using various examples
so what is SQL inner joint using the
inner join the tables are combined on
the basis of uh condition also known as
The Joint predicate this condition is
applied on The Columns of both the
tables on either side of the join Clause
the query checks all the rows of table 1
and table 2. now it will display only
those values that satisfy the join
predicate in the resultant table that
means it finds the matching values or
the uh matching records that are found
in both the tables for example I have a
table a which is records one two three
four and in table B I have records three
four five six now if you join these two
tables now the resultant output output
will be 3 3 and 4 because these are only
two records that are present in both the
tables that is the table is matching the
common values that are present in both
the tables let us now understand the
syntax of SQL inner join the syntax is
followed as select table one dot column
one table one dot column to table two
dot column two and so on from table 1
inner join is the keyword we have to use
table 2 on table one dot column equals
to table 2 dot column here after the
join expression we are mentioning The
Columns uh from which we want to match
the both the tables now that we have
understood uh what is SQL in a join let
us jump into MySQL workbench and execute
it with the help of an example
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and on the left side you can see
the database that is simply code and the
various tables that are present in our
database simply code like we have
customer table Department table employee
table order stable Etc now to perform
the SQL in a join operations I will use
the employee table Department table and
the projects table now let us display
the values that are present in the table
so that we have to use the select
statement or you can directly click on
this table icon here so first let us
display the values present in the
employee table the employee table has
the following Fields such as employee ID
employee name age designation the city
they belong to salary date of joining
and their Department ID next let us
display the values that are present in
the department table the department
table has two fields that is Department
ID and Department name and finally let
us display the values present in the
projects table the projects table has
the project ID employee ID the project
name and the project manager
now let's say we have a query here which
says to retrieve the employee details
and the department they are working in
now before we write a query we have to
check uh for all those tables in which
these informations are present in for
example I can get the employee details
from the employee table such as their
employee ID employee name the
designation salary and so on and also I
can get the Department details from the
Department table now the expected uh
query or the resultant table is based on
these two tables now in order to
retrieve the records from these two
different tables I need to connect them
in other words we have to join these two
tables this is where the inner join
comes into picture with the help of
inner join we can connect these two
tables and we can retrieve all those
matching records from those tables now
the following query would be for the
inner join is
select mention the column names that you
want to display now I want I will
display the employee ID
so employee
dot employee ID I'll also display the
employee name so employee dot employee
name
I'll also display the employee
designation
so I am taking employee.designation
now I'll also retrieve the information
from the Department so I'll have to
mention the department table here as
well so Department
dot Department ID
right now the query is continued as from
the table table one that is employee
I'll just write in the next send uh next
sentence from employee
inner join is the keyword we have to use
here and mention the second table that
is
Department
on which is the keyword and mention are
the condition on the basis of which you
are connecting these two tables now I am
connecting the employee and the
department table with the hemp with the
help of the department ID so I'll
mention employee Dot
in the apartment ID
equals to
Department
dot Department ID
so let us now execute this statement and
see the output
so as you can clearly see it is
displaying the values of employee ID
employee name the designation and the
department ID as well now as it clear
clearly you can see that the join
condition is specified in the inner join
Clause after the on keyword as the
expression now for each row in the Pro
in the employee table the query finds a
corresponding Row in the department
table that has the same matching values
based on which we have mentioned here
that is the department ID now if there
is a match between two rows in both the
tables it returns all those rows that
contains columns that we have specified
for example we have specified employee
ID name designation and the department
that they belong to
so in this way you can use the inner
join to get the records from both the
tables
also you can get the Department name as
well by mentioning the department names
in the uh query the department name dot
department DOT Department name now this
will display uh the records of the
department name that are present in the
department table as well
so as you can see uh there are total of
uh six records and the employee details
and the department names that they are
working in and also if you uh notice
there are only six records that are
present in a resultant table when we
have a total of 20 records that are
present in the employee table that's
because the energy only matches those
records from those columns that are
having matching values from both the
tables and and also the condition that
we have specified uh in our in a joint
statement
similarly let us look at another query
which says to retrieve the employee
details project they are working on and
the project manager assisting them now
for this to get the employee details
again I'll again use the employee table
and to get the details of the uh project
uh name and the project manager's name
I'll use the project table so the
following query would be select e dot
employee ID now here I have taken the
Alias name for the tables that is you
can mention a temporary name for the
tables that you have chosen so for
employee table I'm taking as e and for
projects I am taking SP in order to save
time and uh to save time we'll write in
this way so the query is followed as
select e dot employee ID e dot employee
name p dot project name p dot project
manager from the first table that is
employee
e inner join projects we have taken the
name as p on E dot employee ID is equals
to P dot employee ID which is the common
column from which we get the matching
values from both the tables let us now
execute uh this statement and see the
output
so as you can see we can uh we are able
to retrieve the employee ID employee
name project name that the employee is
working on and the project manager that
uh have been assigned to these employees
and if you notice uh carefully here like
some of the employees who are having
employee ID like thousand and twelve
thousand and thirteen thousand eighteen
sixteen uh there have no project names
assigned to their uh to their names that
this is because even though we have all
the details of employees uh in the
employee table we do not have the data
that that is being stored in the
projects table that is the reason uh
only a limited number of records are
being shown and as per the definition of
inner join it will re fetch only those
records which have matching values from
both the tables
so in this way you can join uh two or
more tables using the inner join
statement and with that we have come to
the end of today's session that was all
about you know the execution part let us
just quickly discuss what is SQL Auto
joint the outer join statement returns
all those records which are present in
either the left table or the right table
now for example if you consider uh the
table here a which has records one two
three four and the table B which has
records three four five six now if you
apply the full outer join to these two
tables it will display all the records
that is one two three and up to 6.
now let us discuss the syntax of SQL
outer join the syntax is followed as
select table one dot column one table
one dot column two table two dot column
one and so on these are basically the
columns that you want to display in your
resultant table from table one full
outer join table 2 on table one dot
column equals to table two dot column
now as far as MySQL concern this syntax
is not applicable now if you're working
on other databases like postview SQL and
Microsoft SQL Server you can apply this
uh syntax but if you're working on MySQL
workbench there is a different syntax
which I'll be discussing in a while so
now that we have understood what is SQL
Auto join let us jump into MySQL
workbench for the execution part
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and on the home page on the left
side you can view the databases and
tables now I've created a certain tables
uh time for time being so let me just
display the values that are present in
these tables now in order to execute the
I scale outer join we'll consider the
employee table as well as the project
tables so let me just display the values
present in the employee table I'll use
the select operator to display those
values select start from
employee
so it will display the records of all
those employees having employee ID
employee name is the designation City
salary date of joining and their
Department ID now similarly I'll display
the records of projects let me just take
another tab
I'll use again the select statement to
display the records
start from
projects
now I've execute this statement it'll
display the project ID employee ID
project name and the project manager
details now let's say if I want to fetch
the details of all the employees from
the employee table and the project
details they are working on from the
projects table I'll have to use the full
join to retrieve information from both
the tables now as discussed earlier the
full outer join keyword is not
applicable to mySQL database so I'll
have to implement a new logic here which
is quite simple as you know the full
outer join is the result of combining
the left and right table so we'll first
use the left join then we'll use the
right join and finally we'll use the
union operator which is used to combine
the resultant set of two or more select
statements and uh and execute it in a
single statement by the way we haven't
executed left and right join yet so stay
tuned for the upcoming videos on both
these joints as well if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
so the following query would be let me
let me make another tab again
so the following query would be
select
now mention all those column details
that you want to display in your
resultant table so I want to display the
employee ID employee name project name
and the project manager's name as well
so you have to mention the column names
in the format of table name dot column
name so I'm taking the uh Alias name for
the employee table as e so e dot
employee ID comma e dot employee name
now for the projects table I am taking
the Alias name as B
so P Dot
project name
comma
P Dot
project manager's name
from the table that is uh project tables
sorry the first table is employ right so
we'll mention the employee now use the
left join keyword
left join on projects
on now you have to mention the condition
uh on the basis of which you are
connecting these two tables now if you
look at the two tables we have the
employee ID that is present in both the
tables so that will be the common
attribute to specify this condition here
so e Dot
employee ID equals to P dot employee ID
now I'll just copy paste this same
statement
and uh instead of using the left join
I'll use the right join keyword so let's
just replace the left join keyword with
the right join
and I'll mention the union operator
keyword to join these two tables so
that's it guys uh this is how you can uh
use the full outer join in MySQL
workbench now let us just execute this
statement and see the output
so there's a bit of error let me just
check it once
so I forgot to mention the Alias name
here for both the table so that is why
it is throwing an error so as you can
see this is our output and you can
clearly see that the record from both
the tables that is the left table which
is employee and the right table which is
projects are being displayed here now
unlike the inner join which only fetches
those records which have matching values
in both the tables full outer join
retrieves all the values irrespective of
whether they are matching or not for
instance if you look at the employees
having employee IDs here 1.1012 1013
1016 and as well as 1018 we have uh
their information present in table one
that is the employee table here but we
do not have their information in the
projects table here and similarly
employees having employee IDs like 1022
2023 and 1024 their information is
present in the projects table but it is
not in present in the first table that
is employee you can see only the
employee details uh having their
employees ID up to 1020 are being
displayed in the employee table also if
you notice the resultant table here guys
uh some of the employees like kirti
Varon and uh
nithya have no uh projects assigned to
their name that's why we have null
values in the project name column that's
because though the records are present
in the employees table but their
employees IDs are not present in the
project table that means all these
employees are yet to be assigned a new
project so if the values present in both
the tables that does not match it will
simply just return null values similarly
we can see the other three projects that
are present uh in the table but there is
no sign of employee details here read
their employee ID or employee name and
it will just simply return the null
values again here because we do not have
the employee information in the first
table employee even though their IDs are
mentioned in the project table and hence
it will only return null values now
suppose this is just a demo table having
around 20 or 25 records but if you
consider a company's database in real
life it will have thousands of Records
in order to access and manage various
database tables and fetch information
from those tables all together it
becomes quite difficult right so this is
why we use full join to connect the
tables and retrieve each and every
information from them and in if any
column has null values they can just
simply update those rows or even delete
them as per the required let's just have
a quick recap on what is SQL left join
so SQL left outer join also known as
left join results in a table containing
all the rows from the table on the left
side of the join that is the first table
and only the rows that satisfy the joint
condition from the table on the right
side of the join that is the second
table the missing values for the rows
from the right table in the resultant
table of the join are represented by
null values for example if you consider
here two tables that is table a and
table B which is values one two three
four in table a and three four five six
in table B now if you apply left join
for both these tables or it will display
only the values from the left table that
is 1 2 and the matching values from the
right table that is 3 4. so the
resultant table will be one two three
four
let us now understand the syntax of the
SQL left join statement the syntax is
followed as select column lists these
These are basically the list the columns
that you want to display in your
resultant table from table one left join
which is the keyword we are using here
table two on table one dot column equals
to table two dot column now here here
you have to mention the uh a common
attribute on the basis of which you are
joining these two tables so now that
we've understood about SQL left join let
us now jump into MySQL workbench to
execute this using various examples
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and on the home page on the left
side in the schema section you can view
the databases and the tables that are
present so in this case we have the
database simply code and various tables
in that such as customer Department
table employee orders and Etc now in
order to execute this uh left join
statement will will be going to use
customer and the order stable statement
tables so let me just display the values
from both these tables for that I'll use
the select Clause select star
from
customer
which is the table name so let us just
execute
so as you can see the customer table has
various Fields such as customer ID
customer name age address and their
phone numbers similarly let us go to
another Tab and display the values that
are present in order statement
select star from the table that is
orders
so let us execute this statement so as
you can see in the output the orders
table has various Fields such as product
ID customer ID product name that is the
product I've purchased quantity the
price of the product and the purchase
date
now let's say if I want to fetch the
details of all the customers and the
product details that they've purchased
I'll have to connect these two tables
that is customer and the orders table to
get the resultant table now for that
I'll use the left join statement so let
me just take another Tab and execute the
statement so the following query would
be select mention the column names that
you want to fetch in your resultant
table so I'm going to take here
Aaliyah's name for both the customer and
the orders table as C and O that's
because uh instead of writing the full
name of the tables each and every time
you can just simply use an alias name
which is a temporary name which will
save time as well so for customer uh
table I'm taking as C so I want to
display the customer ID
so C Dot
customer ID
I want to display the customer name
customers address so C dot address
now from the orders table I want to uh
mention the products name that they've
purchased the quantity price and
purchase date
so we have taken o as the Alias name for
our table so o dot purchase name
sorry product name
that they have purchased
I also want to display the quantity so o
dot quantity
its price as well O DOT price
and the purchase date oh Dot
purchase
date
from the table first table that is
customer
mention the Alias name c
left join which is the keyword
on the second table that is orders
oh on mention the condition on which you
are joining these two tables so as you
can see we can find the customer ID and
the customer ID in both the customer and
the orders table so we'll mention the
customer ID as the column common
attribute here so C Dot customer ID
equals to
O DOT
customer ID so let us just execute the
statement and see the output
so as you can see it will display the
customer ID customer name address
product name quantity price and purchase
date of the customers in our resultant
table now let us understand what exactly
are the left join statement is doing
here firstly the database checks each
and every row of the table and looks for
a match in the right table based on the
related columns now if a match is found
the data from the right table is added
to the corresponding row of the left
table now you can see uh customers
having customer ID one zero one one zero
one zero one two zero one zero one three
zero and one zero one three one four
zero we have the details present in the
first table as well as the second table
that is orders so it will display all
those records and then if there are
multiple matches now in this case we can
see a customer name Ajay is having two
different uh Records who has bought sofa
set and a TV so the rows in the left
table are duplicated here that is the
records are repeated in the resultant
table in order uh to include all the
records from the right table
so now for all the
columns that you have fetched from the
right table that is orders which is not
satisfying the join conditions then the
values present in the columns will be
resultant as null that means if there is
no matching value found from the right
table it'll simply retain the row from
the left table and inserts null into the
corresponding Columns of the right table
now let me just explain this now if you
see here the customer uh customers like
others and pranay who are having details
in the first table that is a customer
table but they do not have their details
in the Pro orders table so there is no
sign of any
their customer ID in the order table
that's why we do not have their details
present in the uh resultant table so it
will just show the null values here
so basically left join is a combination
of inner join we can say because it just
checks the matching values from both the
tables first and then it will check for
any additional or extra values that are
left out from the left table that is the
table one now you might have a question
that when to use and why to use the left
join like there are times when you want
to keep rows from the first table that
don't have any corresponding records in
the second table now if you in this case
if you consider our example we might
want to see information about all the
customers in a resultant table even if
they didn't place any orders so in that
case we'll use the left join which
should be used to combine data from two
tables so that all the rows from the
left table are included in the resultant
set even if there is no matching value
from the right table if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
now before getting into the execution
part let us just have a quick recap on
what is SQL right join
SQL right outer join also known as the
right join works the opposite way to
that of left outer join it follows the
same rule as the left join and the only
difference is that all the rows from the
right table and only the condition
satisfying rows from the left table are
present in the resultant table
so basically the right join returns all
the records from the right table and
only the matching records from the left
table they are satisfying the condition
for example let's say we have two tables
table a and table B and when the Left
Right join is applied to the two tables
it will give all the records from the
table B and only the matching records
from the table a that is table one
let us now look at the syntax of SQL
right joint the syntax is same and it is
followed as select table one dot column
one table one dot column two table two
dot column one and so on these are
basically the columns that you want to
display in your resultant table from
table one right join is the keyword we
use here table two on table one dot
column equals to table 2 dot column now
that we've understood what is SQL right
join let us jump into MySQL workbench
for the execution part
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 Plus hours of
video content for free visit skillup by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
so MySQL workmanship started and on the
left side you can view the database
simply code which has various tables
such as customer Department employee
orders now for time being I've already
created and inserted values into all
these tables and to in order to execute
the SQL right join we are going to use
the customer table and the orders table
so let me just display the values that
are present in these tables for that I
am going to use this select statement
select star
from the customer table
thank you
so as you can see the customer table has
a various Fields such as customer ID
customer name their age their address
and the phone number similarly let us
just retrieve the request from the
orders table as well
select
star
from orders table
so the orders table has of various
columns such as product ID customer ID
product name that they've purchased
quantity price of the product and the
purchased date now if I want to join
these two tables I am going to use the
right join statement so the following
query would be
select now I am going to use a layers
name for both these tables for customer
table I'm going to take as C and for
orders table I'm going to take as o now
I want to display the columns from the
customer table uh only so the tables are
the columns are customer name I want to
display their address as well so mention
the column names customer name
C dot address
now from order stable I am going to
display the product name that they've
purchased quantity price and purchase
date
so O DOT
product name
comma O DOT
quantity
comma o dot price
and finally o dot purchase date
from the table one that is customer
mention the keyword right join
mention the second table name that is
orders
on mention the condition on which you
are joining these two tables now now as
you can see we have customer ID as well
as the customer ID present in both the
tables customers and orders so we'll be
taking the customer ID here as the
common column on C Dot customer ID
equals to O DOT
customer ID
let us now execute the statement and see
the output
so there is just an error let me check
okay I didn't mention the Alias name
here so mention the Alias name for both
the tables
I guess it will display now
so as you can see this is our resultant
table which uh basically displays the
various columns customer name their
address product name quantity price and
purchase date let us now understand what
exactly the right join is performing
here now basically the right join Clause
starts selecting the data from the right
table and matches it with the rows from
the left table the right join returns a
resultant table that includes all the
rows in the right table whether or not
they are having matching rows from the
left table now if a row in the right
table does not have any matching rows
from the left table The Columns of the
left table in the resultant set will
have null values now clearly the SQL
statement would return all the rows from
the orders table here as you can see we
have all the details like AC TV phone
cooker car sofa set and phone bike Etc
in our orders table so it it is
basically retrieving all the data from
the right table and only those rows from
the customer table where the join
condition is being satisfied now it will
only display the matching values here
because can you as you can see we have
customer
id101101012010130 so basically we have
one total six records and we have
them in the resultant table as well now
if you consider the resultant table here
it is showing null values for some of
the customer names and address because
though we have the product names
mentioned in the orders table here for
example the product name car sofa set
bike and the customer IDs are one zero
one four zero one zero one six zero and
one zero one nine zero but we do not
have their uh details present in the
customer table and that is the reason we
that it is showing is null here
so in this way you can use the SQL right
join statement now you might have a
doubt that when to use and why to use
the right join statement again it will
depend on your own requirement for
instance if you want to keep the records
from the second table that do not have
any corresponding records from the first
table in that case we will use the right
join also another point to be noted here
that the table that you have mentioned
to the right side of the right join
keyword that is we have taken here
orders right so it will give the highest
priority to this table and it will
display all the records from the orders
table here even if they do not have any
matching values similarly just take
another scenario here I'm just
interchanging the tables here like the
first table I'm taking is orders and the
second table I'm taking as customers so
when we execute this statement it will
display the records from all the records
from the customer table that is the
first table and even if they do not have
the matching values it will just display
the null values here that's because now
if you consider other
we have their details uh in the employee
in the customer table but we do not have
their information present in the orders
table and that's the reason we can see
that only their details are present but
they do not have the orders details that
we have present here
so in this way you can use the right SQL
join statement as well so with that we
have come to the end of session guys
that was all about the SQL understanding
what exactly are SQL keys and then we'll
understand why we use SQL keys and
finally we'll go through some different
types of keys that are used in SQL so
without any further Ado let's dive
straight into today's topic on SQL keys
so what are keys in SQL SQL Keys plays
an important role in relational
databases it is used for identifying
unique rows from table a key is a subset
of columns in a table that allows a row
to be uniquely identified so a key can
be more than just a column and every Row
in the table will have a unique value
for the key or a unique combination of
values if the key consists of more than
just one column
now as you know databases are used to
store massive amounts of information
which is stored across multiple tables
now each table might be having more than
thousands of Records or rows now
needless to say there will be many
duplicate rows with redundant
information so how do we deal with that
now how do we manage these records that
are storing only unique data now for
that we might need a combination of one
or more columns in the database table to
uniquely identify a row in a database
so in that case we use the SQL Keys now
SQL Keys creates constraints that can be
used to enforce data Integrity in SQL
now as you know a database must adhere
to certain properties to maintain
integrity and quality of the data that
is storing keys and constraints are
rules that Define what data values are
allowed in certain data columns there
are an important database concept as
well as for SQL and are part of database
schema definition defining keys and
constraints is part of database design
process and ensures that data within a
database is reliable and maintains
integrity
let us now understand why we use SQL
Keys SQL Keys identify each record
separately and uniquely now a key is
used in the definition of various kinds
of Integrity constraints and a table in
a database represents a collection of
Records or events for a particular
relation now since there are thousands
and thousands of such records some of
which may be duplicated now in order to
identify these records uniquely and
separately we need SQL keys
SQL Keys allows user to establish and
identify a relationship between the
tables as well and finally SQL Keys
access or manages the store data quickly
and smoothly
now that we have understood what SQL
keys are and why we use them let us now
discuss some of the various types of
keys in SQL SQL keys are broadly
classified into various types such as
primary key Super Key candidate key
alternate key composite key foreign key
now let us discuss each and every type
of key in detail with an example
firstly let us look at what exactly is
primary key
the primary key is one of the most
important and commonly used SQL keys in
the databases the primary key is in SQL
is a single or a group of fields or
columns that can uniquely identify a row
in a Dipple putting it simply it is a
column that accepts unique values for
each row therefore whenever you use the
insert into command to insert new values
in a table the value for a primary key
column or columns need to be unique now
primary key advantages is mainly it
uniquely identifies each row of a table
also it gets a unique index for each
primary key column that helps with
faster access
now there are properties which are
helpful of SQL primary key they are it
enforces uniqueness by not accepting any
duplicate values and a primary key also
uniquely identifies each field and can
take only one primary key for a table
now primary key column cannot accept
null values as well
let us consider an example here consider
student table which is having various
Fields such as student ID role number
name class section age and address now
if you look at the table clearly student
ID can be taken as a primary key here
also you can take the roll number but
since we are taking the records of all
the students in a school that's why we
are taking the student ID as the primary
key now if you take the records of the
students for a particular class then you
can take the roll number as a primary
key as well
let us now understand the syntax of
primary key Now to create a new table
with a column defined as a primary key
you can use the keyword primary key at
the end of the definition of that column
and the syntax is create table table
name and within the parenthesis mention
the column names and its column types
and finally mention the primary key
inside the brackets
so for example if I want to create a
table which is having ID last name first
name and age in that I am going to use
the primary key here as ID so in this
way you can use the primary key in SQL
next let us discuss about the candidate
key a candidate key is defined as set of
one or more columns that can identify or
record uniquely in a table so basically
candidate key is a Super Key with no
repeated attributes by the way uh we'll
discuss about the super key in a while
uh the primary key should be selected
from all the candidate keys and every
table must have at least a single
candidate key and a table can have
multiple candidate keys but only a
single primary key now candid key
shouldn't have redundant attributes that
means it should not have any duplicate
values in the table now unlike primary
key the attributes of candidate key can
contain null values and as discussed a
table can have more than one candidate
keys and it is also called as the
minimal Super Key guys that's because we
select a candidate key from a set of
super Keys such that the selected
candidate key is the minimum attribute
required to uniquely identify the rows
in a table so let us understand this
with an example consider the students
table here which is having various
columns such as student ID role number
name age address and contact now as you
know we can take the student ID as the
primary key and with that we can take
the rule number as well as the contact
of the students as the candidate key
here because all these three columns
alone can uniquely satisfy the condition
of the candidate key here so in this way
we can use the candidate keys in S2
next let us discuss about alternate key
in SQL
alternate key or subset of candidate
keys that can also uniquely identify
tuples in a table which are not chosen
as primary key for example consider the
employee table here which has columns
employee ID employee name job department
number pan number other number and uan
now if you look at the table uh The
Columns that can uniquely identify each
and every record are basically employee
ID pan number other number and UA number
now since we have taken the employee ID
as a primary key and the rest of all the
columns that are not chosen as a primary
key are considered to be alternate keys
so in this case we can take the pan
number other number UN number as our
alternate keys next let us discuss about
the super key in SQL super key is
another important key that is used
day-to-day usage and SQL databases a
Super Key or a simple key is a
combination of all possible attributes
which can use uniquely identify the row
or tuples in a table that means that a
Super Key may have some extra attributes
which isn't necessary for uniquely
identifying the rows in the table
a Super Key is a in SQL is a superset of
primary key candidate key and Alternate
key that means basically it is a
combination of all the keys such as
primary candidate and Alternate Keys as
discussed super key will have additional
attributes that are not needed for any
unique identification and finally super
keys with the least number of attributes
form the candidate keys
so let us take an example again consider
the employee table here and if you look
at the possible keys that will be for
super keys are employee ID part number
employee ID other number employee ID uan
number other number pan number uan other
number uan employee ID pan number as
well as un and finally pan number other
number and uan
now all the above keys are able to
uniquely identify each row so each of
these Keys is a Super Key now again in
this example we have like more than uh
six Super keys but all of them cannot
become a candidate key here only those
super Keys would become a candidate key
which have no redundant attribute for
example uh if you take employee ID part
number this key cannot be considered as
a candidate key because uh when we take
this subset of this key we get two
attributes that is employee ID as well
as the pan number now each of these
attributes is basically a candidate key
so it is a minimal super key but hence
this key is not a candidate key
and finally let us discuss about the
foreign clean SQL a foreign key is a
column or combination of columns that is
used to establish and force a link
between the data in two tables to
control the data that can be stored in
the foreign key table in a foreign key
reference a link is created between two
tables when the column or columns hold
the primary key value for one table and
the reference by the column or columns
in other table now this column becomes a
foreign key in the second table the
table with the foreign key is known as
the child table and the table with the
primary key is known as the referenced
or parent table
now as foreign key has bought the
referential Integrity in SQL uh which
means that
it requires that a foreign key must have
a matching primary key or it must be
null this constraint is specified
between two tables that is parent and
child and it maintains the
correspondence between the rows in these
tables it means that the reference from
a row in one table to another table must
be valid now the foreign key uh helps in
maintaining the data Integrity of the
table and allows easy navigation between
two instances or attributes it is also
used in SQL to make the database data
consistent and it is also used for the
prevention of any action that may result
in destruction of relation between these
two tables
let us understand this with an example
now consider two tables here employee
and Department the employee table has
employee ID employee name job department
number pan number other number and UN
number and the department table has
employee ID and the department name now
clearly the employee ID which is the
primary key in the first table employee
is acting as a cross reference for the
Department table that is uh the employee
ID acts as the foreign key here for the
Department table
so in this way you can use the foreign
key in SQL
and similarly we have some other types
of uh keys in SQL which are not that
significant in its usage the first one
being is unique key a unique key same as
a primary key with the difference being
the existence of one null value in a
table field or a row for example
consider a student table having student
ID roll number and its name now for some
reasons if the student is leaving the
school then his roll number might be
deleted although his student ID will be
preserved for further assistance so
since there is a null value in roll
number it can be considered as a unique
key and student ID can be considered as
a primary key similarly we have
composite key a composite key is a
combination of two or more attributes
that can together uh can uniquely
identify a tuple in a table
and that brings us to the end of today's
session uh that was all about uh the SQL
keys so let us just quickly recap what
we have discussed uh the different types
of keys so to summarize this I've
created a table here employee ID
employee name other passport department
ID which is the table one that is
employee table and we have Department
idea and Department columns in the
second table that is Department table
now you are clearly employee ID is the
primary key since it uniquely identifies
each and every record in the table and
employee ID other number password can be
taken as candidate keys because they are
set of more than one primary keys since
though so they can be considered as the
candidate key here now alternate Keys
which are other than the primary key
that is employee ID so I am taking other
card and passport as the alternate Keys
here now the combination of all these
keys that such as primary key candidate
key alternate key forms are super key
now I am taking the passport as the
unique sense and not but everyone has a
passport to their name so I'm taking the
passport attribute here as the unique
key and finally the foreign case the
department ID as it points uh to the
reference to the second table that is
Department table
so in this way you can use the SQL Keys
accordingly any further delay let's get
started with today's topic firstly let
us understand the agenda for today
session we'll start the tutorial by
understanding what exactly are SQL keys
and then we'll understand why we use SQL
keys and finally we'll go through some
different types of keys that are used in
SQL so without any further Ado let's
dive straight into today's topic on SQL
keys
so what are keys in SQL SQL Keys plays
an important role in relational
databases it is used for identifying
unique rows from table a key is a subset
of columns in a table that allows a row
to be uniquely identified so a key can
be more than just a column and every Row
in the table will have a unique value
for the key or a unique combination of
values if the key consists of more than
just one column
now as you know databases are used to
store massive amounts of information
which is stored across multiple tables
now each table might be having more than
thousands of Records or rows now
needless to say there will be many
duplicate rows with redundant
information so how do we deal with that
now how do we manage these records that
are storing only unique data now for
that we might need a combination of one
or more columns in the database table to
uniquely identify a row in a database
so in that case we use the SQL Keys now
SQL Keys creates constraints that can be
used to enforce data Integrity in SQL
now as you know a database must adhere
to certain properties to maintain
integrity and quality of the data that
is storing keys and constraints are
rules that Define what data values are
allowed in certain data columns there
are an important database concept as
well as for SQL and are part of database
schema definition defining keys and
constraints is part of database design
process and ensures that data within a
database is reliable and maintains since
integrity
let us now understand why we use SQL
Keys SQL Keys identify each record
separately and uniquely now a key is
used in the definition of various kinds
of Integrity constraints and a table in
a database represents a collection of
Records or events for a particular
relation now since there are thousands
and thousands of such records some of
which may be duplicated now in order to
identify these records uniquely and
separately we need SQL keys
SQL Keys allows user to establish and
identify a relationship between the
tables as well and finally SQL Keys
access or manages the store data quickly
and smoothly
now that we have understood what SQL
keys are and why we use them let us now
discuss some of the various types of
keys in SQL SQL keys are broadly
classified into various types such as
primary key Super Key candidate key
alternate key composite key foreign key
now let us discuss each and every type
of key in detail with an example
firstly let us look at what exactly is
primary key
the primary key is one of the most
important and commonly used SQL keys in
the databases the primary key is in SQL
is a single or a group of fields or
columns that can uniquely identify a row
in a dipl putting it simply it is a
column that accepts unique values for
each row therefore whenever you use the
insert into command to insert new values
in a table the value for a primary key
column or columns need to be unique now
primary key advantages is mainly it
uniquely identifies each row of a table
also it gets a unique index for each
primary key column that helps with
faster access
now there are properties which are
helpful of SQL primary key they are it
enforces uniqueness by not accepting any
duplicate values and a primary key also
uniquely identifies each field and can
take only one primary key for a table
now primary key column cannot accept
null values as well
let us consider an example here consider
student table which is having various
Fields such as student ID role number
name class section age and address now
if you look at the table clearly student
ID can be taken as a primary key here
also you can take the roll number but
since we are taking the records of all
the students in a school that's why we
are taking the student ID as the primary
key now if you take the records of the
students for a particular class then you
can take the roll number as a primary
key as well
let us now understand the syntax of
primary key Now to create a new table
with a column defined as a primary key
you can use the keyword primary key at
the end of the definition of that column
and the syntax is create table table
name and within the parenthesis mention
the column names and its column types
and finally mention the primary key
inside the brackets so for example if I
want to create a table which is having
ID last name first name and age in that
I am going to use the primary key here
as ID so in this way you can use the
primary key in SQL
next let us discuss about the candidate
key a candidate key is defined as set of
one or more columns that can identify or
record uniquely in a table so basically
candidate key is a Super Key with no
repeated attributes by the way uh we'll
discuss about the super key in a while
uh the primary key should be selected
from all the candidate keys and every
table must have at least a single
candidate key and a table can have
multiple candidate keys but only a
single primary key now candid key
shouldn't have redundant attributes that
means it should not have any duplicate
values in the table now unlike primary
key the attributes of candidate key can
contain null values and as discussed a
table can have more than one candidate
keys and it is also called as the
minimal Super Key guys that's because we
select a candidate key from a set of
super Keys such that the selected
candidate key is the minimum attribute
required to uniquely identify the rows
in a table so let us understand this
with an example consider the students
table here which is having various
columns such as student ID role number
name age address and contact now as you
know we can take the student ID as the
primary key and with that we can take
the rule number as well as the contact
of the students as the candidate key
here because all these three columns
alone can uniquely satisfy the condition
of the candidate key here so in this way
we can use the candidate keys in SQ
next let us discuss about alternate key
in SQL
alternate key or subset of candidate
keys that can also uniquely identify
tuples in a table which are not chosen
as primary key for example consider the
employee table here which has columns
employee ID employee name job department
number pan number other number and uan
now if you look at the table uh The
Columns that can uniquely identify each
and every record are basically employee
ID pan number other number and UA number
now since we have taken the employee ID
as a primary key and the rest of all the
columns that are not chosen as a primary
key are considered to be alternate keys
so in this case we can take the pan
number other number UN number as our
alternate keys next let us discuss about
the super key in SQL super key is
another important key that is used
day-to-day usage and SQL databases a
Super Key or a simple key is a
combination of all possible attributes
which can use uniquely identify the row
or tuples in a table that means that a
Super Key may have some extra attributes
which isn't necessary for uniquely
identifying the rows in the table
a Super Key is a in SQL is a superset of
primary key candidate key and Alternate
key that means basically it is a
combination of all the keys such as
primary candidate and Alternate Keys as
discussed super key will have additional
attributes that are not needed for any
unique identification and finally super
keys with the least number of attributes
form the candidate keys
so let us take an example again consider
the employee table here and if you look
at the possible keys that will be for
super keys are employee ID part number
employee ID other number employee ID uan
number other number pan number uan other
number uan employee ID pan number as
well as un and finally pan number other
number and uan
now all the above keys are able to
uniquely identify each row so each of
these Keys is a Super Key now again in
this example we have like more than uh
six Super keys but all of them cannot
become a candidate key here only those
super Keys would become a candidate key
which have no redundant attribute for
example uh if you take employee ID part
number this key cannot be considered as
a candidate key because uh when we take
this subset of this key we get two
attributes that is employee ID as well
as the pan number now each of these
attributes is basically a candidate key
so it is a minimal super key but hence
this key is not a candidate key
and finally let us discuss about the
foreign key in SQL a foreign key is a
column or combination of columns that is
used to establish and force a link
between the data in two tables to
control the data that can be stored in
the foreign key table in a foreign key
reference a link is created between two
tables and the column or columns hold
the primary key value for one table and
the reference by the column or columns
in other table now this column becomes a
foreign key in the second table the
table with the foreign key is known as
the child table and the table with the
primary key is known as the referenced
or parent table
now as foreign key has bought the
referential Integrity in SQL uh which
means that
it requires that a foreign key must have
a matching primary key or it must be
null this constraint is specified
between two tables that is parent and
child and it maintains the
correspondence between the rows in these
tables it means that the reference from
a row in one table to another table must
be valid now the foreign key uh helps in
maintaining the data Integrity of the
table and allows easy navigation between
two instances or attributes it is also
used in SQL to make the database data
consistent and it is also used for the
prevention of any action that may result
in destruction of relation between these
two tables
let us understand this with an example
now consider two tables here employee
and Department the employee table has
employee ID employee name job department
number pan number other number and UN
number and the department table has
employee ID and the department name now
clearly the employee ID which is the
primary key in the first table employee
is acting as a cross reference for the
Department table that is uh the employee
ID acts as the foreign key here for the
Department table
so in this way you can use the foreign
key in SQL
and similarly we have some other types
of keys in SQL which are not that
significant in its usage the first one
being is unique key a unique key same as
a primary key with the difference being
the existence of one null value in a
table field or a row for example
consider a student table having student
ID roll number and its name now for some
reasons if the student is leaving the
school then his roll number might be
deleted although his student ID will be
preserved for further assistance so
since there is a null value in roll
number it can be considered as a unique
key and student ID can be considered as
a primary key similarly we have
composite key a composite key is a
combination of two or more attributes
that can together uh can uniquely
identify a tuple in a table
and that brings us to the end of today's
session uh that was all about uh the SQL
keys so let us just quickly recap what
we have discussed uh the different types
of keys so to summarize this I've
created a table here employee ID
employee name other passport department
ID which is the table one that is
employee table and we have Department
idea and Department columns in the
second table that is Department table
now you are clearly employee ID is the
primary key since it uniquely identifies
each and every record in the table and
employee ID are the number password can
be taken as candidate keys because they
are set of more than one primary keys
since though so they can be considered
as the candidate key here now alternate
Keys which are other than the primary
key that is employee ID so I am taking
other card and passport as the alternate
Keys here now the combination of all
these keys that such as primary key
candidate key alternate key forms are
super key now I am taking the passport
as the unique sense and not but everyone
has a passport to their name so I'm
taking the passport attribute here as
the unique key and finally the foreign
case the department ID as it points uh
to the reference to the second table
that is Department table
so in this way you can use the SQL Keys
Apple by understanding what is SQL Group
by statement and see why we use Group by
clause and then we'll understand what is
SQL order by statement and why we use
order by clause and next we'll see some
key differences between these two
statements and finally we'll understand
the syntax and look into the execution
part in MySQL workbench
so what is SQL Group by now SQL allows
the user to store more than one type and
up to almost 30 types of data types in
as many columns as required so sometimes
it becomes difficult to find similar
data in these columns now Group by in
SQL helps us club together all these
identical rows present in The Columns of
a data Group by statement is used to
group together any rows of a column with
the same value stored in them on a
function specified in this statement
basically Group by Clause is used to
group the row switch matching values
using the specified condition now
generally we use this group by Clause
with aggregate functions such as count
Max minimums maximum and average by the
way guys uh if you want to know more
about the aggregate functions make sure
to check out our previous video or
introduction the aggregate functions
where we have discussed about these in
detail
now uh the SQL Group by statement uses
the split apply combined technique here
now the different groups are split with
their values and then an aggregate
function is applied to these values of
these groups and finally the values are
combined into a single row now if you
consider this example here we have two
columns and we have three different
items uh a b c having different values
now you can see a has two values four
seven one three
and C has nine four now when we split
this and apply the sum aggregate
function which results in the arithmetic
sum of all these row values as you can
see now a has values four and seven now
when I apply this sum it becomes 11 and
b 1 3 it becomes 4 and C 9 4 it becomes
13. so it will display all these
identical arrows having matching values
and into a resultant set so in this way
you can use the SQL Group by
let us now understand the syntax of SQL
Group by statement the syntax is
followed as select column one column two
up to n number of columns from table
name where condition Group by column
name now the group by statement lets the
database system user know that we wish
to group the same value rows of the
column specified in the statements
column names parameter and you can also
use there is an optional where clause
which can be used to specify any
condition According to which the row are
to be selected
next let us understand what is SQL order
by statement the order by Clause is an
SQL sorts the data of a column in the
SQL database it helps us sort the column
in both ascending as well as the
descending order the ASC keyword helps
us sort in ascending order while the
desc keyword sorts in descending order
and if no keyword is specified in which
we have to sort the records in the
column it will take the default value
the order by Clause sorts the required
in ascending order by default if it not
mention any specific keyword that is AAC
or DAC
now the order by Clause can only be for
select statements and the order by
keyword is used to sort the resulting
table in either ascending order by or
descending order based on the columns
specified in the statements column name
now another important thing to be noted
here is that the order by statement
always appear after the group by
statement and is applied to the group of
rows form now let us look at the syntax
the syntax is followed as select column
1 column 2 from table name where
condition which is optional as per your
requirement Group by column list order
by column name and you can mention the
AC or desc keyword as per your need
now that we have understood about both
of these statements let us now
understand the differences between Group
by and order by now Group by statement
is used to group the rows that have the
same value whereas the order by is used
to arrange the data obtained in the
resultant table of a query in sorted
form
now the groupa is always used before the
order by clause in the select statement
whereas the all order by statement is
used after the group by clause in the
select statement
now in group by statement the attribute
under the aggregate function cannot be
in group by Clause whereas in order by
the attribute under aggregate function
can be in order by Clause that means if
the group a clause contains an attribute
that is not under select clause or if it
is under select Clause but under
aggregate function then the query
becomes invalid and it throws an
exception hence we can say the group by
Clause is always used in collaboration
with the select Clause now in group by
it is mandatory to use one of the
aggregate functions like count sum
average minimum maximum Etc whereas in
order by statement it is not compulsory
and mandatory to use the aggregate
functions and finally the group by
Clause controls the presentation of rows
or tuples whereas the order by statement
controls the presentation of columns
that means the group is only concerned
with the values of identical rows in the
resultant set whereas the order by
statement uh basically arranges the data
in the columns in either ascending or
descending form now that we have
understood about both these uh SQL
statements let us jump into MySQL
workbench for execution part choose from
over 300 in-demand skills and get access
to 1 000 Plus hours of video content for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
so as you can see MySQL workbench has
started now in order to execute the
group and order by statement we'll
consider the data set of an employee
which have already downloaded from
Google so let me just import the data
set into the MySQL workbench for that
all you have to do is just go to the
tables Tab and right click on it and
you'll find table data import wizard
click on that now it will ask to import
the location from where you have said so
I have saved my file in desktop so I'm
just selecting the file
now once you selected the file click the
next button here now it will ask if uh
to name the table whether to use
existing table or to create a new table
so I'm just taking a new table here
employees one
and click on next
it will display all the columns that are
present in that CSV file so just click
on next
click on next and it will start to
prepare the import now depending upon
the number of Records present in the
data set it will take bit of time so
don't worry now as you can see our data
set has been successfully imported so I
will click on next again
so uh it is showing that fortunate
records have been important successfully
so let me just refresh the schema here
and as you can see employees one uh has
been shown in the table section so let
me just display the records that are
present in these uh tables for that I'm
using this select statement select start
from employees
one
so as you can see our employees one
table has employee ID first name last
name email phone number hiring date job
ID salary manager ID and finally
Department ID
now firstly let us discuss about the
group by Clause uh now let's say if I
want to fetch the total employees in all
the Departments from the employees one
table then the following query would be
select now I can take the employer ID to
display the total number of employees
because each and every every employee
has a different employee ID to their
name so select
foreign
employee ID
as total
comma
I want to display their Department ID as
well
so I'm taking Department ID
from employees table
employee one
Group by
now we want to group all their
Department ID right so I'm taking
Department ID
so let me just execute the statement and
see the output
okay
the table name is wrong here so let me
just correct it
so as you can see it will display the
total employees that are present in each
and every department now if you look at
the department ID column we have the
values in a random way now in order to
display in a systematic and a proper way
this is where we use the order by
statement so we can sort the department
ID values in the ascending or descending
manner as per your as per a requirement
so I want to display an ascending order
so order by Department ID
foreign
let us execute the statement and see the
output so as you can now see that the
department ID are being displayed any in
the ascending manner that is 10 20 30 40
50 and so on up to 110. so in this way
you can use the group by an order by
statements
so that was all about the group and
order by our statement so this is just
to give a quick uh review on how these
two statement works now if you want to
learn more about the order by statement
make sure to check out our rice kill
order by video on our channel uh where
we have discussed about it more in depth
and with more examples as well
and also you might have a doubt that
when to use Group by and when to use the
order by statement now if you want to
form the group of uh the set of records
are the identical columns having values
in them then you must use Group by
clause and in case you want to arrange
the data of a single or a multiple
column uh with variable different
conditions or in that case you have to
use the order by to sort the data in
ascending or descending order session
we're going to learn about between
operator and SQL now SQL provides us
with many such tools that help in
retrieving useful information from all
kinds of data sometimes we need to
retrieve only a particular range of
values from all the values of a tables
column for example to retrieve the
information about all the employees of a
company born in a particular decade or a
year or let's say to find the salaries
of all his employees in a particular
range you need a tool for that now SQL
between operator helps in performing
these activities and is an integral part
of this query language so in today's
session we are going to discuss about
the between operator in detail with its
syntax and execution in MySQL workbench
so without any further Ado let's get
started with today's topic so as you can
see MySQL workbench has started and
before getting into the execution but
let us just quickly understand what is
between operator and SQL now the SQL
between operator is used to test whether
an expression is within a range of
values or not his operator is inclusive
so it includes only the start and end
values of the range and the values can
be textual numerical type or date type
now between operator can be used with
select insert update as well as the
delete command so to get a clear picture
of how this operator works let us get
into the syntax of it now the syntax is
followed as select column names from
table name where column name between
range start and range ends so the
columns to be retrieved are specified
after the select statement and that and
the table The Columns are being
retrieved from the specified is this is
from statement and then we have the
between operator which is used in the
where Clause the column we want to apply
the range condition on is specified with
the column name parameter and the
starting value of the range of values is
specified in the range start parameter
and the ending value in the range and
parameter so now that we've understood
how exactly the between operator works
let us get into some examples and
understand its execution part so let us
take an example to understand the SQL
between operator so I am taking the new
employees uh as the example here so let
me just display the values for that I'm
using the select operator select star
from new employees let us execute the
statement so the new employees table has
various columns such as Employer ID
first name last name email phone number
hiring date job ID salary manager ID
Department ID
that's it so all right now we'll take a
simple example uh to understand the
between operator so let's say if you
want to retrieve the ID and name of the
employees with IDs in the range let's
say now we have IDs up to range like 198
200 2.1 so let us take uh the range
between 110 and let's say 170 then we'll
use the following query as select
employee ID
comma first name
from table that is new employees
use the where condition
where employee ID
between is the keyword
110 and 170.
so let us execute this and we'll see the
output
so as you can see it will display the
records of all those employees whose
employee ID lies between the range that
is 110 and 170. now if any employee
who's having their employee ideas 110
even their values are also included in
the resultant set and similarly if any
employee has 170 in their as their
employee ID even their data will be in
the result and set now in the table we
do not have any employee who's having
the employee ideas 170 so we do not have
their information now so in this case it
will only display only the details of
all those employees who's having the
employee ID range in 110 and 170 and
170. well moving ahead let us take next
another example now we can use the order
by statement also to sort the result
based on some columns now let's say if
you uh want to retrieve the details of
all those employees with salary ranging
from 35 000 to let's say 75 000 and in
order to sort this result based on the
salary we'll use the following query as
cell select in order to display all the
details so I'm using the star operator
select stars from new employee
where
salary
between 35 000
and let us take let's say 55 000.
right and I'll use the order by
salary
so that it will display the values of
all the salaries in the ascending order
so let us execute and we'll see the
output
so as you can see there are only uh
five employees in our new employees
table uh for example run scale Ladwig
who is working as a clerk is having
salary 36000 which is in the bracket of
thirty five thousand and fifty five
thousand similarly we have Diana
Lawrence who sell this 42 000 similarly
we have Jennifer Valen who salary is 44
000 and so on so in general we use the
between operator to find the range of
values like for example we are finding
the salary range right so in a similar
way we can use the between operator
to find the range between two given
values of a particular column
now similarly we can use the not
operator with between as well now we can
also use the not operator with the
between operator to select the values
that do not belong to that specified
range now instead of using between if I
mention the not between keyword here
it'll basically display all those
records of employees whose salary is not
in the ring of 35 000 and 55 000. now it
will display the records of all those
employees like if you take Hermann bear
whose salary is 10 000 which is not in
the bracket or in the range of 35 000
and 55 000. similarly it will display
the records of all those employees whose
salary is not in between that range
which is 35
000 and 55 000. in this way you can use
the not between keyword as well which
will exclude uh the results that are not
in the given range now you can use the
between operator with the date values as
well now when using the between with
dates or the date time values we need to
remember to enclose the date in single
inverted commas as otherwise the credit
they will return a syntax error so let
us take an example here let's say if I
want to retrieve the details of all
those employees whose hiring date is in
between let's say 2000 and 2007. now as
you can see our hiring date is between
like 2005 2004
2002 and similarly Etc right so in that
in that case I want to display all those
employee details whose hiring date was
in between 2000s and 2007. so in that
case the following query would be select
starts from new employees again which
will display all the records where
higher date
between ancient inverted commas so I'll
take from 1st January
and
31st December
2007.
right so let us execute this statement
and we'll see the output
so it will display me the records of all
those employees who have their hiring
date in between this range which is
January 1st 2000 and 31st December 2007.
so in this way you can use the between
operator with the date values as well
right moving ahead uh now we can use the
between operator with the text values as
well between operator can also be used
with the character data types like for
example while using any text values we
need to remember to again enclose the
data in single inverted commas otherwise
it will return a syntax error so let us
take an example here let's say uh we
want to retrieve all the employee
details and along with their names
belonging to our range from let's say
alphabets A and J that means we want the
details of all those employees whose
name is in between the first letter that
is a and the letter J in that case the
following query would be select start
from new employees
where I'm taking first name
right first name
between
letter a and letter j
and close them in the inverted commas
and we'll see the output now
so let us also order
we'll use the order by statement so that
will have an ascending order
I think there is a no need for that so
we'll just directly uh
execute this so as you can see it will
display the records of all those
employees uh whose name is in the range
with starting letter a and the starting
letter J now you can see Donald
O'Connell whose first name starts with d
right so it is in the range of a and j
it will it lies between a and j and
similarly we have Hermann we have
Alexander and David guy himero Etc
so in this way you can use the between
operator to find the values in a
particular range which have only text
data types and that brings us to the end
of today's session guys that was a quick
tutorial on how to use the between
operator in SQL if you remember all the
SQL between operator rules and syntaxes
you can easily customize your queries to
retrieve the type of information that
you want this tool along with other SQL
tools enables us to write different
kinds of essential queries now this
between operator is generally used to
find the values within a certain range
for example you can find the salaries of
employees within a certain brackets you
can also find the marks of the students
in a particular range and similarly you
can find the details of the products
which lie in a certain range so in all
these cases you can use the between
operator as per requirement so now that
you know about the between operator it
is time for you to start using the
between operator along with other SQL
commands Clauses and operators to query
your database tables in today's session
we'll have a detailed comparison between
the where and having Clause now let's
say you are navigating through a huge
database and you wish to display only
certain records that satisfy a
particular condition now carrying this
search process is extremely difficult
and is also time taking now in order to
save time and make your search easier we
use the where and having clause which is
used to explicitly filter out only those
records that meet the condition
specified by the user more on that soon
firstly let us discuss the agenda for
today's session we'll start the tutorial
by understanding what is SQL where
clause and then we'll discuss what is
SQL having clause and then we'll have a
detail in comparison between where and
having clause and finally we look at the
syntax and implement the execution part
in MySQL workbench so let us now dive
into today's topic
so firstly we'll discuss what is where
Clause the SQL where Clause is used to
specify a condition while fetching the
data from more than one table or by
joining with multiple tables if the
given condition is satisfied then only
it returns a specific value from the
table now we can use the wire plus to
filter the records and fetch only the
necessary requests from our database the
where Clause is not only used in the
select statement but it is also used in
the update delete
Etc
let us now understand this syntax the
syntax is simple and is followed as
select column 1 column two so on from
table name where condition
let us understand with an example
consider the employee table here which
is having various columns such as ID
name age City and salary now let's say
if I want to uh find the employee who is
having the maximum salary in this table
and for that I'll write a query stating
select star from employee where salary
is greater than 50 000. now if you
implement this query it will basically
show those records which is having
salary more than 50 000 now if you look
into the table abhay Kumar whose ID is
1175 is having 52 600 which is greater
than 50 000. so in this way where
basically uh meets the condition that is
set by the user
let us now understand what is having
clause in SQL
the having Clause is generally used
along with the group by clause and
having Clause is used to filter the
results obtained by the group by Clause
based on some specific condition having
Clause is quite similar to that of where
Clause as both are used to filter
records in SQL but where Clause cannot
be used with the aggregate functions
like count Max sum and Etc which is why
having Clause is needed and that is the
reason we use the having clause
let us now understand the syntax the
syntax is also similar you have to
mention the having keyword here instead
of where and the syntax is followed as
select column one column two from table
name Group by column 1 column two so on
having and mentioned the condition now
group a clause is used to arrange the
data into groups and having Clause is
used in the column operations and it
basically uh group all the identical
data and gives you the condition that is
specified by the U
let us understand this with an example
again consider the same employee table
here which is having ID name HCT and
salary now
as we know we have to use uh aggregate
functions so I'm using the average
function here and since the having plus
also uses a group by
um so that is the reason I'm also using
the group back
now let's say if I want to find the
average salary of all the employees from
different cities then the following
query would be select City average
salary from employee Group by city now
when I perform this query the this will
be the following output where it will
show the resultant set of all the cities
and their average salary now we have New
Delhi that is being repeated twice which
is two records and we have ghaziabad
which is two records now New Delhi has
two requests which is having 36 000 and
38 000. now if you consider the average
it is basically 37 000 and similarly for
ghaziabad we have three records which
have salaries for six thousand five
hundred for two thousand six hundred
fifty two thousand six hundred now when
you calculate the average it is showing
us forty seven thousand two thirty three
now now that you have applied this now
let us have the having condition here
now let's say if I want to find the
average salary of all those employees
from different cities who is having
average salary greater than 40 000.
now in this case if I implement this
query this will be the following output
as you can see both ghaziabad and Noida
has the average salary more than forty
thousand that is forty seven thousand
two thirty three and forty eight
thousand so in this way you can use the
SQL having Clause as well
let us now look at the differences
between these two classes that is a
skill wear and having Plus
now SQL where Clause basically filters
the individual rows in the table based
on the specific condition whereas the
having Clause filters groups instead of
one row at a time
now as discussed earlier where Clauses
can be used with select update delete
statement whereas the having uh Clause
can be used only with the select
statement
now where comes before group a which
means that where plus filters Rose
performing aggregate calculations and
having comes after Group by which means
the having plus filters rows after
performing aggregate uh calculations so
consequently having is or slower than
where in terms of complexity and
efficiency as well
now as discussed earlier where class
cannot contain aggregate functions and
having plus can contain aggregate
functions such as count sum average
Etc
now SQL wire is considered as a
pre-filter because it performs the row
operations first and having Clause is
considered as the cost filter because it
performs the column operations after
grouping the data
so now that we have understood about
these both types of SQL Clauses let us
jump into MySQL workbench for the
execution part if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
so as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and on the left side you can
view the simply code database which is
having different tables such as customer
Department employee employees one and
Etc now to perform the where and having
plus statements we'll use the employees
once uh table so let me just display the
records present in that table so I'll
use the select operator select star from
employee
employee one table
click on the execute Button as you can
see the employees one table has various
columns such as employee ID first name
last name of the employee their email ID
phone numbers hiring date job ID salary
manager ID and Department ID
so firstly let us discuss about the
where clause or basically where
condition so let's say if you want to
fetch the records of all those employees
from these employees one table whose
salary is let's say less than 5000 and
they belong to Department 30.
so in that case the following query
would be
select
star
from employees
table one
where
salary is less than five thousand
now I'm using the and operator which is
basically a logical operator so whenever
you're performing the where condition
you can use the logical operators and
comparison operators of a logical
operators such as and or between Etc and
the comparison operators like less than
equal to less than greater than equals
to
Etc
so I'm using the and operator here and
Department ID
is equals to 30.
so let me execute this statement and see
the output
so as you can see there are total of
four employees whose salary is less than
50 000 and they belong to the Department
30.
now you can also as discussed earlier
you can also perform the update
operations uh using the where uh
Clause as well now let's say if I want
to update the salary of uh employee who
is having employee ID 116 as let's say
10 000 then the query would be update
table name that is employee one
salary equals to 10 000
where
employee ID
is equals to let's say 160.
an employee name is Shelly baida so I'm
just uh
taking that example so let me just
execute this query so as you can see our
query has been successfully executed so
let me just verify whether it is
executed or not so I'll use the select
statement select start from
employee one
where
employee ID
equals to 160.
so let me run this query and we'll see
the output so as you can see the
employee uh Shelley bada who's having
employee ID 116 and their salary has
been changed into Ten Thousand Years
successfully so in this way you can use
the uh where Clause as well
you can also use the where clause for
delete also now let's say if I want to
delete uh the details of the employees
who's having employee ideas 120 let's
say then I'll use the delete statement
delete
from
employee one
where
employee ID is equals to 120.
so let me just execute this query
so as you can see our query has been
successfully executed here and the
details of the employee who's having
employed as 127 has been deleted
successfully so in this way you can use
the where Clause to perform various
operations such as select update delete
Etc using comparison and logical
operators let us now understand about
the having clause for that let me take
an example let's say if you want to
display the records of all those
employees present in different
departments and whose average salary is
uh greater than let's say a 5000. so in
that case the following query would be
select
now I want to display the department ID
so I'm taking the department ID column
average salary
from employees
one
now as you know while using the uh
having Clause we have to use the group
by uh statement as well so I'll Group by
all the department IDs since we have
multiple Department IDs present in the
table
Department ID
having
average salary
greater than 5000.
five thousand dollars okay let me just
display the output
so our query has been successfully
executed and as you can see here it is
displaying all the different departments
uh and their average salaries as well
here now I can use the different
aggregate functions here as well if I
want to count uh the number of employees
in each department I can take the count
function so let me just use it count
employee ID which will basically count
all the total employees in the different
departments so let me just execute this
statement
so as you can see it will display the
count of all the employees that are
present in different departments and
having average salary more than 50 000.
so in this way you can use the having uh
Clause as well now we can also combine
both the where condition as well as the
uh having condition as well
now we can combine the where and having
plus together in a select query in this
case the where Clause is used first to
filter individual rows and then the rows
are then grouped to perform the
aggregate calculations and finally the
having Clause is used to filter the
grouped data that is the identical
groups that are having the same values
now as discussed earlier uh
we have to use the where condition
before the group by so I am just taking
the wire Clause before the group by and
let's say if I want to display only
those uh departments that are having
more than 80.
as the department ID so Department
ID
greater than 80.
so let me just display
so as you can see it will display only
those records where the department ID is
more than 80 that is 1900 and 110 and
the details of all the employees whose
average salary is more than 500. now I
can also use the order by uh statement
here in order to mention all these
records in a systematic manner that is
an ascending or descending order so
order by
Department ID
so let us execute this query so as you
can see it will showcase the department
ID values in the ascending order that is
1900 and 110. so in this way you can use
the having Clause as well in SQL so what
is a sub query an SQL sub query is a
query which is written inside another
query a sub query is usually added
within the where Clause of another SQL
select statement in a sub query the
outer queries result is dependent on the
result set of the inner query and that
is the reason why sub queries are also
called as the nested queries uh sub
queries also called as an inner query or
inner select while the statement
containing the main query or the parent
query is called as the outer query or
outer select query statement
now the inner query executes first
before its uh parent query or the outer
query so that the results of an inner
query can be passed to the outer query
let us understand this uh with an
example here now consider this syntax
over here which is followed as select
employee name Department from employee
where salary equals to select maximum
salary from employee now select employee
name Department from employees the outer
query and the rest part is the inner
query now when the above query is
applied to the given employee table here
the sub query is executed first which
select the maximum salary from the
employee table then the resultant is the
passed onto the where Clause of the
outer query now this outer query is
executed which selects the rows in this
case the employee name and the
department from the employee table where
the salary is equals to the resultant of
the sub query which is the it selects
the maximum salary from the employee
table Returns the final result
so let us now look at the types of sub
queries that are used in SQL now sub
queries in SQL are majorly used with
insert delete select update statement
along with the comparison operators like
less than equals to greater than or
equals to between in and Etc
uh sub queries are used to execute a
query dependent on the outcome of
another query and it allows the user to
fetch the results without writing two
distinct queries and it is time saving
as well so now that we have understood
what is sub queries under different
types let us jump into MySQL workbench
uh to execute the various sub queries
that are used in SQL so as you can see
MySQL workbench has started and we have
various tables in our database simply
code such as customer Department
employee employee one and so on firstly
let us discuss the sub queries using the
select statement now in SQL in most of
the cases we use the select statement to
perform the sub queries so for that let
us consider the table employees one here
so let me just display the records that
are present in the table for that I am
using the select statement Select Staff
from employee
C1
so let us run the query and see the
records so as you can see the employees
one table has various columns such as
employee ID first name last name emails
their phone number hiring date job ID
salary manager ID and Department ID
now let us understand this concept with
the help of an example for executing the
select statement using the sub queries
now let's say if I want to find all
those employees whose salary is less
than the average salary of all the
employees that is present in the
employees one table so in this scenario
we'll use a sub query to get those
employees whose salary is less than the
average salary from the employee table
and the following query would be
select now since I want to display all
the records I am using the star operator
from
employees1
where
salary
is less than and within the parenthesis
we have to mention the sub query that is
Select
average salary
from
employees one table so let us execute
the statement and see the output
foreign
there is a render in the code just let
me check so yeah I forgot to mention the
parenthesis here uh make sure you uh
write the sub queries always within the
parenthesis otherwise it will show an
error here so now let us understand this
query and let us break this query
statement to understand in a better way
now here the query to find out the
average salary is this sub query here
that is the select average salary from
the employee one table so let me just
execute this statement
so we have the average salary that is
six thousand seven or eight point six
six so now the outer query takes the
result of this inner query which is
basically the sub query and executes the
remaining SQL command based on the
result so the sub query first Returns
the average salary that is six Thousand
Seven not eight and this result is
passed on to the outer query which
fetches the details of all those
employees who's having salary less than
the average salary that is six thousand
seven or eight so when execute this
statement it will display the applies of
all those records who's having salary
less than 6007 on it that is uh 2600
4400 and so on
in this way so in this way you can use
the select statement to perform the sub
queries in SQL if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
now other than uh the SQL select
statement SQL sub queries can also be
used with the insert statement in the in
such statement
the data returned from the sub queries
used to insert the data from one table
that is the existing table into another
new table
now let us consider the employee table
here so let me just display the records
select star from employee
let me just display the records now so
the employee table has various Fields
such as employee ID employee name age
designation City total salary date of
joining Department ID and bonus now if I
want to copy this data from the employee
table into a new table let's say
employee new table so I'll have I can
use the sub queries with the insert
statement here so let me just create a
new table here and the query is followed
as create table employee new the
employee new table has the employee ID
employee name designation total sorry
that's it so I'm taking primary key as
employee ID as it uniquely identifies
the each record in the table
so let me just execute the statement
now I'll use the select statement
now as you can see the employee new
table has various Fields employee ID
employee name designation and total
salary but we do not have any values
that are present in the employee new
table so we'll use the sub query using
the insert statement to into insert
values into it now let's say if I want
to insert the values from the employee
table that is the existing table whose
salary is uh greater than 30 000.
so I want to fetch only those records
from the employee table into the
employee new table of salary is greater
than 40 000 so the following query would
be insert into
the new table that is employee new
select
now since we are only concerned with the
employee ID employee name designation
and total salary we'll mention only
those columns employee employee ID
employee name
designation
total salary
from the previous existing table that is
our employee table
where
total salary
I'm using the in operator here
and within the parenthesis I'll write
the sub query that is Select
total salary
from
employee
where
total salary
is greater than forty thousand
close the parenthesis and let us execute
the statement now
so our statement has been successfully
executed so let me just display the
records again
select star from the table employee new
yeah
so as you can see it will uh insert only
those records for all those employees
total salary is greater than 40 000. so
we have only two employees who's having
salary is fifty thousand and sixty
thousand
now the insert statement basically
specifies that new data is added to this
table that is the employee new table and
as we are copying all the data from the
employee table which is our existing
table to the new employee new table
there is no need to specify the column
name in the insert statement otherwise
you would need to mention the column
name in which you want to add the data
the only thing that you have to keep in
mind is that the table structure has to
remain the same even if the column names
are a bit different the column data
types have must remain the same in order
to insert the data using sub queries
from one table to another table so in
this way you can write sub queries using
the insert statement as well also in the
similar way you can use the update as
well as the delete statement to modify
the existing data that is present in the
table
to know more about it make sure to check
out our SQL full course for beginners
2022 on our channel so that brings us to
the end of today's session guys that was
all about sub queries in SQL to create
and for the execution part of the
functions let us jump into MySQL
workbench so as you can see MySQL
workbench has started and before
understanding the syntax of how to
create a functions let us just
understand what a function is actually
is now a function in SQL is basically a
set of SQL statements that performs a
specific task now if you have to
repeatedly write a larger SQL queries to
perform a task you can simply create a
function for that now next time instead
of rewriting the whole SQL query you can
just simply call that function to get
the desired result
now these SQL functions are basically
programs either developed by the user or
already provided by the SQL system now
we have several email functions or the
system defined functions like aggregate
functions string functions date
functions Etc now other than that we can
create a user defined function as well
so firstly let us go through the syntax
uh on how to create a function so the
syntax is followed as delimiter which I
am explaining in a while when we are
creating the actual functions so let us
keep it aside for a while create
function function name and inside the
parenthesis mention the parameters now
you can create a number of parameters as
per your choice uh the thing is you have
to mention the parameter name as well as
its data type returns data type
deterministic begin and inside that we
have to write the code that is the
actual code for the function and use the
end so let me just explain how this
syntax Works firstly we are specifying
the name of the stored function that we
want to create after the create function
keyword next we have to list all the
parameters of the stored function inside
the parenthesis followed by the function
name and then we are specifying the data
type of the return value in the return
statement which can be valid using any
data type here as well like int car
worker Etc and then we are specifying if
a function is deterministic or not now a
deterministic function always results
Returns the same uh value for the same
input parameters
whereas a non-deterministic function
returns different result for the same
input parameters so let me just explain
this an example now if I take a function
x y z and I am specifying a parameter
let's say PE function so it will always
result the same answer as long as its
input that is p is the same
and finally we'll write the code in the
body section after the begin keyword so
this code will be written uh in the body
of the stored function in the begin end
block now inside the body section you
need to specify at least one return
statement this return statement
basically returns a value to the calling
program now whenever the return
statement is reached this execution of
this function is terminated
automatically
so let us now understand this with an
example uh we have a query here which
says like uh create a function bonus
status which has one parameter salary of
type care and returns wire care of size
20. now we have to use the following
operations in the statement to create
this function the first one is return
eligible for bonus as the statement if
salary is greater than 35 000 else
return not eligible
so let us now write the Syntax for this
so let me just switch to another Tab and
we'll write the query here first write
the
keyword that is create function
now the function is bonus status
inside the parenthesis mention the
parameter now I am taking parameter as
salary here which is of character I am
giving sizes 20.
close the parenthesis
now mention the return return statement
that is it returns
of size 20.
deterministic
as the keyword that we are using here
again
and inside this we have to write our
main query now the query that we have
earlier discussed is that if salary
is greater than 35 000.
then
return
eligible for bonus
eligible for bonus and close the
parenthesis
else
return
else return
inside the parenthesis
not eligible
mention the double quotes and close the
parenthesis and put a semicolon
now that's it that is the end of our
body so now I'll use the end if
statement
which will basically close the body of
our function and then I'll use the end
uh
operator here
with the dollar signed
and that is it this is basically our
code for it to create a function so let
us now execute this statement and see
the output now while I execute the
statement it will throw an error and
this is where we'll use the uh SQL
delimiter
now as you know when we write an SQL
statement you use the semicolon after
the SQL statement uh like if you write a
two separate statement for example uh if
I say
select
start from like I'm taking an example as
employee and I'm taking another example
as select star
from orders
now when I execute this query it will
throw an output because I haven't
selected which query I want to execute
now for that we'll place an individual
semicolon for at the end of our
statement right so in a similar way
from MySQL uses the delimiter function
to separate statement and executes each
statement separately now however a
function consists of a multiple
statements separated by a semicolon so
if you used to define a function that
contains semicolon characters then it
will not treat the whole function as a
single statement but many statements
therefore you must redefine the
delimiter temporarily so that you can
pass the whole function as a single
statement so for that we'll use the
delimiter here so let me just
incorporate the delimiter here
you have to use delimiter with the help
of a double slash or double dollar sign
here
we have to specify at the beginning as
well as the end
and I'll mention two double so that's it
now our code is complete and let us
execute the statement now
so our query has been successfully
executed now to see whether our function
is created or not let us just refresh
the schema here and as you can see in
function section you can see bonus
status which is the function we have
created earlier has been created
successfully so let us now just verify
whether our function is working or not
so I'll just write a simple query as
select
bonus status
let us take 40 000 as our example
so let me just execute this statement
and we'll see the output
so as you can see uh the condition which
is specified is if the cell is greater
than 35 000 then the employees eligible
for bonus now since we have taken the
salary is 40 000 it is showing us
eligible for bonus now similarly let's
say if I take uh twenty thousand
and if I execute the statement it will
definitely show me not eligible
as you can see it will show not eligible
for bonus
so in this way you can create and user
defined function by passing certain
parameters to get the desired result of
your choice so now that you've created a
function you can query an already
existing table by calling that function
in an SQL statement by passing certain
parameters into that function let us
understand this with an example consider
the employee table here so let me just
display the records in that employee
table so as you can see the employee
table has various columns such as
employee ID employee name age
designation cities total salary date of
joining and Department ID Now using this
already created functions let's say if I
want to know whether the employee is
eligible for the bonus or not using
their total salary I'll use the function
and to achieve that I'll simply use the
select statement to display the records
so let me just write the query here
select I want to fetch the employee ID
employee name the total salary so I am
mentioning The Columns employee ID
employee name
their total salary
I'll call the function here that is our
bonus status
and inside the function I am going to
pass the uh parameter which is the total
salary on which we'll know whether the
employee is eligible for bonus or not so
I am taking as total salary
from the table that is employee so let
us execute this statement and see the
output
so there was a mistake in the function
name so let us execute the statement now
and we'll see the output
so as you can see based on the total
salary and the functions that we have
created earlier it will result whether
or not the employees eligible for bonus
or not now you can see the employer
Rahul who's having salary 40 000 which
is above 35 000. so in this case it is
showing as eligible for bonus now if you
consider another employee Varun whose
salary is 30 000 Which is less than 35
000 so that is why it is showing is not
eligible in this way and for the rest of
the employees also it will show the uh
same as per the condition that we have
specified in our function that is the
salary should be greater than 35 000. so
in this way you can simply call a
function using its name and provide the
parameter and get the required output
now the other important thing to notice
here is that we have used the function
as a column as a parameter in our select
query now we have passed the parameter
that is total salary into our function
so that is bonus status and the function
returned a result of this calculation
now in this way a skill function can be
very useful as we have avoided writing
complex calculations in a select query
and also we can reuse this function
later in any other queries as well and
that brings us to the end of today's
session guys I hope you understood how
to create a user defined function and in
today's session we are going to talk
about another important function that is
conversion functions in SQL in this
tutorial we are going to cover about the
cast and conversion which are most
commonly used conversion functions in
SQL more on that soon but before we get
started if you are new to the channel
and haven't subscribed already consider
getting subscribed to our Channel simply
code to stay updated with all the latest
tech content and hit that Bell icon to
never miss an update from us so without
any further Ado let's get started with
today's topic
firstly let us discuss the agenda for
today's session we'll start the tutorial
by understanding what is cast function
and then we'll discuss what is convert
function and next we'll have a detailed
comparison between the cast and convert
function and see how they are different
from each other and finally we'll
execute these two functions in MySQL
workbench using various examples
so let us get started with today's topic
so firstly what is cast function the
cache function in SQL is one of the most
commonly used conversion function which
allows the user to convert from one data
type to another it is very useful for
concatenating results from various data
types now this conversion can be either
a single expression or the values from
the columns in the SQL tables
it also allows the user to perform
calculations on two different data types
as well now using cast it does not
change the data completely in the
database this conversion of data from
one data type to another is only valid
while the query is running and is not
permanent that is the changes to the
query is only done on a temporary basis
however it is possible to convert and
insert into a new column or table as
well let us now understand the syntax of
cache function the syntax is followed as
cast expression as data type length
expression here represents the data
which we want to convert and the data
type specifies uh the data type which we
want to convert the value and finally
the length of the data which is optional
you can give it as per your requirement
for only certain data types such as
ncare or VAR care
now let us consider an example here
which says select cached 76.87 as it
here I am taking a string value which is
76.87 and I'm converting this data type
into the int value now the output is as
expected that is 76 which is an integer
value in this way you can use the cast
function to change one data type to
another data type in real time
next let us discuss about what is
convert function
the convert function converts an
expression in one data type to
corresponding value in other data type
now you might be confused that the
convert is different from the cache
function convert is similar to that of
cache function as well while the
functionality of both these conversion
functions is same the only main
difference is the syntax and the usage
so you can specify the format to convert
as well as the data type in the convert
function and it is a very useful
function especially for converting the
strings to date formats and the syntax
is followed as convert expression comma
data type now again the data type
parameter defines the target data which
is to be converted now and the data type
parameter can take data types as an
input such as big in small and decimal
numeric values float values character
values variable characters in care Etc
and the length is optional parameter
which specifies the target data type
length and the default of this parameter
is around 10 or 20.
now we also have the expression this
parameter specifies the value in which
we want to convert to another data type
so let us consider an example here which
is Select convert
2022.06.07 as date now this is basically
a string value or you can say a part of
a decimal value and I'm changing this
string or character into date format
which is 2022 hyphen 0 6 hyphen 0 7
which is converted into date format so
in this way you can use the convert
function as well
let us now understand the difference
between the cast and convert function in
SQL now both these SQL conversion
functions are row functions which are
capable of typecasting column values or
an expression from one data type to
another and the functionality of both of
the functions are almost similar but
there are some major differences in them
as well
now both the cash function cast and
convert function are obviously are used
to convert one data type to another data
type and one of the main difference is
the syntax now the syntax of cast is
very simple it includes the value to
convert and the type of resulting data
type it has as a keyword to separate the
data type from the value and there is an
option to express the length which is
the integer that specifies the length of
the target data type and on the other
hand the convert syntax mentions the
resulting data type first along with the
optional length there is another
expression and another optional
parameter called style in the convert
function which is only specific to the
SQL Server database now this style
allows formatting the data type and
specifies how the convert function
should translate or format the data type
now apart from this there are some
certain differences as well the cache is
an ANSI standard function that is cast
is uh considered as the American
National Standard institute's standard
function that means it is applicable to
most of the SQL databases out there like
postview SQL MySQL mariadb mongodb Etc
on the other hand conversion function is
a specific function that is only
restricted to mainly Microsoft SQL
Server cache function is also more
portable function of these two it means
that the cache function can be used by
many databases out there and also cache
is considered less powerful and less
flexible than the convert function and
on the other hand the convert function
is generally considered as a flexible
function which allows more flexibility
and is mostly preferred to use for date
time values Etc convert is also useful
in formatting the data's format as well
and finally cache function is used to
convert a data type without a specific
format whereas the convert function does
converting and formatting data types
simultaneously
now for example cast cannot convert a
date time to specific format whereas the
convert function can do that so these
were some major differences between the
cache and convert function I know you
might be confusing at first because
there isn't much difference between
these two functions and also there is no
difference in the performance of these
two functions as well so it's just a
matter of preference to choose which
function to use you can choose to use
cast when you work with multiple
relational databases and the syntaxes
are pretty standardized easy to remember
and since it is an ANSI standard
function you can use it in any database
as well
on the other hand if you need to specify
the output styling we can use the
convert function for that and even
though the style is optional and is
limited to certain uh databases like SQL
Server the cast function is often is
used to preserve decimal values and
places while converting between decimal
numeric values whereas the convert
function cannot do this so it is a
matter of requirement when to use both
these functions and it is up to the user
to choose between these both conversion
functions so now that we have understood
about these two functions let us jump
into MySQL workbench for execution part
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and we can now work on our
conversion functions firstly let us
discuss about the cast function in SQL
so let us take an example for this let's
say if I want to convert a string value
into an integer data type then the
following query would be select cast
and within the parenthesis let's say I
have a string value which is
45.68 and I want to change this into int
data type so I'll mention int
as end which is the keyword we use in
the cached functions so let us now
execute this statement and see the
output
now it will show me an error that's
because the in data type is not
supported in MySQL workbench if you are
working on cast function so instead of
India you can take the sine function
which is basically a sister group of the
int data type so you can take the signed
integer as well so let us now display
this value so as you can see it will
return me the 46 which will round off
the decimal value which is 45.68 to 46.
now let us take another example let's
say I have a string value I want to
change it into date format so then the
following query would be select cast
so let me just uh take some string
values like 22 comma
9 comma 24.
as date
so let us execute this statement and
we'll see the output
so as you can see the string value that
we have taken here that suggests 22 924
has been changed into date format which
is 2022 which is the year 9 is the month
and 24 is the date which is in the
format of year month and date now if you
pass the values here which is not in the
range of the function that of the
derivative that you have specified in
this function for example instead of 9
if I take 14 and let's say if I want to
pass this function then it will show me
a null value that's because the value 14
is not in the range of the date value
that is
14 there are only like 12 months rights
from so the values it can take is from
only from 1 to 12. now if you pass other
than this range then it will show an
error now similarly if I want to uh
specify this value into date time
function then I can simply mention the
daytime function data type as well
so let us see the output
so it will show me the output in the
form of uh date as well as the time
format here
so let us now understand another example
now as discussed earlier a cache
function not only changes the data type
of an expression it can also change the
data type of the column values in the
table as well so for that let us take an
example for this let me consider the
restaurant orders table here now I have
this price column which is in decimal
values now let's say if I want to round
off these values into integer values
then the following query would be select
cast
mention the parameter which is price as
signed
from the table name that is restaurant
orders
so let us execute and see the output
so as you can see the prices are being
changed into the integer values now and
the decimal values have been rounded off
so similarly if I want to mention the
columns I can mention them as well so
I'll take the item name the previous
price and the change price so I'm giving
this change price as the new price as a
new column
so let us now execute this statement and
see the output so as you can see it will
display uh the item name the price and
the new price of these items now as you
can see the price of the Tandoori mix
Grill which is 11.95 has been rounded
off to an integer value that is 12 and
similarly all the other values as well
now if you scroll down a bit as you can
see we have a price which is 0.5 and the
new price is changed into zero which is
not acceptable right now the price has
should be of a value now instead of sign
if you can take the decimal data type uh
wherein you can mention this and it will
change the value into the nearest value
of the decimal value now as you can see
here the 0.5 has been rounded off to 1
here and similarly 0.8 which is more
than 0.5 is also rounded to 1. so in
this way you can use the cast function
to change the data type accordingly so
now that we have covered the cached
functions let us now see a few data type
conversions here which will help you
understand the usage of the conversion
convert function as well
now firstly let us start with the
decimal data type now as the date as the
name suggests decimal produces a decimal
value and has two optional parameters
which is basically m and d where m is
the maximum number of digits that you
want to show in the resultant table or
which is also known as precision and D
is a number of digits after the decimal
points from the scale are you understand
with an example here so the following
query would be select convert
and inside the convert mention the
expression so I'm taking the value as
let's say 21.345
and I want to change this value into
decimal data type and inside the decimal
I am mention the parameters so I'm
taking as let's say
7 as the total number of digits that I
will display and I am taking only two
decimal values that I want to display
after the decimal point
all right so let us just execute this
statement and we'll see the output
so as you can see it will show me only
the uh two values that is 3 5 after the
decimal point so the output is 21.35 now
the value that you have taken is 21.345
which is converted into decimal uh data
type format which is 21.35 basically it
will round up the value of 345 into 3 5.
now similarly you can convert the values
into date and time data types as well in
using the convert function so let us
consider the example for that as well so
select convert
let's say now I have a value 10 comma 25
as date time
data type so we'll convert this into
date time uh data type so let's see the
output
so as you can see the value of the
string value which you have specified
here as 11 10 25 it will be changed into
the date time data type that is 2011 10
25 and the time as well and similarly
you can use the convert function to
change a number or a string value into
year type as well so let's say I'm
taking a value 22 and I want to change
this string value into your data type so
the following query would be select
convert 22 as EO
so as you can see the output the value
of the string value that we have taken
is 22 has been now converted into 2022
which is in the format of year data type
now similarly you can convert a string
value into the time as well so let's say
I'm taking a value like let's say 0 9 17
26.
and I'm specifying the data type as time
so let us see the output for this as
well
so as you can see the string value that
we have taken as 0 9 1 7 2 6 which is
basically a number and we want to
convert that number into time data type
so it will display the value as 9 17 26
which is in the format of harsh minutes
and seconds and that brings us to the
end of today's session guys that was all
about the MySQL conversion functions we
have studied and understood what convert
and cast function does how exactly it
works its parameters with some examples
now you can try converting the value in
every valid data type using these two
functions that is convert and cast
so I hope you found this tutorial
helpful and informative we'll start the
tutorial by understanding what is commit
in SQL and discuss why we use commit and
then we'll understand what is rollback
in SQL and discuss why we use the
rollback command in SQL and then we'll
have a detailed comparison between
commit and roll back and see how they
are different from each other and
finally we'll execute both these
commands in MySQL workbench
so what is commit and rollback in SQL
commit and rollback are the commonly
used transaction control language
commands or TCL commands used in SQL
these TCL commands or transaction
control language commands are basically
used for managing and controlling the
transactions in a database to maintain
consistency and it also helps a user
manage all the changes made by the DML
commands for maintaining its
transactions TCL lets the statements get
grouped into a logical transactions now
to understand more about commit and roll
back it is important to understand what
exactly are transactions now a
transaction is basically a block of SQL
query or set of SQL statements executed
on the information and data stored in
the database management system
so any transaction when made happens
temporarily or permanently in database
now a user needs TCL commands to make
these changes permanent or temporary
for example if you're creating a record
or updating a record or even deleting
the records from the table then you are
performing a transaction on that table
so it is important to control these
transaction to ensure that the data
Integrity is maintained and it also
handles the database errors effectively
so generally you will incorporate many
SQL queries into a group and you will
execute all of them together as a part
of a transaction
next let us discuss about the commit
command in SQL the commit command in SQL
is a transaction command that is used to
save all the changes made by a
particular transaction in rdbms since
the last commit a rollback command is
used it signifies the end of a
successful transaction in an SQL
database
now generally the commit command is used
after a data manipulation language a DML
operations like insert delete and update
transactions now when you perform a DML
operation without a commit statement the
changes are only visible to you now you
can use a select statement and check the
updated records from this modified data
but once you use a commit command after
a transaction the changes in the table
or database are visible to other
database users as well now another thing
to keep in mind is that the database
cannot be restored to its previous state
once the combat command is executed
all the transaction commands obeys the
basic principles of asset properties in
SQL and the Syntax for commit and SQL is
followed as you the easy text is
basically the is uses just one keyword
that is commit and you can use this
commit using various DML operators like
insert update delete statements as well
now let us say for example I have an
employee table and from that I want to
delete an employee a record whose ID is
110. now when I perform this query it
will delete the employee ID 110 and then
if I perform a commit operation then it
will permanently save that transaction
that is it will completely delete the
records from the table next let us
discuss about the rollback in SQL the
rollback in SQL is a command that is
used to revert changes performed by
transaction now whenever a rollback
command is used it reverts all the
changes since the last Commander
rollback that we have made in our SQL
table
the syntax is similar to that it is
includes just one keyword that is
rollback and it is similarly used with
the insert update delete statement and
let's say for example I am deleting a
record whose ID is one not PSI and for
some reasons if I want that record back
in my table then I'll use the roll pack
command here which will restore the
deleted record that is the the ID of the
employee who's having is one or five so
it will revert back the changes that
were made in the database by bringing
back the original state
let us now understand some differences
between commit and rollback
the comment is used to save the changes
permanently in the database whereas the
rollback is used to undo the changes and
restore its previous States
the comment statement is basically used
after an internet transaction which has
been successfully completed that is if
you're performing any SQL operations or
transaction in SQL and if you are sure
that if there is no changes to be made
for that transaction only then you have
to use the commit statement whereas a
roadblock statement is used after a
transaction is unsuccessful due to any
circumstances like system failure Etc
after executing commit command any
transaction can't be used for rollback
which you've discussed earlier and on
the other hand after executing the
rollback command a transaction can be
still modified and send for commit again
so now that we have understood what
commit and rollback are let us jump into
MySQL Workman for execution part
as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and now by default MySQL
automatically commits the changes
permanently to the database so in order
to First MySQL not to commit changes
automatically we use a following
statement here which is followed as set
auto commit
to 0 so let me just display this uh okay
it is successfully executed now what
this basically does is it will not
commit any changes permanently that were
done prior to the database earlier or
else you can click on edit option here
and choose preferences and in
preferences you will find SQL execution
under the SQL editor section so you'll
find an option which says new
connections use Auto commit mode so if
you find a tick here in this checkbox
make sure you untick before you proceed
to commit and roll back commands so
click on OK so that you are good to go
now so let me just consider uh a table
here to perform the commit and roll back
commands here so for that I'm taking the
employee one table as a reference so let
me just display the records from that
table and I'll use the select statement
for that select star from employee one
so let me execute the statement
so in our employee one we have various
columns such as employee ID employee
name age designation City total salary
date of joining and Department ID
now to commit the current transaction
and make its changes permanent we use
the commit statement right so I'll use
the commit command here
and I'll execute this so now basically
what this does is it will
permanently or save the changes that
were done prior to this
database that is database table that is
the employment table
so let me just display the values now
so now let us perform some transactions
on this table so as we discussed earlier
we can use any DML operators like insert
update or delete to perform operations
using the commit and rollback command so
I'm going to use the update command here
so I'm basically updating the salary of
an employee let's say sanjana whose
employee ID is 2013 whose total salary
is thirty thousand now I want to update
that salary as 35 000 so for that I'm
using the update statement
update the table name that is employee
one
set total salary
as 35 000.
where
employee ID equals 2030.
right so let us execute this statement
so as you can see one row has been
affected and our query has been executed
successfully let me just display the
records again
so as you can see uh employee sanjana
whose employees 2013 herself a total
salary has been changed to 35 000 which
was earlier 30 000. now let's say in
future I have this requirement where I
want to have the original salary salary
or the previous salary now for that I
can use the rollback here
so when I execute the rollback
statement here and select this table
again
the total salary has been changed to 30
000 again so basically we have done a
transaction we have upgraded the total
salary of the employee sanjana to 35 000
and after that we are again rolling back
to its previous state that is again to
thirty thousand
now similarly you can perform another
transaction let's say using the delete
operation now I want to delete all the
records from this employee one table
whose designation is let's say business
analyst now we have a total of business
analyst uh one two three right we have
total three records so we'll be deleting
all these reports from the table so tell
it from employee one
where
where designation
equals to
business analyst
right so let me just execute the
statement
sorry the column name has been written
wrong so that is why it is showing me as
error
so as you can see our query has been
successfully executed and it shows three
rows are affected that makes all the
records of the employees whose
designation is business analysts have
been deleted see as you can clearly see
there are no records of business analyst
records right so again I have this
requirement where I want to get back the
results or the records of the employees
who are working as business analyst
from this employee one table so for that
I can simply use the rollback here so
we'll simultaneously perform to a
transaction here firstly we'll update
this table again
and then we'll delete which is already
done
so now let me just roll back this
statement again
so when I roll back this statement and
display the records from the table as
you can clearly see the employee sanjana
whose employed is 1013 her salary which
we have uh set as 35 000 has been
reverted back to 30 000 to its previous
or original state and similarly we have
deleted uh the records of employees
whose designation as business analyst
and similarly their records also have
been reverted back
so in this way you can use the rollback
command to get back to the current
transaction and cancel it changes
now let us take another scenario here
now what if I perform a transaction
before the commit command so for that
I'll take another another example where
I'll update the age of an employee let's
say Rahul is employed is 1013 and is
ages 26 I want to change it to 27 so
I'll use another update statement here
update
employee one table
set age equals to 27 so his previous age
was 26 now I'm changing it to 27
where employee ID is 1011.
all right so let me just execute the
statement
so it is successfully executed and we
will select the records so as you can
see rahul's age has been changed to 27
from 26. now let's say if I commit this
uh
transaction all right so I'll just
commit this transaction so basically you
cannot make any further changes uh to
this record since we have committed uh
the transaction already
so
I'll perform the uh two transactions
again here which is basically updating
the employees total salary to 35 000 and
deleting all the records of employees
whose designation is business analyst so
let me just uh
execute this
so as you can clearly see all our skill
Paris has been successfully executed so
let me just display the table here
now
all right
so as you can clearly see that we uh the
employee sanjana who's having one
employee ideas 1013 her salary has been
changed to 35
000 and we also have uh no records of
those employees whose designation is
business analyst and similarly the first
transaction which you have done which is
updating the salary of uh employee Rahul
whose ID is thousand and eleven to 27.
now let's say if I want to roll back
this Trends all these transactions so
let me just roll back here and we'll see
what happens so our rollback has been
successfully executed and let me just
display the records again
now all the changes done past the last
commit will be reverted if you roll back
a transaction since we have uh performed
two operations or transactions after
commit statement which is basically
updating uh the employee salary to 35
000 and delete the records of employees
whose designation is business analyst
now clearly we can see that their
records have been reverted back to their
original state so so like we have this
employee name sanjana whose salary was
30 000 which is we have changed to 35
000 and since we have rolled back again
to its previous state it is 30 000 and
similarly we all we have all the records
of the business analyst as well but if
you look at here we have
change the employees age here like we
have taken rahul's
age as 27 which was earlier 26 and we
have changed that to 27 but even after
rolling back this we haven't uh got the
original record that is his age is 26
that's because we have already committed
this transaction so it will basically uh
not revert back to its previous state
so once the comment statement has
executed the modification made by the
transaction it cannot be rolled back
again however once the rollback
statement is executed the database
reaches its previous state
so that brings us to the end of today's
session guys now that was all about the
commit and rollback uh commands in SQL
so basically to ensure that the changes
made by the transactions are permanently
saved in the database we use the commit
after the transaction successful
completion in case the transaction faces
any error while execution then to undo
or revert the changes done by the
transaction a rollback command is used
now you might uh get a doubt that where
we have to use this and where this is
applicable now if you are an SQL
Developer or even a beginner who is
working on a database let's say you're
working on a database which has
thousands of records and you're
modifying let's say a 100 records in
that now due to some errors you want to
revert back all the changes that you
have made right so for that you will
basically use the rollback function for
that so in this way it will be helpful
uh for getting the records again back to
its original state choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1 000
Plus hours of video content for free
visit skillup by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
skill developers who frequently work
with large data sets and analyze
enormous amounts of data find that they
also need to query specific types now
SQL provides us with many such tools to
accomplish this and one such operator is
SQL like which helps us to look at
specific data types instead of the
entire database this reduces the time
and efforts spent on any given task and
gives people the opportunity to work
more efficiently so in this tutorial on
SQL like operator we'll be learning how
to query data to find specific patterns
using the like operator in SQL firstly
let us understand what is SQL like loss
the like operator is used to find
specific characters in a tables column
it is also used to compare columns with
the specified values together with the
where Clause it determines if a pattern
matches specific values in a table it
uses Wild Card characters which are
characters used to replace one or more
characters in a string to fulfill this
purpose you can also use like when only
up portion of the value in that table is
known let us now understand the syntax
the syntax is simple it is usually used
with the select command and the syntax
of this is followed as select column 1
column two so on up to column n from
table name where column name like and
pattern now basically the columns to be
shown in the result table are specified
after the select statement the column
that is designed for pattern matching is
specified in the where clause and the
pattern forms from the specific row
selection which is defined in the
pattern parameter of the like operator
now the like operator is case
insensitive that means you can either
give capital or small letters as well
now multiple patterns can be specified
with this operator using the and or or
keywords as well and while car
characters are the most vital tools of
this operator so let's go over what
these are and how they are used within
like operator
so what is wild car character now
wildcard characters are special symbols
and characters used to represent one or
more than one character in a string
these are imperative to the like
operator as this enable Titans to be
specified that is it filters the data
using certain patterns to identify a
value of a string in the database now
the two wild cards used with the like
operator are generally percent and the
underscore now the percent sign is used
to represent zero or one or more
characters whereas the underscore is
used to represent exactly one character
now to get a clear picture of both these
characters let us look at an example uh
in a SQL statement and see how they are
used now consider this following example
which is Select employee ID employee
name from employees where name like a
percent
now from the stable employee if you want
to know the employee ID of all the
employees whose name start with a letter
or character a you should use this
following query which is the uh
character or the pattern we are using
here is a percentage
now as we discussed earlier you can also
use a small letter instead of capital
letter A because the like operator is
not K sensitive
now there are many operations that can
you that you can perform using by
specifying different patterns using the
like operators now for example if you
have to find a value that starts with a
then the following query would be where
column name like a pattern so basically
we are mentioning the pattern here as a
percentage which will retrieve all those
uh string values which starts with the
character a now similarly if you want to
find values that end with let's say s h
then you have to use percentage SH now
similarly if you want to find values
that can have a character a in any
position then you have to mention the
pattern as where column name like
percentage a percentage which basically
returns any values that contain the
letter a in any position and similarly
you can use the underscore operator as
well let's say if you want to return
only exact return exactly one character
then you have to mention a single
underscore sign now let's say if you
want to find values that have a
character a in third position then the
following query would be where column
name like and within the single quotes
you have to mention three underscores
that is uh three times you have to
specify the underscore that would be
present before the character a and then
you have to mention the percentage
and similarly you have these different
types of operations which you can take a
screenshot of this by pausing this video
now
so now that you have understood how
exactly SQL like works let us jump into
MySQL workbench to understand in depth
on how these exactly work by using the
different examples
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
I just started and in order to execute
the SQL like Operator Let Us consider a
following table in our database let's
say new employees on which will apply
various operations using the like
operator so let me first display the
records that are present in the new
employees table and for that I'm using
the select operator and the query select
star from new employees
so let me just execute this and a new
employees table has various columns such
as employee ID first name last name
email phone number hiring date job ID
salary manager ID and Department
so firstly let us discuss some examples
using the percent wildcard which
basically uses the percentage sign right
so let's say if I want to fix the
details of all those employees whose
first name starts with a or let's say s
then the following query would be select
star
from the table name that is new
employees
where is the conditional clause
first name
like is the keyword
and within the single quotes mention s
percentage
now it is important to enclose all the
patterns that you have specified in a
single inverted comma otherwise that
query will return a syntax error so let
me just display this and execute this
so when you execute this query it has
returned me seven rows as you can see in
the output which basically returns all
those employees name whose uh first name
starts with the character that is s so
we have like different employees like
Susan Mavericks Shelley Higgins Shelley
baida sigaltobias and Etc
now similarly let's say if you want to
fetch the details of all those employees
whose uh last name or like first name
ends with uh let us take a character
let's say uh n so let me just display
and execute the query
so when you execute this query it
basically returns all those employees uh
details whose first name ends with n
like for example if you consider here
Susan maveris whose first name has uh n
in the last position and similarly we
have Herman Bayer John Chen den rafley
and Etc
next let us take another example let's
say if I want to select all the
employees whose first name starts with
let's say S and ends with
let's say n
so then the following query would be
select
star from new employee
where
first name
like
now the first character would be S and
you have to mention it percentage symbol
and the next last character would be n
so let me just display execute this
statement so as you can see we have a
records of three employees whose first
name have the letter or the character s
in the first place and the character and
in the last phase for example Susan
maveris in the first name we have S in
the first place and then in the last
place similarly we have Steven Markle
and Stephen styles
now let us take another example let's
say uh I want to find the details of the
particular employee now the thing is I
don't know the exact name of that
employee but I know that uh his salary
is somewhere between thirty thousand and
fifty thousand so for that I can use the
and or operator here so the following
query would be select
star
from new employee
where
first name
like
let's say if I know the employee name
starts with uh K okay then well mention
a percentage symbol
and we'll mention uh the and operator
here and salary between thirty thousand
so let us execute this statement and
we'll see the output
so when you execute this we can see that
there are no records in the table that
means there is no employee whose name
starts with k and is salary is between
30 000 and fifty thousand so let us take
another example let's say the employees
name starts with j
so on a salary somewhere between thirty
thousand and fifteen thousand so let me
just execute the statement now as you
can see in a result set we have three
different employees uh Jennifer Valen
Julia Nair and Jason Malin whose salary
is between 30 000 and 50 000
respectively like we have forty four
thousand thirty two thousand and thirty
three thousand so in this way you can
find the details of employee even if you
do not know the complete details but
just by specifying the pattern uh of
their name or the character that we have
in their name you can fetch their
details now if you want to if you
further know that department ID let's
say uh Jennifer Valen Department ID is
10 and she belongs to that department
and I want to get the details of that
employee only then I can retrieve their
details in this way so I hope you've
understood how to use the percentage
sign to find the different patterns uh
in order to find the complete uh string
value from the table let us now discuss
uh some examples using the underscore
while character using the under under
score symbol
so let me take an example here let's say
if you want to fetch the details of all
those employees who have exactly three
characters in their first name so in
that case the following query would be
select star from new employees
where first name
like and within the codes now we we've
discussed there should be only three
exactly three characters in their name
right so we'll mention the underscore
three times one two three
close the single brackets and let us
execute this statement
so as you can see it has fetched a total
of four records uh for example pathway
uh we have only three characters that is
p80 in his first name and similarly we
have Lex Dahan then rapidly guy himro
all these employees have only exactly
three characters in their first name
let us now take another example let's
say if you want to select all the
employees with the first name that
starts with s and are at least five
characters in length then in that case
the following query would be select star
from new employees
where
first name
like
single quotes now the first character
would be S so I'm mentioning s and after
s we have to mention the underscore four
times
that basically means it will return an
exactly of at least five characters in
our uh employees table who's having the
first name uh having five characters
so let me just execute this statement
and we'll see the output
so as you can see we have two uh records
of employees Susan Mavericks and Seagal
Tobias now if you look uh carefully
Susan whose first name has a total of
five characters that is Susa and that is
five and similarly we have Siegal now if
you want at least uh let's say five
characters in length then you have to
mention the percentage sign
so it basically means uh the employees
name will start with s and it will have
at least five characters in length so
let me just execute this statement
so it will display all those records uh
whose first name is starts with the
character s and have at least five
characters in their first name
so we have Susan Mavericks like we have
also Shelley who's uh
who's having let's say one two three
four five six seven characters in total
in the in her first name
so in this way retrieve all those values
whose first name starts with s and
basically have at least five characters
in location we are going to discuss one
of the most commonly asked SQL query
during job interviews as well as campus
placements that is how to find the end
highest salary in SQL now there are many
ways to find the answer to this query
but in today's session we are going to
discuss the easiest and the most
simplest way to find the nth highest
salary in SQL let us jump into MySQL
workbench for execution and understand
how to finally end highest salary in SQL
as you can see MySQL workbencher started
now in order to find the nth highest
salary we need an employee table and for
that I'm going to consider the new
employees table here so let me just
display the records that are present in
the table
and for that I'll use the select
statement and the queries followed as
select star from new employees
so let me just display the results so as
you can see the new employees table has
various columns such as employee ID
first name last name email phone number
hiring date salary manager ID and
Department
so firstly before discussing how to find
the highest salary let us see how to
find the maximum salary now to find the
maximum salary in SQL you can simply use
the uh aggregate function Max to find
the highest salary in SQL so the
following query would be select Max
salary
from the table that is new employees
so let me just display the results so as
you can see it is showing as 93 000
which is the highest salary in our table
now next to find the second highest
salary in the above table we'll use the
concept of sub query which means that
firstly we'll find the highest salary in
the table and then we'll Nest that query
to a sub query to find the second
highest salary in SQL so the query would
basically be us now I'll put this as a
sub query here
and I'll write the outermost query now
that is
select
salary
from the table that is new employees
where salary is less than this inner
query or the sub query
so let us just execute this query and
see the output now it will display all
the salaries that are great that is less
than the uh sub query that we have
written here that is the maximum salary
which is 93 000. now that is not the
answer that we want or the results that
we want now we want the maximum salary
Which is less than the 93 000 so I'm
going to take the max function again
here
so basically how this query works is the
firstly the inner query gets executed
which is the maximum salary that is 93
000 next the outer query executes that
is it will select the maximum salary
from the new employee table which is
less than the 93 000. so let me just
display the results
so as you can see it is showing as 90
000 and as the second highest salary so
let us just verify whether it is correct
or not I'll use the select statement
again select star from new employees
we'll use the order by order by function
order by salary and I'll display the
values in descending order that means
from highest to lowest
so in this way we can find the higher
salary
and the corresponding service that are
less than the highest salary so as you
can clearly see that we have 93 000 as
our highest salary and the next salary
as 90 000 as our next second highest
salary
now till now it is fine now let's say we
are asked to find the fifth highest
salary or let's say 20th highest salary
or basically in highest salary from this
table now you can't keep on adding sub
queries to this already uh return query
right it will become time consuming and
it becomes complex as well
now in general there are two ways to
find the nth highest salary the first
one is using the limit clause and the
second one is using uh the dense rank
function which is an inbuilt function
provided by SQL which we are going to
discuss about in a while so firstly let
us discuss about the uh limit clause and
how we'll use the limit plus to find the
nth highest salary here
so firstly let us understand the syntax
here now the syntax is followed as
select column list
from table name order by expression
limit n minus 1 comma 1 so let me just
explain the syntax here now after the
select statement you will have to
mention all the columns that you want to
fetch in your resultant table from the
table name order by expression which is
this basically the column name you have
to specify here and you are using the
limit keyword and after that we have two
parameters here that is n minus 1 comma
1. Now in the syntax the limit n minus 1
comma 1 Clause returns one row that
starts after the row end now in other
words if I have to Define this the first
parameter that is n minus 1 defines
after how many rows it will start
fetching the records in a resultant set
and the second parameter will uh
basically return the number of rows in
that table
so let me just explain this with an
example so select now I'll use the
distinct keyword here which will
basically remove all the uh
anomalies or the repeated values in our
table so distinct salary from table name
that is new employees
order by salary
limit now let's say if I want to find
the 10th highest salary in our table so
now our n becomes 10 so the value here
it will be n minus 1 so 10 minus 1 is
basically 9 comma 1.
now what this query basically does is it
will return one record after the first
nine rows that is basically the tenth
row which is the query that we want that
is to find the 10th highest salary so
let me just execute this statement
so yes uh the query is returning me as
24 000 which is the 10th highest salary
here now similarly if you want to find
the let's say uh 24th highest salary
I'll just change the value into 24
so oh sorry also basically if you wanted
to find the 24th highest salary you will
have to mention 23 here that is n minus
1 right so let us find the output so the
next highest salary is 48 000.
oh so I forgot to mention the descending
keyword here that is why it is showing
me the uh highest value so if I run this
query again
so the 24th highest salary here is 29
900. so in this way you can basically
use the limit loss to find the nth
highest salary
now let's say if I want to fetch the
complete details of that employee who is
having the 24th highest salary I'll
simply use a sub query here so I'll put
this query as a sub query and I'll write
another outer query using the select
statement
select star
from new employees
where
salary
is equals to the inner query so let me
just execute this query and we'll see
the output so now it will display the
complete details of the employee their
employee ID first name last name email
phone number their salary manager ID
department and Etc so in this way if you
want to fetch the complete details as
well you can use this sub query here
now let's say if you are asked to find
the first five highest salaries in the
table then the parameter here will be
changed now here our n value becomes 1
so the N minus 1 becomes 0. now and we
want to fetch the first five records
from the table so we'll mention five as
our second parameter which will
basically display the first five records
so let me just display and execute this
statement so as you can see it will
display the first five highest salary
starting from ninety three thousand
ninety thousand next eighty eight
thousand eighty three thousand and next
eighty two thousand now if you have to
observe this query carefully it is
somewhat similar to that of the top
function we use now since top function
is not applicable in MySQL we are using
the limit Clause here now if you are
working on different other databases
like SQL server or mongodb or Oracle you
can use the top function now the format
uh will remain the same only the syntax
will change with the use of top keyword
so in this way you can use the limit for
Clause to find the nthis salary let us
not discuss the second way that is using
the dense rank function
now MySQL dense rank function is an
urban function which is used to return
sequential numbers starting from 1 based
on the ordering of rows imposed by the
order by Clause now when you have two
records with the same data set then it
will give the same rank to the both rows
so firstly let us understand the syntax
here the syntax is followed as select
column list these are basically all the
columns that you want to fetch in your
resultant table comma dense run is the
keyword we use here over and inside the
parenthesis we are writing the order by
uh clause and we'll mention the
expression as and will give a Alias name
to this
dense rank function from the table name
so now basically uh the function is
always used with Over clause here which
will always assign rank on basis of the
order by clause and the rank is also
assigned to the rows in a sequential
manner that is the rank the assignment
of rank to this rows will always starts
from 1 and the next value will be 1
greater than the previous ranker side so
let us understand this with an example
now let's say I'm
I'll use the select Clause here and I
want to display the employee ID
first name of the employee
last name
comma salary
next I'll mention the denser dense rank
keyword
over
and inside the brackets use the order by
clause and mention the uh expression now
we want to specify the condition here
which is basically on the salary right
we want to find the entire salary here
so we'll specify the salary here
as let's give an Aliyah's name let's say
a rank salary
from the table that is
new employee
so let us execute this statement and
we'll see the output
so as you can see it will display the
employee ID the first name last name
salary and the rank of the salary
now since we haven't given any uh
a keyword here for descending and
ascending it is showing in the ascending
order by default so let me just write
the descending keyword by using the tesc
so let us now display this
as you can clearly see it will display
the records from highest to the lowest
value and the rank is aside accordingly
now for the salary 93 000 it is giving
rank as one and for ninety thousand two
for eight eight thousand three and so on
now if you look here like the uh
employee Adams rib who's having 82 000
as salary and similarly John Chen who's
also having 82 000 salary and the rank
is assigned as 5 which is same now if
you carefully look here it will assign
rank based on the value and not on the
number so even if then uh values are
repeated it will assign the same rank to
that value
so I hope you understood how to use the
dense rank function here now let's say
to find the nth highest salary we'll
have to use a sub query here now
basically I'll keep this as a sub query
here and I'll use another select
statement
so basically I want to again display the
employee ID first name last name and
salary in a resultant table so I'll just
copy this
and keep it as an outer query
from
this uh table right so and I'll mention
a wear condition where rank salary
is equals to now you can mention the nth
highest salary now whatever you want to
display you can mention this here now
let's say if I want to find the uh 32nd
highest salary I'll just mention the
rank salary equals to 32 so let us now
execute this statement and we'll see the
output
now it will show me an error basically
here which says every derived table must
have its own Alias name so we have not
given uh any a specific Alias name to
our table here so let us just give a
layer's name let's say as e or you can
take EMP or anything as per your choice
right so let me just display this and
we'll see the output so as you can see
the 30 what is that 30 second highest
salary uh has been assigned to the
employee Hazel Phil tanker who sell this
22 000. so let's just check whether it
is correct or not I'll just copy this
dense rank select statement again
so let's just scroll down and as you can
see uh 32
which is the rank here has been assigned
to the employee Hazel field tanker whose
salary is 22 000 so which is correct and
your successfully executed query in this
case now similarly if you want to find
another uh
employee salary let's say if you want to
find 18 16 highest salary where I take
this
will execute the statement and it is
showing me as a 48 000 which is the 16th
highest salary and the employee ID is
105 the employee name is David Austin
and in today's session we are going to
learn about views in SQL SQL views are
very powerful in its usage when used
properly they allow the user to store
SQL queries into virtualized containers
or in other words virtual tables in our
database so in today's tutorial we are
going to learn how to create a view in
SQL and understand how exactly they work
what is vo and SQL a database view in
SQL is like having virtual tables
containing a single query and its result
the result is usually a virtual table
with rows and columns just like the
actual table in a database we can either
pass a query to store all the rows and
Columns of a table or only a part of it
now the most significant advantage of a
view in SQL is that it stores the query
and hence we don't have to write it
again and again from scratch scratch now
but then then a question arises why not
use the stored procedure instead even a
stored procedure can hold a query and
execute whenever called however the
advantage with view is that they are
easier and more straightforward compared
to procedures while procedures can have
multiple statements with them views can
have only one also viewers do not accept
any parameters as in case with the
stored procedure now SQL views can be
considered as one of the database
objects which is created over an SQL
query it simply represents the data
returned by an SQL query so a view does
not actually store the data in the
tables but every time we call a view in
the database it Returns the result set
of the query in which it is defined so
in a nutshell we can say that a view is
similar to that of a regulational
database table which can be treated as a
virtual table and it is just a mere
representative of an underlying SQL
query it always fetches the data from
base stable that are used to create The
View using the view creation query let
us now understand the syntax the views
in SQL are created with the create view
syntax and creating viewers in SQL is
very simple following is the basic
syntax to create a view in SQL and it is
followed as create view view name as
select column 1 column 2 up to so on
column n from table 1 table to table n
where condition now to see the data in
the view we can query The View using the
following select statement now create
view is used at the start of the code to
initiate the view and then select is
used to decide which columns to pick
from the tables now table one table up
to so on table n denotes the names of
the table however you can work on a
single table as well
now where is used to define the
condition which is used to select only a
particular number of rows
now another significant advantage of
views is that it allows certain
operations like insert update delete
just like uh you perform in a normal SQL
table
now other than this we have other
operations which can be performed using
the view now view is used to filter
records using where Clause now we know
that there is a lot of chunks of data in
our database and if we want only a part
of it we can filter the data using the
where plots similarly we can select
columns from a single table as per our
need and in the same way we can use the
group by Clause to select only a
particular or a summarized result of a
resultant set and finally we can also
select columns from multiple tables
using the join condition as well so now
that we've understood what exactly views
are let us jump into MySQL workbench for
execution part if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit skill up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
just started and before we proceed into
the execution part and see how to create
a view in SQL using various examples let
us first quickly understand why we use
in SQL so that will have a clear picture
before we get into the execution part
now there are various reasons for using
Vios and SQL the first one is majorly
because of security reasons
right now views provide security to the
data acting as a security mechanism and
Views can actually enhance security by
restricting data access to users for
instance we can limit a user from
accessing the actual table that contains
sensitive data but provide access to the
view that has only insensitive data
let's take an example to understand this
now in a company there is an employee HR
and a manager who might be working on a
same database table to fetch some
information now because they are from
different departments there must be some
data that might be relevant to HR but it
might be relevant to the manager and in
other case that data might be relevant
to manager but it might be irrelevant to
the employee so in that case there
should be a security mechanism that
would hide irrelevant information of the
table from certain Usage Now views
allows us to hide or show some date of
table depending on the requirement and
security with the help of condition we
can hide some data for a particular
person now the second reason is because
of
to reduce the complexity now views are
introduced or whatever actually
introduced to reduce the complexity of
the multiple tables and deliver data in
a simple manner we use hide the
complexity of the data and the database
as they join and simplify multiple
tables into a single virtual table which
is easier for a user to understand
and finally because of consistency
reasons
now views also maintain the data
Integrity as it represents a consistent
and accurate data from the database you
can easily make changes to the Views
according to the user requirement and
the effect of the same will be seen
quickly in a quick manner so now that
we've understood why we use views in SQL
let us just quickly uh go get into the
execution part now now we can easily
create a view in SQL from a single table
or even multiple tables using the create
view of statement now but before we
create a view we'll create a table named
customers that we will use throughout
this session now so let us just create a
table first which is a customer table
and the syntax is create table customer
and in the customer table I am going to
create various columns or Fields such as
customer ID customer name age address
and I'm giving customer ID as a primary
key because it uniquely identifies each
and every record in the table so let us
just execute this statement and we'll
see the output so our query has been
successfully executed so let me just use
the select statement to display the
result so let's start from
customer
right so our table has been created and
the fields our customer ID customer name
is and address are being displayed now
let us quickly insert uh some values
into the in this table now I'll use the
insert statement for that insert into
table name which is customer
values
and within the brackets now customer ID
let us take as 1.1
name let us take as k run
and age I'm taking as 25
and address I'm taking is Hyderabad
right so let us execute this statement
and we'll see the output
so our query has been successfully
executed and the uh information has been
inserted into our table
so as you can see the details of Kiran
has been successfully executed and
displayed in our table now similarly
I'll insert some more records into the
table so let me just copy this insert
statement
so let us change the values here one or
two one not three one not four and one
not five and name also let us change
I'm taking another customer name as
Priya
kushal
web half
and let's say guys
and let us change their age as well I'm
taking as 26
24 28
and 23.
now you can change their address as well
so I'm taking
the address of Priya as Bangalore for
kushal I'm taking as
Mumbai
let us just uh remain
Hyderabad for viber itself and let us
take as Chennai for Gayatri
so let us just execute the statement and
we'll see the output
so our query has been successfully
executed let me just display the values
huh
so as you can see a total of five
records have been inserted into our
table now we can proceed uh into
creating a view for our table customer
now to begin with I will create a simple
view from our customer table which is an
existing table which we've created just
now so the following syntax would be
create view which is the keyword we use
uh you can give any name to your view
let's say customer View
as
select the columns that you want to
display in your resultant view table
which is a virtual table right so I want
to display all the fields in my
resultant view table so I'll use the
select star operator select star from
customer
so let us execute this statement and
we'll see the output so our query has
been successfully executed and now when
you refresh the schema section you can
see in views you can find a new one
which is created as a customer view so
let me just display the results in the
view for that I'll use the select query
again select star
from
customer View
so as you can see the exact details of
the customers that we have already
inserted in our previous able customers
has been inserted in the customer view
as well
so that means in this way this view will
store all the columns that were in the
customer table and it will simply copy
paste all the records from customer
table into the customer view which you
have created now
now similarly you can also uh Create A
View From the existing table as well so
for that let us take an example let's
say if I want to create a view of
projects table here so let me just
display the records from the projects
table
put
so as you can see the project table has
various Fields such as project ID
employee ID project name project manager
now let's say I have I've had a new
requirement wherein there is a new
employee who is joining as a fresher
into the company and as a manager I want
to uh show the details of all the
project names uh that the compress
currently working on now I want to hide
the employee ID details because I don't
want the fresher to have exact idea on
which project the current employees are
working so for that I'll create a view a
simple view here which will basically
give all access to the fresher or the
the employee who have recently joined he
can only view the project name and
project manager's name that's it so let
me just create a view here create View
let us take the view name as project
view again
as
select the columns now I'll just select
the project ID
the project name
and the project manager's name here
click manages from the table let us
projects
so let us execute this statement and
we'll see the output
so our query has been successfully
executed now when you refresh this again
you can see another view is formed in
the views section which is the project
view so let me just display the records
that are present in this view I'll use
the select statement again select start
from
projects View
so as you can see now only the project
ID the project name and the name of the
project manager are being displayed
without displaying the employee IDs in
this view table so it will basically
encapsulate or hide The Unwanted details
for the new employee so that he can only
view the project name and the project
manager's name itself that's it right so
that brings us to the next segment
wherein we'll understand how to perform
various operations in a view and SQL
that is how to insert update and delete
records in a view
now just like actual tables we can
easily insert update and delete rows in
a view that is not allowed in store
procedures now firstly let us discuss
how to insert a row in a view for an
inserting a row in a view we'll use the
project view as an example that we have
created earlier now the view already had
let's say I think a 10 rows and we will
insert another row using the insert into
command so the following syntax is
insert
into
name of the view that is Project views
project View
values
and inside that let's say I'm taking a
project ID as one one two zero comma
project name let us say artificial
neural network
comma and let us say the project manager
name is Akash
so let us execute this statement and
we'll see the output
so our query has been successfully
executed so let me just use the select
statement again to display the records
so as you can see there's a new record
with the project id1120 and the project
name is artificial neural networks and
the project manager name is Akash so as
you can see in the output in this way we
can create another row by inserting in
the view which confirms that the insert
statement has been successfully executed
right so next let us discuss how to
update
a record in a view
now like just like insertime we can also
update a row in a view if you notice the
previous example we have inserted a new
row that is with the project ID as 1120
let us update uh one of the record in
this
let's say if I want to update the
project details of blockchain Technology
as something else I'll use the update
statement here
so the Syntax for the update would be
update
mention the view name that is Project
View
set
now since you are changing the project
name and mention the field project name
set project name equals to now let's say
if I want to change the project ID
110 as let's say SEO optimization
or let's say SEO Analytics
where
project ID
equals to 1110
right so let us execute this statement
and we'll see the output
so our query has been successfully
executed so let me run the select
statement again to display the records
so as you can clearly see that the
project ID which was 1110 which was
earlier blockchain technology has been
changed into SEO Analytics
so the updated uh the version of the
column name which was blockchain
technology uh has been changed into SEO
analytics successfully thus it is
confirmed that the update statement has
been executed successfully as well now
finally let us see how to delete a
record in a view now just like how we
inserted an updated a row we can also
delete a row using the delete statement
for example we will delete the row which
is having project ID let's say 810 which
is Project name as diabetic retinopathy
and the project manager name is Harsh so
let me uh just delete this record so
I'll use the delete statement here
they let from Project View
where is the condition we use here
where project ID
equals to 810
right so let me just execute this again
so our query has been executed
successfully let me just display the
records so as you can see the record the
project ID which is having 810 which is
one of the record in this table has been
successfully uh deleted so in this way
you can perform various such operations
which we actually generally perform in
the normal SQL tables you can similarly
perform them in SQL views as well now
for some reasons if you want to delete
the whole view that is the view that we
have already created for some reasons if
you want to delete it you can simply use
the drop command here which will
completely delete the view that you have
created so the query would be drop
mention the view name which is Project
View
right so let us just execute this
so our query has been successfully
executed so let me just uh use the
select statement to display the records
select star from
which is Project View
right so let us execute this now when I
execute this it will simply say that uh
project view does not exist which means
that our view which you have created has
been successfully deleted from the
database and the schema as well and that
brings us to the end of today's session
guys I hope you understood how to create
a view in SQL now you might have a doubt
that when to use uh views in SQL now
since views have both advantages and
disadvantages the question arises when
to use them right now for instance if
you remove an attribute or if you
actually delete a table it can impact
the functionality of a view as well just
like in a related table for instance if
a view is using the email column of a
table and you drop that column or even a
single data of it that is in use by the
view the output of the view will be
impacted now the short answer to when to
use uh views in SQL is when you want to
write complex select queries that
require Gathering data from multiple
tables in that case you can use SQL
views number to understand how to delete
this duplicate records in SQL let us
jump straight into MySQL workbench for
execution part
so I hope you are able to see the MySQL
workbench window and as you can see the
MySQL workbencher started and on the
left side you can see the simply code
database where we have different tables
such as crypto 2022 customer Department
employee 4 employee 3 and so on
right now before we get into the
execution part wherein I will discuss
how to delete the duplicates in SQL let
us understand uh why there are actually
duplicate records in SQL now as you know
uh sometimes you might see more than one
copy of the same record appearing in
your mySQL database table now this
usually happens after importing data
from external sources such as
spreadsheet applications like Excel or
from external websites like kaggle and
Etc which do not have the features of
relational databases right so having
this identical copies of the same
required May negatively affect your
application and your business logic so
to overcome these challenges you must
need to delete the duplicate records
from your table
now only rarely you will find uh to
remove duplicate entries from a table
because the tables in this databases
generally have this constraints such as
primary key or unique constraints to
prevent these duplicate entries
occurring in the first place
but due to some mistakes or the
duplicates can get you to properly
design table wherein this is due to
changes in the business side where after
merging of two or more different systems
or data from two or more different
tables will have this duplicate data in
our tables so in this session uh we'll
look at some of the ways to remove
duplicate records from the table in SQL
right so I've already created uh tables
and inserted some values in it as well
as some duplicate values also so let us
consider uh firstly the employee 4 table
here let me just display the apricots so
use the select statement which is Select
star from employee 4.
so let us execute this statement and
we'll see the output
right now employee for table has various
columns such as employee ID first name
last name email phone number hiring date
job ID salary manager ID
and finally Department ID
now there are different ways to delete
the duplicate records so we'll discuss
uh one by one each so firstly we can
delete the duplicate records using the
group by and having function so let us
understand the syntax first now before
we get into the execution part you'll
have to understand how to fetch the
duplicate records from the database
table right so for that we'll use the
following query as select
first name
comma last name
which are basically the columns and I'll
use the count function which will
basically count all the duplicate values
that are present in our employee 4 table
mention the table name
and we'll use the group by function
Group by mention the column names you
want to group which is basically the
first name and the last name right
having
count
mention the star operator greater than
one right let us now execute the
statement and we'll see the output
so as you can clearly see in our
resultant set we have a total of five
records such as donor local and Jennifer
Valen Michael Hasting Herman bear and
finally Alexander hunnold where their
records in the employee table have been
repeated for example do not denied o
Colin records have been repeated three
times here and similarly we have
Jennifer valence two Michael hattons two
times again Herman's bear was also two
times and finally Alexander hoodner is
also four four times right now now that
we've understood uh how to find the
duplicate uh Records that are present in
our table let us now understand how to
delete now the query for that would be
tell it
from mention the table name which is
employee 4
where
employee ID
not in
so let us first understand the syntax
then I'll clearly explain how it how it
actually works so select
which is a sub query now
use the max function
the employee ID column name
close the parenthesis from employee 4
and you can use this group by function
as well so we'll Group by your
the first name and the last name here
and close the brackets right there so
let us now execute this statement and
we'll see the output
uh there is an error in the code which
says you can't specify the target table
employee 4 for updating from clause
well guys I think there is an issue in
the back end or maybe there's a
error in the code but I think the logic
is correct here so what this uh query
actually does is it basically executes
the inner query first which is it
selects maximum employee ID from the
employee table right and it will display
all those records now it will delete all
the records in the employee at four
table whose employed is not in the
maximum value such as if I have let's
say 1.4 is the maximum value and if I
have one not one one or two or one or
three which are basically the duplicate
records so it will basically delete all
those records right so this is how it
will delete the duplicate records in the
SQL I don't know why it is showing here
but we'll get back to you again with the
right code so this is one of the way to
actually delete the duplicate rows from
SQL using the group by and having
function so let us now understand a
different scenario where you use another
method here we can also deliver the
duplicate records using the delete join
statement
okay so for that uh the query would be
delete
now I'll first let me write the query
and then we'll understand how the syntax
works so delete I'm taking an alias name
for a table employee
so I'm taking as E1
from
employee 4 which is the table right as
E1
and I'm joining the table
employee 4
as E2
where
even Dot
employee ID
is less than E2 dot employee ID
and even DOT first name
is equals to E2 DOT first name
right so this is our query now
so let us understand how this actually
works here right so
now basically we are this query is
referencing this to uh employee for
table twice and therefore we are using
we'll use the stable Lis as E1 and E2
and after this executing the statement
we'll get the following output as
so let us see the output and we'll
understand
it's showing an error which is okay
employee underscore ID this
so as you can see in our output our
total eight rows have been affected now
let us understand how this query is
working right now I have taken uh two
similar tables here that is basically
the one table I am referencing it twice
here so basically it will delete all the
rows which are less than the values that
are present in the employee two table
here
so let me just display the values again
so that will have a clear idea
select star from employee 42.
so as you can see now previously we had
the repetition of certain records for
example Dom Plus Grand we had and
similarly we had Alexander who knowled
and for similarly Herman Banos after
Execute this statement we have only a
single record where all the existing
duplicate records have been successfully
deleted so in this way you can use the
delete join statement as well uh to
delete the duplicate records from your
table
now let's uh the next method to delete
this duplicate records is using the row
number function
now row number function is basically a
SQL ranking function guys that will
assign a sequential rank number to each
record in a partition now when this SQL
row number function detects any two
identical values or let's say duplicate
values in the same partition it it
assigns different or rank numbers to
both and this ranked number will be
determined by the sequence in which they
are being displayed I know this might
sound a bit confusing so let us
understand the query and see how it
exactly works
so the query is followed as select
employee ID
comma first name
so basically display all the columns
that you want in a resultant table
last name
mention the row number function
sorry guys row number function
over
partition is the keyword Partition by
as the keyword
and we are partitioning using the first
name here right so mention the column
name as first name and similarly we'll
also mention the order by clause
mention the first name again as now let
us give an alias name for this let's say
I will take it as row underscore num
mention the table name that is employee
employees so let us consider another
table here which is employees 3.
right so this is our query so let us
understand what exactly uh the syntax is
all about now we are using the over
keyword here which basically is a clause
which specifies the windows or set of
rows that the window function operates
and the Partition by an order by other
two possible classes of the Over clause
and next we have the Partition by
keyword which is an optional clause in
the row number function it is basically
a clause that divides the result set
into partitions now the row number
method is then applied to each partition
which assigns a separate rank number to
each partition and if the Partition by
Clause is not specified the row number
function will treat the entire result as
a single partition and drag it from top
to bottom
and finally we also have uh order by
Clause we are using here which is the
Clause it allows the allows the user to
order the rows in the resultant set
so I hope you have understood this law
let us now execute this statement and
we'll see the output
right now as you can see in our
resultant set we have uh details of an
employee Alexander who know who's
employed is 103 here which has been
repeated for four times here right so in
this way the row number function will
assign values in a sequential manner
starting from 1 that is one two three
four that is basically four different
values now again we do not have a
repetition of this value so again it is
mentioning or it is assigning one as
value for the next record now similarly
we have Bruce Ernest as only one record
so we have row number as one now next we
have Donald O'Connell whose records are
again repeated Thrice here right you can
see here so the row number function
assigns the values as one two three so
similarly for all the rest of the uh
Records that are present in the table it
assigns the value in a sequential order
on the number of times it has been
repeated
so now that we've uh added the
partitions and the row numbers to the
our resultant set let us now understand
how to delete these duplicate records
now the Syntax for that would be delete
from
from sorry uh Delete
from employee 3
which is the table name
employee three
where
employee ID
in
now within the uh
parenthesis we'll write a sub query here
which is basically select all the
employee IDs
from
mention another sub query here which is
basically the uh previous query that we
have written here so we'll just write it
again
select
employee ID
comma first name
comma last name
and mention the row number function
over
Partition by is the keyword
first name
again we'll use the order by clause for
the first name again
and we'll give an alias name for this uh
sub table which is ronum
from employee 3 table
and for this uh outer part of the query
we'll give another temporary name let's
say temp table
where
row number
is basically greater than 1.
so what this uh
query does is basically it will check
all the values
and it will see that for all the values
which is having row number greater than
one for example we have for Alexander
honol we have uh row numbers has one two
three four right so it will remain this
uh the first record as it is and it will
delete the remaining records for example
the records having Alexander as row
number function two three four will be
deleted and similarly for donor docanel
2 3 0 numbers will be deleted
so let us now execute the statement and
we'll see the output
it is showing an error again so let me
just make some changes
well the queries actually correct guys I
don't know why it is showing the error
here
okay I forgot to uh close the
parenthesis here right so that was my
mistake sorry uh so let's now execute
the statement and we'll see the output
or E3
three
three things implant table name has been
returned wrong right
so let us execute this statement and
we'll see the output
foreign
guys and we can see that 13 rows have
been have been affected so let us now
use the select statement again and we'll
see the records where
whether they are not whether the
duplicate records have been deleted or
not so select star from
employee three table
right so clearly uh you can see that in
a resultant set we have all the
duplicate values that have been
successfully deleted permanently so in
this way you can use the row number
function as well to delete the duplicate
records in your SQL table so that brings
us to the end of today's session guys
that was all about how to delete the
duplicate records are rows from the SQL
tables I hope you understood how to
implement this discussing uh what is
pattern matching in SQL and we'll see
how to find certain values in the table
using so using some patterns with the
help of some special characters so
without any further delay let's get
started now in order to for the
execution part let us jump into MySQL
workbench
so as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and on the left side you can see
the simply code database which has
various tables like crypto 2022 customer
Department new employees Olympics and
Etc
so before getting into the execution
part guys let us understand how exactly
the pattern matching works
now remember when you uh start typing
something into Google search bar and it
auto completes feature already completes
your sentence right so what exactly is
happening there so Google is basically
trying to accomplish is what is pattern
matching pattern matching is basically
checking whether a specific sequence of
characters or token or a data or the
other information that you are looking
is existing in the database or not so
for that we use pattern matching in SQL
now SQL pattern matching allows you to
search for patterns in data if you don't
know how the exact word or phrase
your finding is there or not
so this kind of SQL query uses wildcard
characters to match a pattern now the
like operator is basically used to find
the specific uh pattern in the tables
column it is also used to compare
columns within the specified values now
together with the where Clause it
determines if a pattern matches specific
values in a table it also uses some
special wildcard characters such as the
like percentage as well as the like
underscore operator to find the specific
pattern so basically the uh like
percentage sign is used to represent
zero or more characters and the
underscore sign is used to represent
exactly one character right to get a
clear picture of both these uh operators
using the special wide card symbols let
us look at some examples and see how
they are executed and how it will return
the values so for that let me just
switch to another Tab and let us
consider the Olympics table to perform
operations
using the patterns matching in SQL so
let me just display the results uh from
the Olympics table so I'm using the
select star from Olympic Steven
right so the Olympics table has various
columns or Fields such as ID name sex
age height weight country NOC games er
season City Sport and event
and also the medal that they have won
so firstly let us discuss some examples
using the like percentage operator guys
so as we discussed earlier like
percentage operator basically returns
one or more characters having certain
patterns that we've mentioned in the
condition in our query so let me just
take a first example here and we'll see
how it gets executed now let's say if I
want to fetch details of all the
athletes who have participated in
Olympic Games whose name starts with s
so in that case the following query
would be
select
star from Olympics
where
name like
and within the single quotes you have to
mention the character that you are
searching for which is s and mentioned
the percentage symbol
so let's just go this statement and
we'll see the output so it will
basically display the results of all
those uh athletes who have participated
in the Olympics whose name starts with s
so if you want to further uh write a
queries in order to display in ascending
order you can use the order by function
as well so I'll use the order by name
so this will basically uh represent all
the names starting from s and also the
second character which will maintain in
the ascending order like if you see
Sally mapenos and next we have silvano
Abba and so on
till
Stephen Anthony Bass
right so in this way if you want to
display only
uh the results using the first character
you can use this next let us disc uh
discuss another example now you can use
multiple characters also to find the
patterns uh in order to fetch the data
let's say if you want to retrieve the
details of all the events uh in the
Olympic Games whose name starts with
let's say s a
so in that case we'll be using the query
as select star
from Olympics
where
event like
s a person
so let us execute this and we'll see the
output
so we were talking about events right so
we have events here like various events
so let me just uh use the distance so
that we'll have only the events name
select distinct event
and we'll see the output
so as you can see we have a total of
five records that starts with the
characters essay like sailings women's
Windsurfer selling makes three person
keyboard and so on so in this way if you
know the first two characters of the
value that you want to search then you
can use the percentage operator with by
mentioning the first two characters here
that is we have taken sa here
right so let us move to the next query
uh let's say if you want to display
the names of all those employees sorry
all those are athletes in the Olympics
table whose name ends with letter or the
character in so in that case you use the
query as select star
from Olympics
where
name like
now in order to get the details of all
those athletes whose name ends with them
you have to first mention the percentage
and then mention the character that you
are searching for which is basically in
right so we'll execute this query and
we'll see the output so in our resultant
set you can see list of all those
athletes whose name ends with a like if
you consider Arrow awesome
and similarly we have geometry tapio
altonin and if you scroll down a bit
you'll find all those names of the
athletes whose name ends with n
so you can use this percentage operator
to find the names of all those uh
athletes in the Olympics table that ends
with n as well Right Moving ahead uh
similarly you can also find the names of
the name of the athletes in the Olympics
table that ends with multiple characters
so no other than names let us take
another example let's say if I want to
display distinct uh records of the
sports whose Sports name ends with ing
so in that case I'll use select star
or sorry select distinct
sport from Olympics
where
sport like percentage
ing
so let's execute this statement and
we'll see the output
so it will basically display the records
of all those ports played in the Olympic
Games which ends with the characters ing
so no matter what it has in the starting
places it should end basically with the
ing characters so we have various ports
like speed kit skating cross country
skiing swimming sailing Alpine skiing
weight lifting and finally wrestling oh
sorry we have more than uh that so
basically it displays all those uh
Sports which have ing in the last place
so I hope you understood this uh so let
us now understand another scenario where
we'll use this percentage now if you
want to uh display the records of all
those
uh athletes whose who have i or k let's
say ik in any particular order in their
names so in that case You'll Use the
following query as select star
from Olympics
a stable name where
name like
so the name can start with any character
so I'm using the percentage now it
should have only ik in between their
name so at any positions and finally
I'll enclose in with the percentage so
it can be in a second third or you can
say fifth sixth but basically it should
have ik characters in the name so let us
just
for what to mention a single code so let
us execute this statement and then we'll
see the output
right so as you can see we have uh the
resultant set which has for example if
you consider Agnes Erica Anderson uh she
uh she has ik in between her name and
similarly Jan Eric uh similarly he has
ik characters in middle of his name and
similarly we have Mika Laurie arnica are
we Alec Monica Ava and so on
so even in this way you can use a
different scenario where you can
understand and use how the percentage
operator
well let us now consider another example
guys let's say if you want to display
all those countries where the Olympic uh
say sorry uh the countries of all the
athletes who have participated in the
Olympics whose country name starts with
c and ends with a so in that case the
following query would be select star
from Olympics
where
[Music]
country like
C
percentage a
so what this basically does is it will
retrieve all the records of the
countries which has the letter c as it's
either first position and a as in the
last position and it can have any number
of characters in between so for that we
are using percentage sign so let me just
execute this and we'll see the output
so if you can see in our output we have
uh different countries that start with c
and ends with a so let me just uh use
this thing so that we can have a clear
picture
so as you can see we have China and Cuba
which are only two countries uh which
have the letter c as it's in the first
position and a in the last position as
well
so this is another case where you can
use the percentage operator sign as well
so and finally let us look another
example of like uh before uh moving
ahead with the underscore operator now
let's say if you want to find the
details of all the athletes who have
participated in the games uh in the 20th
century that is from 1900 to 2000 so not
only the character values you can even
work on the numerical values as well
while you're performing like like
operations so let me just write a query
so select I'll use the distinct uh name
because we have repeated values of
athletes so and also mention the year
from
Olympics
where
game like
19 percentage so it will basically
display all the records uh whose uh the
games that were played in the year 19 9
or 20th century that is between 1900 and
2000. so let us just execute this and
we'll see the output
oh sorry I think it's games the column
name is games
so as you can see it will display the
records of all the athletes who have
played uh various games in this years
starting from uh 1900s to 2000 so if if
you want a more uh
good looking query you can use the order
by so that it will sort the result in
ascending order
so let us just execute this so as you
can see uh in the resultant set it is
displaying the record starting from 1900
and so on up to 1998 so in this way you
can use the numerical values also to
find certain patterns as well and you
can also use uh the and or operator and
or operator as well so let us consider
an another example there now let's say
if you want to fetch the details of all
these athletes who have taken part in
various Olympic Games be It Summer
Olympic Games or Winter Olympic Games
and the sport that they have
participated is basically starts with
the letter b
so in that case what we'll do is we'll
add game section as well which is a
column mention the and operator and
Sport like
percentage B
so what it does is basically displays
all the records of the athletes who have
taken part in all the Olympic Games paid
summer or winter Olympic Games in the
19th 20th century that is from 1900 to
2000 and also it will filter the records
wherein it will only display the sport
which starts with the letter b
and similarly we'll do the order by year
so let us let's execute this statement
and we'll see the output
so as you can see it is displaying me
the record of all those athletes who
have taken part in various uh Games
Starting In the 19th from 1900s from we
have 1924 1952 and so on up to 1998
so in this way you can use also use the
and operator basically to fetch the
records using the percentage operator
so I hope you've understood till now how
we use the like percentage uh in order
to find certain pattern in our values
that are present in our tables to fetch
those records let us move ahead and
discuss some examples uh by using the
like underscore operator
right as we discussed like underscore
operator basically Returns on exactly
one character that we specified so let
us just understand with an example here
so that you'll have a clear idea so
let's say if I want to fetch the details
of all the names of athletes in the
Olympics table whose name starts with j
and have a total of let's say five
characters so in that case the following
query would be select stars from
Olympics is the table name
where name like
in Chinese single brackets and we know
that their name starts with j and they
have a total of six characters so we'll
write underscore 5 times 1 2 3 4 and 5.
so let us see the output
so as you can see in our resultant set
we have no records of the athletes whose
name starts with j and has a total of
six characters so let us take another
example let's say if you want to uh
find the details of the cities where the
Olympic Games have played which
basically starts with the letter b and
has a total of six characters right so
in that case what we'll do is Select
star from Olympics
where
City like
B and mention five underscores because
it has a total of six characters we also
we already mentioned the character B in
the first place so we'll have five uh
underscores
so let us just execute this and we'll
see the output
so in a resultant set we can see Berlin
is basically this city I think it is
only one and only the city that they
have played in which has the letter B in
the first position and it has a total of
six characters now since you don't know
uh the exact characters that are present
in what positions you're basically
you're using the underscore characters
to mention that
right I hope you understood this guys uh
let us take another scenario so that we
have a more clear picture of how the
underscore works now we'll use this
underscore in the last position wherein
will display the records of
all the countries of the athletes that
they have taken part in the Olympic
Games whose country name ends with n and
has a basically uh six characters in
total that is five characters we have to
mention as underscore and we will have
the n as the last letter so select star
from Olympics
where country like
so mention a total of six
and mention the last letter which ends
with a
so let us execute the statement and
we'll see the output
so these are basically the so let me
just use the distinct so that we can
Will have only the country names the
result table
so basically Cameroon and Pakistan are
basically the two countries uh that the
athletes belong to which have a total of
uh
seven characters and has in in the last
position so as you can see Cameron and
Pakistan are both those countries
right so let us discuss another example
a final example before we move on uh to
our next uh scenario so finally let's
say if you do not know uh the name of
the let's say the sport that you want to
retrieve but you know it has a total of
only six characters you don't know the
starting letter you don't know the
ending letter but you know that it has
at least or let's say a six characters
in total so in that case we'll use
select distinct
so we'll uh display this port so I'm
taking this port column from Olympic
Games
Olympics
where
Port like
so mention six underscore values one two
three four five six
so let us execute the statement and
we'll see the output
so basically we have five records of
these ports that are played in the
Olympic Games which have a total of six
characters which is hockey rowing Boeing
diving and Tennis so in this way you can
use the underscore operator without
mentioning any characters or values at
all to find the actual or the value that
you are searching for in your table
while so that is how you use the like
underscore operator guys now we have
another case wherein we'll use both the
like percent as well as the underscore
values all together in order to retrieve
the data from our table by specifying
certain patterns patterns so let us
understand this with an example so let's
say if your uh
trying to fetch the details of all the
countries of the athletes which uh whose
country name starts with s and has at
least three characters I am using the
word at least because uh it can have any
number of values after the first
character so let me just explain this
with a query here select star
from Olympics
where country like
now the country name should start with s
and it can have basically three
characters so I am using the percentage
sign as well now I'm not telling it
should have exactly three characters it
can have
uh at least three characters that is it
can have four five or even six so let us
just execute the statement and we'll see
the output
so where is this the country right so
you can see in a resultant set Spain is
a country which starts with s and have
more at least three uh characters in
total and similarly we have Soviet Union
as well
so in this way you can use both
underscore as well as the percentage
operator so let us just understand with
another example here guys uh let's say
if you're trying to fetch the details of
all the events from the Olympic games
that were played uh which basically has
uh
which basically has m in its third
position and can have any number of
characters so in that case the following
query would be select star from
Olympics
sorry we're just selecting the event
right so I'll mention the event select
event from
Olympics
where event like
now I said the uh character m is present
at the third position so first I'll
mention two underscores next I'll
mention the M character and then finally
I mention the percentage so that it can
have any number of values after the
character n
so let us just execute the statement and
we'll see the output so it will
basically retrieve all the events that
are played in Olympic Games which has m
in the third position so as you can see
gymnastics men's individual all-round
similarly gymnastics men's Team all
round floor exercises horse world and
all this have m in the third position
and basically it has any number of
characters that is a total number of
characters
I hope you're following with me and you
are understanding this so let us
consider another example uh so let's say
if you want to if you're trying to
retrieve the uh countries that the
athletes are belonging to uh where the
country name
has a in the second letter and ends with
n
so in that case what we will do is I'll
write another query which is Select star
from Olympics
where
country like
so I said we have a in the second
position so we do not know what is
present in the first place so I'm just
mentioning an underscore and then I'm
mentioning a and then I'm using
percentage because we have no
restriction here it can have any number
of values now the only criteria is that
it should end with n
right so we'll just execute this and
we'll see the output
okay it is displaying all the records
right so let's just use the adjusting
so as you can see we have a total of
four records which are basically typhoon
Cameroon Bahrain and Pakistan now if you
clearly look into this resultant set we
have a in the second position
uh you can see right so we have a in the
second position and it is having a
number of characters which is which is
of no limit and the only condition we
have specified is it should end with n
so in all these records uh the country
names are ending with n so in this way
you can use uh the percentage and Alias
sorry percentage and the underscore to
specify this kind of pattern as well
so I hope you've understood this guys uh
so finally let us look at another uh
example so that we can wrap this session
finally so let's say if you want to
display records of various ports that
are played which can have any number of
characters but the last but one
character should be in that is it should
contain letter N or basically the
penultimate character should end with
him so in that case the following query
would be select
distinct sport
from Olympics
where sports like
so I hope you understood the question
though the question is uh
it can have this port can have any
number of characters but the only
condition is the last but one character
should be in so I'll first mention the
percentage that is it can have any
number of characters before and after
the percentage I am mentioning n which
is basically the last but one character
and I'm mentioning an underscore that is
it can have any number of uh any value
in the last place that is any it can
fill any character in that place
so let's just execute this statement and
we'll see the output
okay sport sorry it is just support not
Sports
so in a resultant set you can see that
we have various ports which basically
has in in this second last position so
you can see in speed skating in cross
country skiing swimming sailing and so
on in all these are values we have n at
the last position so in this way you can
use the you can use both percentage as
well as underscore to find patterns in
your data table as well
so and similarly guys we have the not
like uh operator to find the pattern
matching as well so let me just uh
help you with this example so let's say
if you want to find the age of
all the athletes uh who's who are not in
the age of who are in the not in the age
group of 20 right so in that case what
I'll do is Select star from Olympics
where
age use the not like keyword and
mentioned to
percent so it will basically omit all
the values or the values of all the
athletes whose a whose arranging in the
age group of 20 to 30. so let us just
execute this statement and we'll see the
output uh we'll also uh use the order by
so that will have in the ascending order
order by h
right as you can see the resultant set
has all the areas of the athletes uh
starting from 16 17 18 and 19 and if you
clearly observe here after 19 we have 30
so basically it is omitting all the
values that has
star 2 or that is The Athlete's ages
lying in the range of between 20 and 30.
so in this way you can also use them not
like uh values not like operator to omit
the values that in the pattern matching
and we will be discussing about triggers
in SQL so in this tutorial we'll be
going through various concepts of
triggers understand its significance and
see how it exactly Works in SQL now have
you ever watched a line of dominoes fall
when you knock the first one down now in
that case you have just invoked a
trigger which has created an event there
your touch of first style trigger the
chain reaction that has knocked down the
rest of the dominoes as well now this is
the same principle applied to database
triggers as well now a trigger in
database terms is set of instructions
that is activated or we say it as fired
by some specific event normally a
command issued through a SQL code
firstly let us discuss the agenda for
today's session we'll start the tutorial
by understanding what are triggers in
SQL and then we'll go through
why we use triggers and after that we'll
see different types of triggers used in
SQL and after that we'll be discussing
various operations used with triggers
and then we'll get into the execution
part in MySQL workbench using various
examples and finally we'll wrap the
session by discussing some advantages
and disadvantages of triggers so without
any further Ado let us jump straight
into today's topic
so firstly what are triggers in SQL
now triggers
is a database object which fires when an
event occurs in a database or you can
say a trigger is a piece of code
executed automatically in response to a
specific event occurred on a table in a
database now triggers as the name
suggests are store procedures now what
are store procedures means procedures
are basically functions which contain
SQL statements which are stored in
database and can return some output
which are executed or fired when some
event occurs
now a trigger is always associated with
the particular table and if the table is
deleted all the associated triggers are
also deleted automatically now the
triggers are executed in response to
certain events like insert update or
delete in a particular table now a
trigger is invoked either before or
after the following events of from the
DML commands like through insert when a
neuro is inserted or through an update
command when an existing row is updated
or through a delete command when a row
is deleted so when you issue an insert
update or delete statement the
relational database management system
fires the corresponding trigger
and also these figures helps in
maintaining the Integrity of the data by
changing the date of the database
let us now understand the syntax of
triggers now we can create triggers for
various types of operations as discussed
above and we'll mostly focus on DML
triggers as these are the most commonly
and extensively used triggers and also
at the same time most important so a DML
trigger can be created using the
following syntax which is followed as
create trigger trigger name before after
instead of insert or update or delete on
table name for each row begin trigger
body and double slash so let's just
discuss the different parts of the
syntax clearly now we have the create or
replace trigger trigger name in the
first line where we give the name of the
trigger we are creating or updating here
trigger name is to be replaced by the
name you want to have for your trigger
in your database now it can be of any
name as per your choice next we have the
before after instead of keywords here we
Define when the trigger would run that
is before or after the DML operation for
example if you want a trigger to be
executed after insertion to a table we
will consider after insert here
next we have various DML commands like
insert or update or delete this is the
operation or event we have to Define
which will trigger a procedure to be
executed if you want a procedure to run
after it deletion happens on the table
then we'll consider writing delete there
next we have on table name here we have
to specify the name of the table on
which we are attaching the trigger and
next we have for each row keyword where
this line specifies that the procedure
will be executed for each one of the
rows present here we can set a condition
for which rows to be impacted this part
is optional though in case we don't use
this trigger shell convert to a
statement level trigger rather than
being a row level one so we'll discuss
about that later so next we have the
when condition where which mentions some
condition basis of which the trigger
will run in absence of when condition
which is again optional you can expect
it to run for all the eligible rows so
this is very important as this will
control which rows the trigger must run
and finally we have the trigger body
which is the main logic of what to
perform once the trigger is fired in the
previous statements always defined is
when this trigger will be fired but here
we have to Define what to do after the
trigger is fired so so this is the main
execution part of the SQL code and we
end the syntax with N double slash
that moving ahead why we use SQL
triggers now since a trigger resides in
the database and anyone who has the
required privilege can use it or trigger
lets you to write a setup and scale
statements that multiple applications
can use so it allows the user to avoid
redundant code when multiple programs
need to perform the same database
operations
SQL triggers also maintains complex
column constraints now what I mean from
that is it helps in maintaining the
Integrity constraints in the database
tables especially when the primary key
and foreign key constraints are not
defined and it also helps in maintaining
the track of all the changes like
updation deletion and insertion that
occur in the database table
triggers also increase the performance
of SQL queries because it does not it
does not need to compile each time the
query is executed
alright moving ahead let us now discuss
the types of triggers in SQL
now triggers are of two types in general
according to the SQL standard language
which is row level trigger and statement
level trigger now row level trigger
which is activated for each row by a
triggering statement such as insert
update or delete
now for example if a table has inserted
updated or deleted multiple rows the row
trigger is fired automatically for each
Road affected by this insert or updated
statement
and next we have the statement level
trigger which is fired once for each
event that occurs on a table regardless
of how many rows are inserted updated or
triggered now further we have uh six
types of triggers based on the uh events
of occurrence of the triggers uh through
the DML commands that are invoked and at
the time of when they are executed so we
can Define the maximum of six types of
actions or events in the form of
triggers which is before insert after
insert before update after update before
delete and after delete let us now
discuss about them in detail
now first we have uh the before and
after insert trigger the before insert
triggers are used to modify or check
record values before they are saved to
the database whereas the after insert
triggers are used to modify other
records and access field values set by
the system
and the Syntax for before and after
insert trigger is followed as delimiter
create trigger trigger name before or
after is the keyword we have to mention
prior to the insert uh name on table
name for each row begin mention the uh
body of the trigger and mention the N
keyword and end with a delimiter
next we have the before and after update
trigger in SQL now before update
triggers are removed automatically
before an update event occurs on the
table associated with the triggers while
after update trigger is invoked when the
operations on row is under execution
after an update operation on the
database now the syntax is also same
instead of the insert you have to just
replay replace it with the update
keyword uh with the before and after
keywords as well now firstly we will
specify the trigger name that we want to
create and it should be unique within
the schema next we'll specify the
Trigger action time which should be
before update or after update so this
figure will be invoked before each sort
of alterations occurs on the table if
you use before and similarly with the
after keyword as well
and third we'll specify the name of the
table to which the trigger is associated
so it must be written after the on
keyword and if you do not specify the
table name a trigger would not exist
finally we'll specify the trigger body
that contains a statement of execution
uh when the trigger is activated where
you can mention the different condition
using the when
keyword as well now we cannot update the
old values in a before update trigger
where and we can change the new values
as well which we'll discuss while we are
executing the code in MySQL workbench so
that you'll have a clear idea
and finally we have the before and after
delay trigger as well before delay
triggers are fired automatically before
a delete event occurs in a table and
after direct triggers are invoked when
the operations on the rows is under
execution after any delete operation on
the database as well now the syntax is
also similar to that of uh previously to
that of insert and update which is
create triggered trigger name before
after delete on table name for each row
and then mention the trigger body
so in this way you can apply various uh
Triggers on your database so to
understand this in a more better way let
us jump into MySQL workbench for further
execution part
so as you can see MySQL Workman just
started and first let us discuss how to
create a before insert trigger now now
as discussed earlier uh before insert
trigger in SQL is invoked automatically
whenever an insert operation is executed
so let us discuss how to create a before
insert trigger with its syntax and an
example now in order to create a trigger
you have to first create a new table and
then insert values into it to perform a
trigger operation but we already know
how to create a table and insert values
into it so let us just consider an
already existing table let's say new
employees so I'll just display the
values select star from
new employees
so the new employees table has various
attributes such as employee ID first
name last name email phone number hiring
date job ID salary manager ID and
Department ID
right so let us now run the before
insert uh syntax so first we have the
delimiter here
now when we are writing uh SQL
statements we generally use the
semicolon right to separate two
statements now since uh a trigger is a
stored procedure which consists of
multiple statements operated by a column
so if you are using MySQL to Define our
stored procedure like trigger that
contains semicolon characters it will
not trick the whole like the stored
procedure as a signal statement but many
statements therefore you have to define
the delimiter temporarily so that you
can pass the whole uh the body of the
trigger as a single statement
so typically we are just uh
separating these statements using the
double slash here
so delimiter now we have to write the
actual Syntax for the before insert
trigger which is create trigger
which is the keyword I'm using and let
us take the uh trigger name as let's say
before insert you can take it as per
your own choice
insert before insert is the keyword on
the table that is new employees
now I'm applying Trio for each row so
I'm specifying for each row
now here comes the main part where you
have to mention the condition now the
trigger that I'll be invoking is let's
say now we have Department IDs here
right which are
uh having values like 10 20 50 100 60s
and hundreds so if you notice here uh
we have the department IDs in the name
in the multiples of values of 10. so
I'll be creating a trigger whenever a
new user is trying to insert values into
that table
as Department ID Which is less than 10
so in that case I'll set the new
Department ID as 0. so the query would
be if new DOT
Department ID
is less than 10.
then
set mu dot Department ID
equals to zero
so mention the end if
and N double slash
now you might get a doubt here uh like
why I'm using new DOT Department ID now
triggers allows access to values from
the table for comparison purposes using
the new and old keyword and this
availability of keywords will also
depend on the trigger event uh which you
are performing now since you are
checking or modifying a value when
you're trying to insert data using the
new DOT column modifier which is
available whereas if you are trying to
insert old values that is using the Old
Dot column name value does not exist for
an insert statement because there is no
information exists in in its place
beforehand so that is the reason I'm
taking the new keyword here so we have
created our trigger so let's just uh
execute the statement and we'll see the
output
okay there is an error so let me just
so it says that trigger already exists
might be have taken it already so let me
just change it and keep it as Department
insert
so as you can see a trigger has been
successfully created now let us consider
the new employee table again and let us
insert some values to understand how
this works so I'll be inserting some
values into the table so I'm using
insert into
new employees
values
so mentioned the employee ID let's say
comma
mention the name of the employee first
name let's say
Carl
and the last name as Haden
next we have email so let's take C
addend
next we have phone number just type a
random number
next we have hiring dates so let us take
as 15th uh June 2009
next we have job ID let's take sh clock
as our job ID
next we have salary uh let's take 35
000.
next manager ID let's take 120
5 or 126 next we have the department ID
so we have I'm taking the department ID
here as 7.
right so let us just execute this
statement and we'll see the output
so our record has been inserted so let
me just uh retrieve the values again so
if you scroll down a bit we have our new
details of our employee having employed
as 288 whose name is Carl Hadden and if
you slide a bit and you can see that
since we have inserted the department ID
value as 7 and the trigger will
automatically uh be created here which
is uh Department ID is less than 10
right so automatically it has changed
the value into zero so in this way you
can use the before insert to create a
trigger in your table
right so I hope you have understood how
to create a before insert trigger let's
move ahead let us now discuss how to
create an after insert reader
now after insert trigger in SQL is
basically invoked automatically whenever
an insert has already occurred on the
table so let us just understand this
with an example so let us consider the
customer tables here so let us just
display the values in the customer table
so a customer table has uh four
attributes which is customer ID customer
name age address and we have a total of
five records so let us understand how
this after insert uh trigger works now
we have customer ID starting from one
not one and one not five now basically
I'm going to create a trigger like a
whenever a customer's details has been
inserted which is having customer ID
more than 200 so in that case I'll be
inserting this into another table
instead of this customer table
so for that let us just create another
table so you can create a table using
this icon here
so I'm creating a new table which is
customer new
and will create the columns as well so
the column names need not be identical
it should basically have the same data
type even if it's not having the same
column names so ID
and then we have name of the customer
and then we
and then we have the age
and finally we have the address
right so let us just apply and we'll
create a new table
all right so we have created a new table
which is customer new here so let us now
write the Syntax for after insert so I'm
again using the delimiter
and let us create a trigger now create
trigger so I'm taking the trigger name
as again after insert you can take it as
per your own choice
so since we are creating after insert
mention the after insert on the customer
table
for each row
now begin so let us now create a trigger
here so the condition that we have taken
is if new DOT
first ID
is greater than
let's say 200. so in that case
insert into
customer new
values
new DOT trust ID
comma new Dot customer name
and then we have new DOT age command new
DOT address
right so let us just close this
and we have the end if
double slash so let us just execute this
query and we'll see the output
so our query has been successfully
executed uh let us now try to insert
some values into the customer table so
I'm using the insert into again insert
into customer
values so customer ID let's say I'm
taking 1.8 name of the customer let us
take Tria
let us take the age as 24 and address as
Pune
and similarly let us insert some more
values let us now take 2 naught four as
the customer ID name as uh harsh
and age is 27 and
address as Chennai
let us insert a final record which is
uh let's say 180 1.9
comma name as
Sam
uh age 24
CT let us take Hyderabad
close the brackets and let us insert one
more final record let us take 214 as are
the customer ID
and the name will be John
age 25
and city will be Mumbai
right so we have inserted the values
into our customer table
so as you can see four rows have been
inserted so let us just display the
records again
so as you can see uh we have four new
records of the customers having customer
ID one or date one or nine two not four
and two fourteen now let us see whether
our trigger has been created or not so
let us display the values from the
customer new table now select star from
customer
new
so as you can clearly see that the
trigger that we have applied to our
table is whenever the customer ID
exceeds 200 now in this case we have two
IDs of the customers which is 204 and
214. in that case the trigger will
automatically insert new values into the
new table instead of the previous table
which is customer so in this way the
after insert trigger works
all right uh moving ahead let us now
discuss about the before update in a
trigger now before update a trigger in
SQL is invoked automatically whenever an
update operation is performed or fired
on the table associated with that
trigger so let us just understand this
within example here so let us just
consider again the new employees table
here for our reference added another
attribute which is bonus in our table
now basically the trigger which are
going to create will be of this sort
wherein if you're updating the salary of
the employees let's say if you are
updating the salary of uh employees
whose salary is greater than 40 or 50
000 or 40 000 then we'll set the bonus
value as 5000 and if the salary is less
than 40 000 in that case that bonus will
be three thousand so let me just uh
write the syntax so that will have a
clear understanding of it
so we'll use the T limiter again
let us create a trigger
update bonus
so we are creating before update trigger
so I'm writing before update keyword on
new employees
for each row
let's go performing on all the rows
mention the begin statement
and mention the condition now so the
condition is basically is a new DOT
salary
is greater than
forty thousand
so in that case the new bonus value will
be
equals to 5000.
so else if uh if the salary
U dot salary
is less than forty thousand so in that
case we'll set the bonus value as 3000.
set new bonus equals to 3000 so mention
the semicolon and mention the end if
since we have used two end if statements
uh if statements so we'll mention ndf
two times before we close our statement
here
so let us now execute this statement and
we'll see the output so our query has
been successfully created here guys uh
let us now uh update the values in our
new employee table
so let us write the update statement
here so I'm updating the new employees
table so update new employees
set salary
equals to let's say 45
000 for only limited uh employees let's
say uh
whose employee ID is more than 200. so
I'm just taking a reference here or just
an example or a scenario so that will
have an understanding on how this before
update trigger works
whose employee ID is greater than 200.
so right let us just execute the
statement so as you can see seven rows
have been affected
so let us now display the new employees
table again so I'm using the select star
from new employees
all right so let us move aside and see
now as you can clearly see that now
employees who are having employees ID
more than 200 which you have taken in
our query now if you can see employee ID
of Michael Hassan is 211 and pathway 202
and for Susan Marvis we have 203 and so
on so for all those employees we have a
bonus attached to their uh
you know salary which is 5000 which is
basically the trigger that we have
created that is if the salary is more
than 40 000 in that case will invoke a
trigger where it will add bonus of 5000
to all those employees so in this way
before update trigger Works in SQL
foreign so in the same way you can also
create the before and after delete
trigger as well uh so now that you have
understood how to implement this and now
try to implement this before I insert
delete in your system if you are facing
any issues do let us know in the comment
section below will help you out uh if
you still face further issues let us uh
know that if you if you want us to
create a separate video on those as you
all know while working with vast
databases in SQL several tables and data
fields will require unique numbers now
for instance a column of the table with
a primary key or a unique constraint
will always require a new number that
means in that field you always need to
enter a new number and it's not have any
duplicate values so you might be able to
do it manually to a limited extent but
when it comes to enormous or large or
huge databases you might forget the last
unique number you have entered or merely
include the same number twice as it
isn't easy to remember everything right
besides it providing a unique number to
all the records is also a tedious task
and that's where Auto increment in SQL
comes to play so in this tutorial we are
going to discuss what exactly is auto
increment in SQL and how to use it so
without any further delay let's get
started let us now jump head into MySQL
workbench for execution part
so as you can see MySQL workmanship
started uh let me just enter the
password to enter into it
[Music]
all right we have logged in into our
MySQL workbench so before getting into
the execution part let us just quickly
understand what is auto increment now
the auto increment in SQL is basically a
feature that is applied to a field so
that it can automatically generate and
provide a unique value to every record
that you enter in an SQL table now this
field is often used as the primary key
column where you need to provide a
unique value for every record you add
however it can also be used for Unique
constraint columns as well
so let us now understand this with an
example here so let me just create a new
table uh so that we can implement it
so let's create a new table here which
is let's say orders
open the parenthesis and let us now
mention the columns that you want to
create so let us take the First Column
as
product ID
and product ID will be of int and we'll
make sure that it is not null and then
you know if you are working on SQL uh
you are it applies an auto increment
field with the keyword as Auto increment
so we'll write it as Auto increment
and then comma
mention the next attribute let's say let
us take as customer ID in our order
stable and I'm again giving int as the
data type for this and again we cannot
have customer ideas null so I'm
mentioning the constraint not null next
I am mentioning the product name that is
the list of orders that the a customer
has placed and the name of that product
and here I am taking the data type as
worker and I'm taking it size of up to
next let us take let's say Quantity
and let us then take it as in data type
and let's and finally we'll take price
which would be again of back cap of 20
size
so that's it I'll mention the comma and
let us
close it
so let us just execute this statement uh
there is another
I don't know guys why it is showing us
error let me just check it once
so I think there is another so let us
just uh create a table using this icon
here
so orders new
and let us mention the column names here
which is
customer ID
sorry first one will be protected
we have customer ID
and then we have
product name
and then quantity
and finally we'll take the price here
all right so let us give uh the product
ID as the auto increment we can
so click on this Auto increment value
where you can find it as Ai and let us
now execute click on apply and our table
will be created so as you can see our
table has now created uh so let us now
just insert some values into it and
we'll see the output
so mention the insert into mention the
table name that is orders
now in order to insert the values into
it you know you need not write the
product ID uh column here so we'll just
directly write the customer ID and we'll
see how the Autumn increment directly
works
so customer ID next we have a product
name
next we have quantity
next we have price
attention values and insert some values
so customer ID I'll just take it as 1.1
next product name let us take as AC
for quantity let's say 2 and price will
be 60 000.
all right and similarly let us insert
another value here
I am taking the next order customer ID
is one or two and we'll take the
next product as cooker
and close in my single brackets next we
will take quantity one and price will be
000 25 000 sorry
and finally let us take another example
let's say one or two one or two three
comma let's say phone as an X product
name and we will take uh
the quantity as 3 and the price will be
ninety thousand
all right we are good to go now let us
execute this statement and we'll see the
output
sorry orders
so as you can see three rows have been
inserted so let me just display the
values from it
so
so as you can see uh in the product ID
column where we haven't mentioned it in
our insert statement and it is
automatically generating the values like
sequential starting from 1 2 and 3. now
you can also make an auto increment in
SQL or to start from another value with
the following syntax using the alter
table as well guys now let's say if
you're working on an employee table or
let's say if you are working on any
other student table for example in that
uh it might be of different digits like
the employee ID can be of 5 digits or
six digits so in that case you have to
change the order in which you want to
create and increase the employee IDs
right so in that case what we'll do is
we'll write alter table
and then mention the table name so we
are taking orders new table here
and mention the auto increment
keyword
and set from where you want to start it
so let's say if I want to start it from
uh 12 000 and one right
so let us just execute and we'll see the
output
so our query has been executed so let us
now uh insert some more values into our
table and we'll see how it goes
so let me just
now I'll add some more values like 107
comma
the product name as cooker
let's say the quantity two and the price
will be
uh 50 000.
similarly let us take another
record let's say 109 comma
let us take as
tablet as a product name and then we'll
mention the
number of quantity as 4 and price will
be 1 lakh 50 000.
all right so let's just execute the
statement and we'll see the output
so uh two rows have been inserted into a
table successfully so let us just call
the uh orders node table again so let me
just do is Select statement select star
from artists
RSU
so as you can see the now there are two
records that you have inserted which is
of customer ID 107 and 109 and the
orders they have placed as cooker and
tablet now if you look at the product ID
we have started uh their product ID from
12001 and sequentially it will increase
the value by one that is now we have
12001 and next we have the twelve
thousand two so in this way you can use
the auto increment in SQL to setup
values in order to make them uh
automatically updates for your for your
database now instead of writing every
time you can just simply mention the
auto increment and it will do the job
and if you're working on various other
databases like SQL server or even Oracle
in that case the syntax will change in
that case what you have to do is in the
create statement you have to take a
the keyword as identity
and mention the values from which your
column name uh column values will start
let's say I'm taking as 100 comma and
how much values you want to increment
like let's say for you mention one it
will increase the value by one like 100
100 and 102 and so on but if I take it
as let's say 5 then it will start from
100 next the value will be 1.5 110 and
so on
so in this way if you are working on
various other databases you can use this
as well so that brings us to the end of
today's session guys I hope you
understood how to use the auto increment
in SQL so now that you have learned
everything about Auto increment in SQL
and we have gone through the use of Auto
meant in SQL and to set up in different
dbms servers so I hope you can execute
in yourself as you all know as a SQL
Developer you often work with enormous
amounts of data stored in different
tables right so that are present inside
the multiple databases now it often
becomes uh difficult to extract the data
if it is not organized correctly so
using normalization you can solve the
problem of data redundancy and organize
the data using different forms so this
tutorial will help you to get uh know
the concepts of normalization in SQL in
detail so without any further Ado let us
dive into today's topic so let me just
present you my screen firstly let us go
through the agenda for today's session
guys uh we'll start the tutorial by
understanding what is normalization in
SQL and then we'll understand why do we
need normalization and after that we'll
discuss various types of normalization
used in SQL which are basically
different normal form such as first
normal form second normal form third
normal form and BC enough which is bias
for normal form and finally we'll wrap
up the session by discussing some
advantages and disadvantages of
normalization so without any further Ado
let us just dive into today's topic
all right so what is normalization in
SQL normalization is the process to
eliminate data redundancy and enhance
data Integrity in the table
normalization also helps to organize the
data in the database and it is a
multi-step process that sets the data
into tabular form and removes all the
duplicated data that is the repeated
data in the relational database tables
normalization organizes the columns at
tables of a database to ensure the
database Integrity constraints properly
execute their dependencies so it is a
systematic technique of decomposing
tables to eliminate data redundancy and
various other undesirable
characteristics
now to better understand this concept it
simply means to bring something to its
normal State not from that what I mean
is the columns and tables are organized
to ensure that the data Integrity
constraints are appropriately executed
with their dependencies in normalization
so normalization in SQL is mainly used
to reduce the redundancy of the data
since SQL is a language that interacts
with the database to start any
interactions with the data in the
database the data which is present in
this database should be the normalized
form before it is processed further so
that's why normalization in SQL improves
the data distribution in the database
across
next why do we need normalization
now as discussed earlier normalization
is used to reduce data redundancy which
is the most important thing so it
provides a method uh to remove the
following anomalies from the database
and bring it to a more consistent State
now a database anomaly is a flaw in a
database that occurs because of various
reasons such as food planning and
redundancy now there are various reasons
such as insertion anomalies which occurs
when we are not able to insert data into
a database because some attributes may
be missing at the time of inter
insertion next we have updation anomaly
as well which occurs when the same data
items are repeated with the same values
and are not linked to each other and
finally we have deletion anomaly which
occurs when deleting one part of the
data relates the other unnecessary or
necessary information from the database
so that is the reason we need
normalization so if I put them into a
nutshell these are the main objectives
of normalization guys so the
normalization removes duplicated and
database anomalies from the relational
database it also reduces redundancy and
complexity of database by clearing
unwanted records or values in the
database it is also used to avoid
creating and updating any unwanted data
connections and dependencies now if you
are working on a multiple tables there
may be a chance of unwanted connections
so normalization prevents that it is
also used to optimize storage space as
well guys now you don't want unnecessary
or repeated values in a in your database
or tables right so to organize and
optimize the storage space so we need
normalization and finally isolation of
data is also maintained now a good
design database states that the changes
in one table or field do not should not
affect each other so this can be
achieved through normalization so these
were some of the uh important
characteristics of formalizations and
why we need it
all right moving ahead let us now
discuss some different types of
normalization in SQL now there are four
types of normal forms that are usually
used in relational database as you can
see in the following figure the first
one is first normal form of 1f next we
have second normal format 2nf next we
have three third normal format 3 and F
and finally we have boy Squad normal
form
now actually we divide the normalization
process into a set of normal forms so a
normal form is nothing but a form of a
table that follows some let's say rules
or regulations that prevent the above
anomalies that we have discussed earlier
to some extent
so let us discuss about them in detail
and see how they are different from each
other and understand why they are
important
so first what is first normal form or
one NFS now a table is referred to as
being in its first normal form if
atomicity of the table is one here
atomicity states that a single cell
cannot hold multiple values it must hold
only a single valued attribute the first
normal form disallows the multi-valid
attribute composite attributes and their
combinations I hope this is quite a bit
confusing so let us just understand the
first normal form with the help of an
example
so these are the two conditions which I
have already discussed that the
conditions to for a table to be in first
normal form is that every table should
sell should contain a single value and
each and every report must be unique
all right let us understand with an
example now in the student or table
let's say you can see the course column
has a certain values so if you look at
some of the courses and I assigned to
each student we have more than one
column that is the course column has two
values thus it does not follow the first
normal form now if you use the first
normal form to the above table you can
get the below table as a result if you
look at this side the second table in
that we have basically divided or the
record into two parts that is Harsh
whose roll number is one who has
enrolled in courses SQL and Java which
were basically dividing into two records
separately that is hush 22 SQL course
and similarly Hertz 22 into Java and
similarly we have for Kunal as well was
enrolled for courses C and HTML and also
we have Sanya who has enrolled for
Python and SQL which we have basically
separated into two different records so
by applying the first normal form you
can achieve atomicity and and also every
column has unique values so that was
first normal form guys let us now move
into the next normal form which is
second normal form
so the second step in a normalization is
basically 2nf or the second normal form
which is basically an additional layer
added to the one enough so a table or a
relation isn't 2 enough only if the
relation at the table should be uh in
first normal form that is it should
satisfy all the properties of the first
normal form while the relations every
non-prime attribute depends on every
candidate key as a whole
so it should meet all the rules and
every non-key attribute is fully
dependent on the primary key so I hope
this is a bit challenging and confusing
so let us again understand this uh with
an example here
all right now the uh second normal form
states that there shouldn't be any
partial dependence you know partial
dependency is nothing but if a proper
subset of a candidate key determines the
non-prime attribute then it is called a
partial dependency so let me just
explain you with an example here
consider this a student table here which
are student ID project ID student name
and project name here now in the above
table if you look at clearly we have
partial dependency let us understand how
now the prime key attributes here are
student ID and project ID and as stated
the non-prem attributes that is student
name and project name should be
functionally dependent on part of a
candidate key to be partially dependent
uh I hope you've uh confusing between
the keys guys so if you want to learn
more about SQL case we have a dedicated
and a separate video on our channel so
make sure you check that out so coming
back to the second normal form so the
student name can be determined here by
partial dependent so therefore the
student and project a relation the table
violates this 2nf in normalization and
is considered a bad database design
so to remove this partial dependency and
the violation of 2 uh to NF we have to
further decompose this table in order to
satisfy the property of second normal
form so let us now understand how can we
do that now basically I am converting
this student table into two separate
tables which is student info and project
into
now the student input table has the
student ID project ID and the student
name whereas the project info as project
ID and project name now a student name
can be identified separately with the
help of student ID so it is uniquely
identifying every record of the student
name using the student ID hence the
consider the
the condition has been satisfied here
and similarly we have the project info
with the help of project ID we can get
the name of different projects that are
allotted to students so now the relation
is in second normal form in the form of
a database normalization using the
second normal form I hope you understood
that guys
so moving ahead let us now understand
what is third normal form
now
in it is a normalization level in dbms
similar to that of 1nf and similarly to
NF
so a relation is said to be in third
normal form in SQL when it is in the
second normal form but no transitive
dependency exists for a non-prime
attribute
so let me just clearly explain you again
now a given relation is said to be in
its third normal form when it is in 2
and if that is it should satisfy a
second normal form properties that is
ultimately indirectly should satisfy
first normal form as well but has no
transitive partial dependency meaning
when no transitive dependency exists for
the attributes that are non-prime then
the relation can be said to be in 3 NF
so let's say in simpler words if I say
it should be in one enough or to NF when
none of the non-primary key attribute
transitively uh depend on their primary
Keys then we can say that relation is in
third normal form of 3 NF so we can see
that relation is in third normal form
when it holds any of the given condition
in case of functional dependency that is
non-trivial where p uh let's say x
relates to Y where X acts as a Super Key
and Y acts as a non-prem attribute
meaning every element of
y forms a part of a candidate key so let
us understand this uh with a simple
example guys so that you will have a
clear understanding of that so for that
I am taking another table which is
employee ID employee name Department
name uh City ZIP code as its attributes
all right now the super key in the table
mentioned above can the candidate ID
candidate ID plus candidate name or else
candidate ID candidate name and
candidate uh
let's say zip code and so on now the
candidate key here is basically the
employee ID because it is uniquely
identifying each and every record
so if you look at the non-prem
attributes all the attributes in the
table mentioned above are non-prime
instead only uh instead of the employee
ID right so notice that uh employee ID
and the employee City that the employee
belongs to are dependent on candidate
zip code and
he employs a zip code and uh employee
zip code is dependent on the employee ID
here all the non-prime attributes like
the city of the employee and employees
uh state
a dependently transitively on the Super
Key which is employee ID so the
transitive dependency here would violate
the rule of the third normal form thus
we must move the employee City and the
employees are zip code to a new table of
let's say into another table which is
zip info so if you look at these uh
resultant table where I have
segregated the original table which is
the employee table into three different
tables here which has the first one is
employee info which holds the employee
ID employee name Department as the
attributes and its information and in
the second table we have Department ID
and Department name separately and
finally I am categorizing the cities
based on their zip codes that is into
zip input table
so in this way you can use the third
normal form uh to perform the
normalization using the three NF
characteristics
all right let us now move into the final
normalization which is BC enough
now applications of uh General
definitions of 2nf and 3 NF May identify
additional redundancy caused by the
dependencies that can violate one or
more candidates key in a table so
however despite these additional country
constraints dependencies can still exist
that will cause redundancy to be present
in 3mf relations so this weakness in 3
NF resulted in the presentation of a
much stronger normal form called Boyce
called normal form or simply bcns
so it was uh initially started it was
coined by uh Dr H uh Court in 1970 1974
so we will understand how this works so
it basically adds a more layer to our
first normal form second normal form as
well as the third normal form
so a Boy Scout normal form is also known
as a 3.5 NF which is a superior or
Advanced version of 3 enough and was
developed by Raymond F boys as discussed
which could tackle certain types of
anomalies which were not resolved with
the help of the third normal form so the
first condition of the table to be
invoice for normal form is that the
table should be in the third normal form
and secondly every right hand side
attribute of the functional dependency
should depend on the Super Key of that
particular table so for example for any
dependency let's say a relation X to Y X
must be a candidate key or a Super Key
in other words for dependency X relates
to Y if Y is a any Prime attribute so X
cannot be a non-prem attribute so now in
general if a table is in a third normal
form it would possibly be in BC enough
and similarly like 4 NF and Phi NF as
well so we do not need much of BC enough
uh if we know what is exactly one enough
to NF and 3 MF we are good to go and
which which is more than sufficient uh
for a beginner level
so that was all about the bcnf guys and
that brings us to the end of uh today's
session and let us now finally
understand some of the benefits of
normalization by
understanding some advantages of
normalization now the first obvious
reason is it reduces redundant data now
we might have a multiple data or
multiple values in our database we
thought because of human errors or we do
not know what we are entering so we
might add additional files without our
knowledge so in order to reduce that you
know repeated values or unnecessary
records we need normalization
normalization also provides data
consistency within the database and it
is also more flexible and it gives more
flexible data design which in turn gives
a higher database security and it is
also better and quicker in execution as
well
so that was a main uh
you see advantages of normalization and
talking about uh disadvantages there are
not there aren't much disadvantages to
talk about uh like since the data is not
duplicated we need table joints uh you
know more numbers which would make
queries more complicated and thus read
times are also slower since joints are
required the indexing of the uh tables
also does not work as efficiently again
this makes read time slower because the
joints don't typically work well with
the indexing
so that brings us to the uh end of
today's tutorial guys I hope you
understood the tutorial so
let us just wrap up what you have
discussed we have discussed about
various uh normal forms such as one and
F2 NF and three NF in our tutorial so in
this tutorial you have seen
normalization in SQL in a glance and
understood how the different normal
forms of normalization now you can
organize the data in the database and
remove the data redundancy and promote
and Achieve data integrity so in terms
of if you're working on the SQL
databases this isn't much an important
concept but this tutorial also helps for
you if you are preparing for any
interviews which which is a basic
question which is asked in many of the
interviews in various companies so it is
important to understand the concept of
normalization in SQL
so I hope you understood this and a good
indexes are the key to good performance
in SQL and the key to creating good
indexes is to understand what indexes
are and how SQL uses them to evaluate
queries now an SQL index is a structure
within SQL 2 which is used to quickly
locate specific rows within a table more
on that soon but before we get started
if you're into the channel and haven't
subscribed already consider getting
subscribed to our Channel simply code to
stay updated with all the latest
Technologies and hit that Bell icon to
never miss an update from us so without
any further Ado let's get started with
today's topic
firstly let us go through the agenda for
today's session we'll start the tutorial
by understanding what is indexing in SQL
and then we'll go through different
characteristics of indexing in SQL after
that we'll understand why we exactly use
indexing in SQL up next we'll discuss
how exactly indexing Works in SQL and
then we'll discuss how to create an
index using its syntax and after that
we'll be going through the syntax and
execution of the indexic part in MySQL
workbench using certain examples after
that let us discuss advantages and
disadvantages of using indexing and
finally we'll wrap up the session by
understanding when you should be using
and when you should not be using uh
indexing in SQL I hope the agenda is
clear uh so let us just dive into State
into today's topic
all right so what is indexing in SQL
indexes are basically a special lookup
tables that need to be used by database
search engine to speed up the data
retrieval process so an index is simply
a reference to data in a table and a
database index is similar to that to the
index in a pack of a book now it also
retrieves a vast amount of data from the
tables quickly so if you are working on
large databases that has chunks amount
of data in that case indexing is useful
now indexing makes columns faster to
query by creating pointers to where data
is stored within a database we'll
understand when uh we'll discuss how
exactly indexing work so now for example
in order to reference all pages in a
book that address a particular subject
you go to the index first which lists
all the topics alphabetically right so
if you consider a textbook it has
various topics which caters to a
particular subject so if you want to
find a particular topic you go to one or
one specific page numbers now indexes
are in a database are similar to that of
indexes that you find in a book guys so
if a book has an index and if I ask you
to find a chapter in that book you can
quickly find that with the help of the
index on the other hand if the book does
not have any index you'll have to spend
more time looking for the chapter by
looking at each and every page from the
start to the end of the book so it is
time taking and tedious as well so
simply you can use the index and you can
directly go to that page
so basically indexes uh prevent
duplicate entries in the columns or
combination of columns on which it is
created
so you can say that MySQL indexes are
you quickly used to find rows within a
specific column values and without an
index MySQL or any SQL database must
scan the whole table to locate the
relevant rows so now the larger the
table becomes the slower it searches so
I hope you understood what exactly is
indexing in SQL let us now understand
why we use indexing in SQL
now indexes are built to provide faster
data access to the user to the specific
data your query is try to retrieve now
indexing in dbms is a technique that
uses data structures to optimize the
searching time of a database query and
makes that overall database performs
better
now indexes are used for faster data
recovery guys uh indexes are used to
quickly locate data without having to
search every row in a database table
every time a database table is accessed
indexes can be created using one or more
Columns of a database providing the
basis for both random lookups and
efficient access of ordered records
and finally indexes provides search
efficiency and index can be used to
efficiently find all rows matching some
columns in your query and then walk
through only that subset of the table to
find exact matches so if you don't have
indexes on any column in the where
clause or the select Clause the SQL
engine has to walk through the whole
table and check every row to see if it
matches which may be a slow operation on
big tables or if you're working on large
data assets which has like thousands or
lakhs of data so these are the main
reasons why we exactly use indexes in
SQL
all right let us now understand how
exactly uh indexing works now generally
the database takes the columns provided
with the create index command and sorts
the column values using a special data
structure called as bleed trees now A B
tree is a type of tree data structure
that contains two things which is
basically the index and the uh index Qi
and the corresponding disk address now
index key refers to a certain disk
address and that disk further contains
rows or tuples of data now using battery
we can achieve faster searches and
faster retrievals of data and since the
data structure beat Rays sorted in order
it makes a search more efficient so this
is how in general index Works in SQL so
let us understand this with an example
here guys
now let us consider we have an employee
table which has let's say 200 records in
it now employee ID in that table let us
consider it as a primary key so by
default an index on the employee ID
column is created this means employee
data is sorted by employee ID column and
physically stored in series of data
Pages here in a tree like structure that
look like the following which is like
the visible on the screen as you can see
uh so let's say the notes at the bottom
of the tree are basically called as data
Pages or Leaf nodes and contains the
actual data rows in our case the
employee data information so these
employee rows are sorted by employee ID
column because employee ID is the
primary key and by default an index on
this column is already created
now for example let's say uh in our
employee table we have 200 rows and let
us assume in each Data Page we have
let's say 25 25 rows in each of them so
the First Data Page we have is from 1 to
25 in the second we have from 26 to 50
and then 51 to 75 and so on and so forth
and they know at the top of the tree as
you can see is called as the root node
guys and then node between the root node
and the leaf node are called as
intermediate level nodes so the root and
the intermediate level loads contain
index rows as you can see the uh one to
two hundred rows has been further uh
subjugated into one two hundred and into
1.1 to 200 and so on so each index row
contains a key value which is in our
case as the employee ID and the pointer
to either an intermediate intermediate
level page in the B3 or a data Row in
the leaf node has been given so this
three like structure has a series of
pointer that helps the query engine find
data quickly
now let us understand how SQL finds the
particular rope by ID that we want to
search for example let's say we want to
find employee row which is having
employee ID as 96. so in that case how
the SQL engine performs indexing on this
data so basically the database engine
starts at the root node and it picks the
index node which is the root or that is
from 1 to 200
and it basically searches on the left
side because the one to two hundred uh
data has been further divided into 1 200
onto the left side right so because the
data engine knows it is this node that
contains employee ID from 1 to 100 it
will basically look for all the records
starting from 1 to 100. from there it
picks the leaf node that is present on
the extreme left because employee data
Rose from 1 to 100 again and the present
in this leaves node and then the data
rows in the leaf load are sorted by
employee ID so it is easy for the
database engine to find the employer row
with ID 96 here so as you can see in
just three operations uh SQL is able to
find the data we are looking for so it's
making use of the index we have on the
table and Performing the operation in a
most simplest way so this is how exactly
SQL indexing works
all right moving ahead let us now
discuss how to create an index in SQL
now creating an index involves a create
index statement which allows you to name
the index name to the specify that table
and which column or columns that you
want to create index so this command is
used for basically generating the table
index in SQL using the build index
expression so let us now go through the
syntax the syntax is followed as create
index which is the Keyword Index name on
table name and in within the brackets
you have to mention the column name so
if you want to create indexes for more
than one column in that case you have to
mention the different column names and
the queries followed as create index
index name on table name column one
column two and so on so basically we can
generate sorted list using indexes in
SQL instead of having to create new
sorted table which would take up a lot
of storage space right so for example if
I want to create an index let's say
index under score ID on a tables called
students and on the column student ID
then in that case the query would be
followers create index index ID on
students student ID so basically if you
are working on the student ID column and
if you want to fetch details which has a
relation to that attribute in that case
you can use this example I hope the
syntax is clear so let us now jump
straight into MySQL workbench for the
execution part
so as you can see MySQL workbench has
started and we are good to go now so as
discussed earlier in order to perform
indexing in SQL you need a data set or a
table that has a large number of Records
now when I talk about number of Records
it shouldn't be like a 100 or 200 it
should have more than 100 like in
thousands so I have downloaded a data
set from kaggle uh which is of our
Netflix information which is as you can
see in this Excel sheet which has the
show ID the type title director country
date added release year rating duration
and the genre of that particular movie
or show so if you look at this table we
have like thousands of Records I guess
uh let me just scroll down and show you
guys
so as you can see we have a chunk of
Records uh as you can see we have a
total of 1896 records so I think we can
perform indexing on this table and we'll
see how it works so let us just import
the data set first so right click on the
uh table section
click on browse and the table name is
Netflix Open the table next click on
next
again click on next and we are good to
go and we can import the data now so
click on next again
so wait some time uh depending upon your
net speed or uh your RAM functions it
will take some time so just hold back
for some time and let it finish so as
you can see uh the data has been
successfully imported click on next
I think only 264 records have been
important I don't know why exactly but
it's okay let us go ahead and let us
understand how it works anyway
so let us just uh double click here and
we'll refresh the schema but as you can
see Netflix table has been added so let
me just display the values from the
table so I'm using this select operator
select star from Netflix
so let's execute this query and we'll
see the output as you can see uh various
attributes that we have discussed
earlier has been displaying in our
resultant table so let us now go ahead
and we'll uh let us write a simple query
first let's say if I want to select
all the titles uh or the shows that are
related to movie type and uh that have
the release here let's say after 2000 so
in that case I'll take as select
title
comma
type
comma release
okay as title type
from table Netflix
where
release year
is greater than 2000.
so let me just execute this query
so as you can see it will display the
records of all those titles and the type
of that show or the movie name which is
released after 2000 now if you look at
the duration part I am not sure why it
is showing 0.00 seconds but it should
like it should specify like more than
like half a second or something but I'm
not sure why it is but it is showing
like that so maybe since we have
imported only a limited number of rows
that is like almost around 300 that is
the reason why it is showing uh in 0.00
seconds but in general if you're working
on large data sets which have thousands
of Records it will generally take like
0.05 or 0.36 seconds like that so let us
go ahead and let us just create a you
know a simple index for this table
Netflix so the queries uh followed as
create index let us take index I'm
taking indexing on title so I'll just
specify index okay Netflix will function
the table name here on table name that
is Netflix and mention all the columns
that you want to create and index on so
I'll basically specify the title and the
type
okay first we'll discuss on one column
and we'll see the output
so let us execute this
so there was an error in the data type
that we have mentioned since the title
which is the column uh name has a data
type of text so we have to mention the
uh number of bytes that it takes so I'm
basically mentioning 20 here so let us
just execute the statement and we'll see
the output so as you can see our index
which is index underscore Netflix has
been successfully created and if you
look at the duration here it has taken
0.078 seconds in order to execute this
query now similarly uh if you are
working on large data sets and where
when you are querying data for example
Select Title type from Netflix where
release Here is greater than 2000 it
generally takes more than like half a
second but I don't know why it is
showing since we have taken only certain
number of Records so again when you
retrieve the query where you want to
Select Title type from the Netflix where
the release year is greater than 2000
it'll basically take duration almost
like in milliseconds like it is showing
0.00 seconds but it will take a Max to
Max up to one or two millisecond ends
only so in this way you can use index on
certain columns now if you want to
create multiple indexes on different
various columns you can specify the
different column names as well so I'll
just copy this and I'll show you how it
actually works
so title and similarly I want to uh
create an index for the type as well so
20.
let me just execute the statement
so I think we have to take another
keyword here so let me just take index
new on Netflix
so as you can see a new index has been
created successfully wherein it will
create a new index for title and type so
whenever you are performing a certain
query in order to retrieve the data from
these two columns that is title and type
it will basically speed up the query
process and it will retrieve the results
quickly
so let's say if you want to uh know all
the indexes that you have applied on the
table so in that case you have to write
as show index
from table name which is Netflix
so it will basically show all the index
details as you can see we have created
three indexes till now on the Netflix
table for example index Netflix index
new index YouTube two times uh we have
created uh indexes on column names like
title type and similarly you can see the
index type is of B tree which we have
discussed earlier and it of course has
null values now finally if you want to
delete
the indexes that you have created on
your table in that case you have to
mention drop index
so the indexer that we have created for
example let's say index Netflix
table
drop the index so as you can see it was
successfully uh deleted so let me just
show the indexes as you can clearly see
index Netflix has been successfully
created so in this way you can use the
indexes as I discussed earlier in order
to
make sure that your results are being
processed fast and the data that you
have in your tables are being retrieved
quickly so in that case you will
basically use the indexes I hope you
understood with this so let us now move
ahead and let us discuss some advantages
and disadvantages of indexes
so firstly let us discuss some of the
advantages of index uh index basically
gives the query optimization which
basically gives increased performance in
searching for records or even sorting
records grouping different records or
maintaining a unique uh columns and it
will also speed up the select query and
similarly you can also uh speed up the
process of the queries using the select
as well as the where plus as well index
also gives you uniqueness guys uh
indexes like primary key index and
unique uh index helps to avoid duplicate
rows data and finally indexes make it
possible to quickly retrieve data which
is obviously one of the main
characteristics of indexes
now there are a certain number of
disadvantages as well uh the first one
is the indexes takes up more or
additional disk space usually the space
usage usage isn't significant but
because of creating index on every
column in every possible combination the
index file would grow much more quickly
from the data file so in the case when a
table is of larger table size or the
data set you are performing is of a
larger size the index file could reach
the operating system's maximum file size
and it can take a lot of size as well
now secondly the indexes slow down the
speed of writing query such as insert
update and delete because uh in MySQL
MySQL has to internally maintain the
pointers to the inserted rows in the
actual data file so there is a
performance deficit in order to pay in
case of above said the writing queries
like insert operations update operations
and delete operations because every time
a record is updated or changed or
manipulated the indexes must also be
updated so however you might be able to
write your queries in a way that do not
cost that very notable noticeable
performance degradation right
so these were some advantages and
disadvantages of indexing
so finally we'll move to our segment
which is when should you avoid using
indexes in SQL now indexes should not be
used in small tables like as I said
earlier indexes are only confined to
large data sets or large tables that you
want to retrieve the information from so
if a table has let's say less than
thousands of Records I think it's better
to avoid using indexes and it will be of
no use as well
next tables that have frequent or large
batch updates or insert operations now
you can use indexes on uh huge chunks of
data sets that have like frequent
changes to its you know values for
example if you're performing uh various
search or insert operations on your
tables in that case you can take the
index and finally attributes and Fields
that are frequently manipulated should
not be indexed so if you're working on
certain columns and the values that are
frequently manipulated or updated in
that case you have to not use indexes so
that were some exemptions in the cases
where so as discussed earlier we will be
discussing about SQL regex which is a
regular Expressions now as we all know
databases are enormous enormous
collections of data that are stored into
organized data sets but frequently we
encounter circumstances in which we need
to get some particular data but like the
information necessary to filter it out
regular Expressions which is a fantastic
feature of SQL comes in handy in this
situation so in this tutorial I will
provide you with entire explanation of
SQL regex and we'll see how to use them
to these mediums or various syntaxes and
Etc
so let me just present my screen so that
we will go to the presentation part
all right I hope my screen is clearly
visible guys uh so let us first
understand what is SQL records now SQL
regex is defined as regular expression
which contains a sequence of characters
that are used to search and find a
particular sequence of characters that
matches a pattern it is a rule that
defines uh the way characters should
appear on an Expression search pattern
is determined by the sequence of
character or set text say for example if
you want to identify the data that
contains a combination like a student's
name a contact number email ID we can
use a regular expression it is also used
in cases where you need to identify a
particular text pattern or you need to
apply a filter over numbers text or
special characters data now you might be
wondering we have SQL like operation so
why is it how is it different from uh
like operation so basically guys if
you're working on complex data set and
if you are
search pattern is quite difficult in
that case you have to use the SQL record
so basically a regular expression
provide a powerful means of identifying
a pattern within a body of text so a
pattern describes what the text to
identify looks like and it could be
something quite simple such as that
which describes any let's say a three
letter word or a four letter word to
something quite complex like that which
can describe as an email address
so it is a tool that gives you a concise
and flexible way to identify strings of
text for a text example like characters
words based on patterns and Etc
so let us now understand why we use SQL
regex
now regular Expressions provide a
powerful and flexible pattern matching
that can help us Implement power search
utilities for our database systems and
it are also and it is also not case
sensitive that is it can work on both
uppercase and the lowercase as well so
if you want a particular case uh you can
mention them and you can proceed with
your database set
so basically it provides a simple yet
powerful mechanism for rapidly
describing patterns and greatly
simplifies the way in which you search
extract format and manipulate the data
in your database
the second reason is it queries database
to find a smaller subset of data within
a table now we as we all know that a
simple form of pattern matching has been
a part of SQL through the likes of the
SQL like operator condition that
provides two variants of wild cards with
the zero or more than one characters
that is the percentage and the
underscore so such characters are termed
as meta characters as they describe the
pattern rather than the Patek in it so a
simple example could be like you know if
you want to find a name that starts with
ABC in that case we use ABC percentage
that matches any row that begins with
the characters ABC right so in many
cases like is limiting and other
Solutions have been sought as mean to
perform more complexes queries so that
is the reason we started using SQL rig X
and finally as discussed it's suppose we
supports various meta characters for
more flexibility now unlike SQL like
which provides only two while characters
that is percentage and underscore we
have a lot of meta characters uh when we
use regular Expressions which we'll be
discussing in a while
so those are some of the reasons why we
need to use SQL regex and finally uh
we'll discuss how it is different from
SQL like operation as well when we jump
into MySQL for execution part
so let us now understand the syntax of
our reg X that is regular expression the
syntax is followed as select column list
from table name where string column
regular expression pattern so basically
the statement performs a pattern match
of a string column against a pattern so
if a value in the string column matches
the pattern the expression in the uh
where Clause returns true otherwise it
returns false so if either a string
column or the pattern is null the result
rent set is also a null
so again we have the select statement
which is the standard SQL keyword to
retrieve the data and we have the column
list which basically specify the rows
that are to be retrieved and we have
where clause which is used to specify a
condition while fetching the data and
then we have the field names which
represents the name of the column on
which the regular expression needs to be
applied on and then we also have the
regex P which is the keyword that is
used to find the pattern and finally you
have to mention the pattern which is
basically a user defined regex pattern
using certain meta characters to search
the data
all right so let us now discuss some
regular expression meta characters that
are used in SQL now the first one is the
asterisk operator so the asterisk meta
character basically is used to match
zero or more instances of the strings
preceding it now we'll understand this
uh when we are executing in the MySQL
workbench so I'll just explain the
description of how this uh meta
characters work so next we have the plus
meta character which is used to match
one or more instances of a string and
next we have the question meta character
which is used to match zero or only one
instance of a string and then we have
the dot character which is used to match
any single character in exception of any
new line
and then we have the carrot which is the
symbol which you can see and we have the
vertical bar or the pipe symbol which is
used to start the matching at beginning
and which is used to find the characters
alternatively respectively
next we have the square brackets and the
uh close brackets which are used to
match any of the characters in
the enclosed characters which basically
matches all the characters that are
mentioned within the brackets and if you
want to find exact uh
so exact name of the character's name
you have to take the closed brackets and
then we have the closed brackets and
when we have the uh carrot carrot meta
character which is used to match only
character those characters excluding the
ones that are enclosed within the uh
square brackets and finally next we have
the uh uppercase and lowercase
characters as well if you want to
specify only if you want to retrieve
only certain uh data which is in like if
you if you want in uppercase letters you
can use from A to Z which in Upper cases
and similarly in uh lower cases that is
from A to Z and finally you can also
perform operations on the numerical
values as well so Within These uh square
brackets you can mention any numbers
starting from ranging from 0 to 9 which
basically matches any digits from 0
through 9. so these are the most
commonly used regular expression meta
characters
so let us now discuss some uh SQL reacts
operation and see how they exactly work
so you can also take a snapshot of this
so that you can it can be handy in
future as well so for example if I have
an expression where I am stating as ABC
that means the query is basically
searching the exact character sequence
that is ABC that it should be in a
proper sequence but it can be in any way
that can be in any position of this
string and next we have the carrot ABC
that is
ABC should start at the beginning of
this string and similarly we have ABC
dollar sign which will basically search
for ABC pattern at the end of the string
and we have a pi b which will retrieve
the values which has either a character
A or B
now we can also perform multiple
operations using various meta characters
simultaneously now if you look at here I
have taken the carrot I have taken the
pipe symbol as well as the dollar symbol
so which basically states that it will
look for the string ABC at the beginning
or at the end of the string so and so on
you can look at uh different operations
which will now discuss as we jump into
the MySQL workbench for execution part
so let us just jump into MySQL workbench
so as you can see MySQL workbench has
started uh let us now consider a simple
table
to perform MySQL regular operation so
let us just consider the Netflix table
which is in our database so let me just
retrieve the values I'm using select
star from Netflix
so the Netflix table has various
attributes here guys which has show ID
type title director uh country date
which is added release year rating
duration and journal
so let us perform some basic to Advanced
uh you know SQL regular uh queries so
let us start with a simple one which
matches literally the complete uh
sequence of a string that we have
discussed earlier so let's say if I want
to find the title from the Netflix table
where the title starts with let's say
let's take any uh sequence like run okay
in that case the following query would
be Select Title from Netflix
where
title reg XP is the keyword
and within a single quotes mention the
characters that you want to see so let
us take a run as I've said earlier let
us just execute this query and we'll see
the output so it will basically search
for all those titles which has ran that
is ran in the same order or the same
sequence so if you look at here paranoia
which has a r a n in the same or the in
the same order
and similarly we have Transformers again
which yeah it has ran and if you want to
look at the next title which is how to
become a tyrant similarly in Tyrant we
have ran and so on so in this case you
can uh you can take the multiple
characters to find a complete sequence
that is in its original sequence
all right moving ahead uh not just only
characters guys uh you can also find for
a particular word which is basically a
substring so let's say if I want to find
a
let's cancel love so if you want love in
our title let us just mention love in
the single brackets and we'll see the
output
so as you can see there are a total of
three titles that has a love substring
in the complete title for example Sam
Smith Love Goes live at Abbey Road
Studios and next we have loved on Costa
thing and finally Love Enough
all right moving ahead let us now
discuss another example where we'll use
the asterisk the plus sign and the
question mark
so let's say if I want to find the title
from the Netflix table again where in
the pattern is it starts with A and N
and it should at least have
a one instance that it occurs and
finally it should have an K so what and
it's bit confusing so let me just write
the query so that you guys will
understand so select titles from Netflix
where title
reg XP
a n
star operator and mention Q
so what this query does is it will find
all the titles from the Netflix table
which has a which has n that is now as
we discussed the Aztec operator finds
you know characters which have zero or
more instances that occurs in a table
right so in that case the asterisk
operators work so let us now execute and
we'll see the output
so as you can see these are all the
titles that has a and K as the sequence
wherein it can have 0 or more than one n
so if you look at a Sankofa it has a and
K which has one n and similarly if you
look at
the uh Bangkok breaking it does not have
n in between that is because it can have
0 or more than one n so in that case we
are taking uh the Bangkok breaking as
well in our title and similarly the
others as well
so in this way if you want to use uh
this asterisk operator wherein the first
one has a character and then the next
one has zero or more than one instance
of appearing in the uh sequences that
you have mentioned in that case you will
use the asterisk operator
so let us now take another example where
we'll understand how to use the uh the
pipe uh meta character let's say if you
want to find the genre of all the uh
details of the titles you know where it
can be crime or it can be either
thriller or it can be fantasy so in that
case the following query would be select
start
from Netflix
where
Joanna
reg XP
within single quotes now I want the
genre to be either crime
and I'll mention the pipe symbol so do
not mention the space here guys uh
directly mention it and why it can be
Thriller and finally it can be a fantasy
as well
so let us just execute this statement
and we'll see the output
so as you can see if I scroll this a bit
so it will display the uh records of all
the titles that were added to Netflix
which has genre of either crime thriller
or fantasy so if you look at this uh
for example title ganglands which is
crime TV shows simrani second one we
have crime again and if you look at we
have a thriller here which is basically
movie Paranoia and similarly we have
fantasy as as well I guess if you scroll
down a bit we can find it
so as you can see we have action
adventure subscriber and fantasy so it
will basically search for all the uh
substrings which has basically has a
crime a thriller a fantasy substring in
the genre names
so this is how you can use uh the pipe
operator instead of now when we if you
remember if we use the SQL like operator
which we use the percentage sign right
so in that we have to use multiple or uh
operator in order to find the result so
in this case we are just mentioning the
pipe operator which will automatically
search for all the uh
characters or the strings that you have
mentioned
all right let us now move to another
example where and discuss another
scenario wherein will uh
Match multiple multiple characters with
a single characters so what I mean from
that is uh let's say if I want to find
the details of all the titles which has
a combination of characters B C and R
so in that case the following query
would be
select
star
from
Netflix
where title
reg XP
now within the close brackets I'll
mention two words that is b r
sorry b c let us take as a b c and I'll
close the brackets and I'll mention R
next so it will basically search for all
the patterns which has either b r or CR
in the title name so let us just execute
this and we'll see the output
okay let us just only mention the title
so that we have a clear idea
all right so as you can see uh if you
look at the pattern BR right so in the
first one we have the Great British
which has BR continuously so it does not
mean that it can have it any random
position it should be in a sequential
order that is continuous position so BR
we have British right next if we look at
the Bridget and again we have b r and
similarly if you look at the Cobra Kai
we have BR again so that was one
instance now if you look at this CR
combination right if you compare to the
CR combination we have crime source
which has CR and similarly if you scroll
down a bit as well you can find some
more examples of CR as well so again you
can find Crocodile Dundee in Los Angeles
which again starts with CR pattern
so in this way you can uh find multiple
characters while mentioning them in the
square brackets and with a single
character as well
all right let us now move to another
example uh where we'll use the close
brackets now the close brackets is
complete opposite of the square brackets
which will find the exact word that you
are trying to find so let's say if I am
finding if I want to retrieve the
director details of the shows that they
have directed
and the director's name should be either
let's say
Anthony on it should uh he can either
have its name has that can start with b
or or a character C so in that case what
I'll do is Select director
from Netflix
where
director
reg XP
mention a single quotes and we'll use
this operator
which is basically the carrot symbol
and within the uh close brackets I'm
mentioning I am doing that is the
director names should start with Anthony
or his name can start with B
or his name
can start with C so this is one of the
pattern that we are looking into now so
let us see how it executes
so let me just display the results
all right also we will use the order by
so that will happen
the assignment descending or ascending
order as per our wish
all right as you can see in the
resultant Set uh the director's name has
started with
B so which is satisfying a condition
which you have taken B and similar if
you score line we have the director's
name starting with C which is again
satisfying the condition that we have
taken and also it will look for the
director name whether it is starting
with Anthony or not so I don't think we
have Anthony here in this
so it will omit so you can basically
take uh any other character as well so
let's say if I want the uh the director
names to start with M so in that case it
will search for it as well
so if you scroll down it will display
the reports of all the directors who has
M as the starting letter so we have like
Mark ROMs and Mark Thornton and Martin
Campbell and similarly Etc so in this
way you can use the close brackets with
the carrot symbol as well as the pipe
symbol to find another pattern in this
way as well
so now if we want to find the director's
name other than MB or C in that case you
have to use the negation operator which
is basically another carrot which should
be embedded inside the close brackets so
when you execute this query
sure like this
all right so we have to use the square
brackets here in order to retrieve all
the details of director's name whose
name doesn't start with the characters m
b or c so if you look at the result and
set it is displaying the director's
names like starting with a d f g h j and
so on
s t w and y that is basically except M B
and C characters it will display the
records of all the directors
so in this way you can also use this
kind of pattern in order to find the
data as well so let us look into our
final uh
you know example wherein will perform a
complex you know regular expression
search wherein will find the title the
directors and the release year and the
type that is the genre from the table
where the title uh name will be within a
range so let us consider a range here
that is the
all these uh the talent title that where
the title name starts with a character C
and it can be in between C to K and it
should have a
type
from Netflix
[Applause]
where
title
reg XP is a keyword
open the single brackets I'll mention
the carrot symbol and let us mention the
range now so I want the uh title's name
in the range of the characters C to K so
let us mention them and we'll close the
brackets
and then mention the dot symbol because
it will allow you to find a single
character in between and will have a
total of 12 characters so the title name
should be of total 12 characters and we
have to mention the dollar symbol
so let us just execute this statement
and we'll see the output
so if you look at the result and set in
the uh
we have the title names which has a
total of 12 letters so if you count the
first title which is final account one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten eleven twelve so it has exactly
twelve uh characters in it and it is
also satisfying the condition uh within
the range that is it is starting
with the character F which is lying in
the range of C to K and similarly all
the others as well so in this way you
can also mention the uh range in the
pattern that you want to search for as
well and you can also use the numerical
values now we don't have as such of
numerical values to retrieve so I'm not
taking any examples
so I hope you understood this various
scenario guys
so that brings us to the end of today's
session uh that was all about the SQL
regex
operator now the
now as we know that the advantage of
using a regular expression is that
you're not limited to search for a
string based on a fixed pattern with the
percentage sign or a underscore which is
the Wild Card characters in The like
operator so the regular expression have
more meta characters to construct
flexible as well as the complex patterns
so that is the reason why we are using
the SQL regex operation and coming to
the uh disadvantages of using a regular
expression is that it is quite you know
difficult to understand and maintain a
complicated pattern so if you are an SQL
beginner you might struggle with uh you
know all these patterns so with a
question given you have to change the
patterns accordingly so if you are
working on first time with this regular
expression so you might find it a bit
difficult so therefore you should
describe the meaning of the regular
expression uh in the comment of the SQL
statement so that you can understand
clearly in addition the speed of the
data retrieval in some cases is also
decreased if you know use complex
pattern in regular expression
now as you all know working on Long
queries uh with complex logic is common
for any SQL Developer out there so this
can include using various joins various
levels of aggregation date aggregations
and filtering across any number of
tables now in some cases a result
resultant set can be cannot be obtained
with a single query using a select
statement or using a where condition it
requires a series of queries to be put
together now furthermore for complex
queries the best way to write a query is
to break it down into a logical steps
and will it piece by piece now sub
queries are typically one way to
consolidate functionality into a single
SQL statement that can be later be
incorporated back to the main query now
this has the potential to be useful but
it is also challenging for a beginners
who has just started with you know a new
level to read and comprehend and
understand it well
so this is where and it is possible to
simplify difficult queries into a
sequence of logical steps using CT or
comma table Expressions which also helps
to make your queries more readable and
allow you to produce more complex
resultant set so in this session we'll
be discussing all about common table
expressions or CTS in SQL how they are
used and Implement them using certain
examples in MySQL workbench so without
any further Ado let's get started
so firstly let us understand what is SQL
CTE now CT stands for Common Table
expressions and in SQL it is a temporary
resultant set that has a range within a
single SQL statement now a CT can be
referenced at any place within that
statement multiple times now generally
the width Clause is used to define a CTE
a Common Table expression do not exist
as a separate statement instead it is
always used along with a select insert
update or delete statement which
immediately follows the CT
so it is generally used
used and it enables users to write and
maintain complex queries easily with
increased readability and usability so
you can basically Define multiple
Expressions within a single query so
once Define these Expressions can be
referenced repeatedly throughout the
rest of your queries
now Common Table Expressions was
relatively a new SQL feature which was
later introduced in 1999 by Microsoft
SQL Server now CT was first introduced
in SQL server in the Year 2005 and then
post U SQL made them available starting
uh in 2009 and which is further used by
MySQL which which has waited a bit
longer and made them available in the
year 2018 starting with the version of
8.0 so again uh simply put it together
it is a temporary data set guys which
returns you know a query which is then
used by another query so in order to
reduce the complexity of a query we use
CT so it is temporary because the result
is not stored anywhere so it exists only
when the query is being run so that is
what uh CT is all about so let us now
move ahead and let us understand why we
use
SQL CT now the main reason is to start
the result of a complex subquery for
further use now in SQL we will use sub
queries to join the records or filter
the records from a sub query right so
whenever we refer the same data or join
the same set of Records using a sub
query the code maintainability will be
difficult so a CTE makes improved
readability and maintenance easier for
the user
and another reason being is uh CT can be
reusable guys now the reason uh why I'm
telling it is reusable means you know a
CT is reusable by Design instead of
having to declare the same sub query in
every place you need to use it you can
simply use a CTE to define a temporary
table once then refer to it whenever you
need it so you can call upon the
specified CT whenever you want in your
query also CT is more readable than a
sub query now another reason why we use
CT is they are more readable than sub
queries since CT can be reusable you can
write less code using CTE than using sub
query also people tend to follow the uh
logic that we put behind uh behind the
CT in an easier way than in a nested
query fashion so whenever you write a
query it is easier to break down a
complex query into smaller pieces using
CTE and finally CT increases the
performance of a query now if you're
working on a complex data performance is
Paramount right so using sub queries
using multiple joins and joining various
tables put together can uh you know
increase can decrease the performance of
a query now CT can be defined in various
uh
scenarios like in procedures views
triggers and many more so it can be used
recursively with a sub query not which
can ultimately increase the performance
of a query
all right let us now understand how CTE
works now a CT must be followed by a
single select insert update or a death
statement that references some or all
the CT columns so let us now understand
the syntax of a common table expression
the syntax is followed as with is the
keyword we use CTE name now you can
specify the name of your choice for the
CT as and within the parenthesis mention
the select statement with all the
columns you want to get in your
resultant table and from the table name
and close the parenthesis and after that
we'll be basically again selecting The
Columns from the CTE name instead of the
table and you can also specify the where
condition as per your requirement I hope
you understood the syntax and how CT
Works now it will be clear when we get
into the execution part so let us
directly jump into MySQL workbench for
execution
all right as you can see MySQL workbench
has started and let us now run some
queries using CT so let us just take an
example for that let us consider the
employee table for understanding how CT
Works so let me just display the values
from the employees table
all right so the employees table has
various attributes such as employee ID
first name last name email phone number
hiring date job ID salary manager ID and
a department ID so let us now run a
first query uh wherein will find the
highest salary of an employee working in
different departments or you can send
each department so in that case we'll
use a CTE here and as we discussed
earlier in the syntax it starts with the
width keyword and after that you can
give the CT name as per your choice so
let us give it as highest salary since
we are finding the highest salary of
employees in different departments so
highest salary and after that use the as
keyword and within the parenthesis use
the select statement and display all the
records that you want to fetch in a
resultant table so select I want my uh
first name of the employee last name
comma Department ID
comma salary
now since we are finding the highest
salary of each employee from different
departments will be using the rank of a
function now we have discussed about the
rank over function in how in our
previous video which is how to find the
entire salary so if you want to know it
in a more detailed way make sure you
check that out
so I'm using a rank over
and which is followed by the partition
keyword which is
Partition by
we are partitioning based on the
department ID here
order by salary
and we'll use the descending keyword
here because we we are only concerned
with the highest salary so it will be
basically from highest to the lowest
point
so close the parenthesis and you need to
give a temporary name for the rank over
function so let us just let's say give
it a salary rank
from employee table
employees table right
and after that we have to mention the
select statement again where we'll
display uh all the columns that we have
mentioned in our CTE again so let me
just mention the first name
last name
salary
Department ID
from now we have to mention the CT that
you have chosen you know highest salary
is basically the name of our CT so I'll
mention the highest salary here instead
of the table name
where
salary salary rank
is equals to 1. now I am choosing one is
it will segregate all the salaries and
it will only choose the highest salary
from that so all right I think we can we
are good to go so let us just execute
the statement and we'll see the output
all right as you can see in a resultant
set it is displaying all the uh data of
the employees that is their first name
last name and their highest salary uh
that is the employees working in
different department and their highest
salaries
so let me just explain how the query is
working here now the CT is named here as
highest salary we use it to rank
employees within each department by
salary by using the window function rank
over now we partition that data by the
column which is Department ID this means
we rank the salaries only within its
Department not across all the table
right so the data is sorted according to
the column salaries in descending order
because we want the highest salary as I
said earlier in the department to have
the highest rank which is one
also we also have selected several
columns from the table employees in the
same city and we need data from the CT
in the next select statement uh in order
to fetch in a resultant set
and in the select statement we are
basically selecting The Columns needed
to uh have in a resultant set that is
the first name last name salary and
Department ID
so in this way you can use the CTE to
find the highest salary of each employee
from uh different departments now I know
you might be wondered you know why uh CT
is being used where you can simply write
a sub query to find the highest salary
now I I get it I'll explain it in a bit
where we'll discuss in in the end why we
are using CT here so let us just again
take another example here guys so that
we can have a clear-cut idea on uh more
how VCT can work so in the second query
we'll be basically finding the average
salary of each employee working in
different employee now previously we
have found the uh
you know highest salary of the employee
in this case we'll be using the uh will
finding the average salary by each
department of the employee so let us
just write the query here first
so again I'm taking width so let us name
our CTE name as average salary here
since you are finding the average salary
and within the parenthesis mentioned uh
all the
column names and the uh operation that
you are performing so since we are
performing the average operation on the
salary I'm taking as average salary
as I am taking it as all right so I'll
just give it a Alias name
and then we are mentioning the
department ID
from the table that is employees
and will be basically grouping all the
uh details of the employees by their
Department ID
so that we can have these average salary
in each department
so close the parenthesis
now again we have to mention
the select statement which is the outer
statement after the CT now select first
name
last name
Department ID
salary
from employee table
employees table right now basically uh
the criteria which is to find the
average Charities basically we have to
join the two tables which is basically
the same table that is employees and
will be comparing the salary of
employees from these two tables
simultaneously right so we have to join
these two tables that is the CT table
and the employees table here so that is
the reason I will be joining the table
now so let me just take the employees
table uh Alias name as e so that we can
find it easily
so e DOT first name I'm taking e dot
last name
e dot Department
ID and erot salary from employees e and
basically I'll be joining this with the
CT that is average salary that we have
taken
all right so I hope you have understood
this till now so let us just give a name
to this uh let's say AVG and we are
joining the table based on
the department ID from both these
reference to tables right so I am taking
e Dot Department ID
is equals to AVG which is the name of
our CTE table that is the temporary
table which you have taken
so Department
ID
and will order we'll use the order by
statement so that will have a more clear
resultant set order by Department
ID
and we are good to go now so let us just
execute this statement and we'll see the
output
all right as you can see in a resultant
table it is displaying all the average
salaries of the employee so let us just
quickly go through the uh explanation so
this query is using a CT named average
salary guys in order to calculate the
average salary in each department now
the select statement in the CTE groups
the rows by department and uses the
average aggregate function to calculate
the average for each department now once
we have that we combine it with other
columns from the table employees to
complete the resultant answer now to do
so we are basically joining the
employees with the CT name as we would
do with any two tables to join them so
we select the columns the required
columns as we have taken here which is
the first name last name department and
salary from the employee table and the
column average salary from the CT so in
this way you can use
the city to find the average salary uh
in each department of different
employees
so there's a little error guys I forgot
to mention the average salary columns so
I was just wondering why we didn't had
the average salary result in set so let
us just mention that
now average dot average salary which we
have taken earlier
all right so let us say thank you this
statement
all right now you can see the uh the
salary of the employees working in
different departments and also the
average salary of that particular
department now if you look at the
department 10 now the salary is 44 000
and the average salary is also 44 000.
now if you look at the department ID
which is 20 now we have two different
employees Pat Frey and Michael Hassan
whose service are different that is 60
000 and 13 000 by the average salary in
that uh department is thirty six
thousand five hundred and similarly you
can see for the rest of uh the different
departments as well
so I hope this is clear uh now it brings
us to the main question that why are we
using and when we are using you know CPE
now traditionally you've probably
noticed that cities are a lot like sub
queries maybe you're wondering why I'm
using CTS when everything I did could
have been done with a simple sub query
now that's true aside from being more
readable CTS have one big advantage of
sub queries that is the resultant set or
the results from a CD can be used more
than once in a query so let's say if
you're working on a complex database
where you have to join multiple uh
tables from the database and you have to
perform various operations so in that
case you have to keep on writing the sub
queries now let's say if I want to find
the maximum of average salary from the
uh employee stable so in that case now
that I've created a CTA I can directly
write a select statement which says
select Max
and inside that I'll be writing the
average salary
which is the name of the city from the
ctma CT name that is we have taken as
AVG underscore salary so now instead of
calculating the average salary uh of
each employee from different department
using sub queries which is a whole
complete whole uh process right it takes
a bit of time so instead of that I'm
writing a simple CT for that and later I
am using the same to calculate the
maximum average salary
so when I execute this it will directly
display the maximum of average salary of
all the employees in at different
departments so it becomes quite easier
you know instead of writing sub queries
each and uh every time now if the code
with the sub query is less readable and
it is harder to understand the code with
a CT in simple way right so you would be
trying really hard just to understand
what every part of the code does when
you are writing sub queries now having
difficulties understanding a code can be
frustrating so that is where CTS can
help you guys it is one of the most
powerful tools to process hierarchical
complex data into a simple manner where
you can use it multiple times
so that brings us to the end of today's
session guys that was all about uh CTS
in SQL I hope you as you all know
learning how to answer the SQL interview
questions is a powerful skill which can
make the difference between getting
hired for the job or not and nowadays
the competition for one job is quite
high and many candidates are applying
for the same position so if you want to
get hired you cannot effort for not
being prepared to present yourself as
the best fit candidate for that
particular job role
so in order to answer the interview
questions one of the main area where you
can prepare the best is especially when
it comes to the most common SQL
interview questions because these
questions are asked during all the
interview all the job interview
questions right so in this session we'll
be discussing some uh SQL queries where
you can practice them and which will
also help you during your uh interviews
as well more on that soon but before we
get started if you're new to the channel
and haven't subscribed already consider
getting subscribed to our Channel simply
code to stay updated with all the latest
Technologies another well I can to kiss
an update from us
so without any further Ado let's get
started so let us jump into MySQL
workbench uh in order to uh execute this
top five free SQL queries so let's get
started
all right as you can see MySQL Workman
just started uh so firstly let us look
at some of the key things that you need
to keep in mind while you know uh
preparing or answering the interview
questions now the general questions will
revolve around key Concepts like you
know asking the different types of
commands in SQL different constraints
indexes views uh joints different
functions and Etc and at the same time
not just this theoretical and the uh
you know scenario based questions rather
than the objective questions wherein you
can be asked to write a query you know a
proper SQL query wherein the interviewer
wants to test your knowledge in deep you
know whether you're understanding the
SQL queries or not
now this level of interview questions
also entirely depend on the position
that you are applying so keeping in mind
I have uh already created Five SQL
questions that you might find tricky so
this might be useful for a beginner as
well uh which is
the difficulty of the querices from uh
you know from beginner level to moderate
level so you can easily answer this
queries but there is a bit of you know a
tricky part in them as well which we'll
discuss as the session progresses so
before answering the queries you have to
be thorough with all the concepts of SQL
so we have a dedicated playlist on SQL
wherein we have covered various topics
on uh topics and Concepts regarding SQL
so make sure you check that out before
you know you start performing the
queries so let us discuss the queries uh
one by one so the first query is write
an SQL query to fetch the third last
record from employees table so let me
just open this new tab
all right let us know first uh display
the records from the employee table that
is Select start from employees
so as you can see the employee table has
various columns such as you know
employee ID first name last name email
phone number hiring date job ID salary
manager ID and Department ID so the
queries that was asked is write in SQL
22 fetch the third last record from this
employee table so if you scroll down a
bit
and you can see the last record is
William and the third last record is
Hermann bear so basically we need to get
the record of this employee who's having
employee ideas 204 whose name is Hermann
bear and he works as a PR
or some PR uh as a specialist on PR so
right so basically you can solve this
you know in different ways so basically
The Logical approach is using any window
function which we'll be discussing now
and sort the data in descending order
you know based on the employee ID and
then provide a row number to each of the
record and fetch the record having row
number as three I know it is a bit of
confusing so let us just directly write
the query first so you guys can have a
clear-cut understanding select uh
mention the all the uh
rows you want in your resultant table so
I am taking employee ID
the first name
the last name
Department ID as well
salary
from now we have to write a sub query in
this wherein we'll use uh no select
operator select
star
comma now we have to use a window
function here now the window function
which I'm going to use here is row
number function
so the row number function is basically
uh you know SQL ranking function that
assigns a sequential ranking number to
each new record in a partition now when
the SQL row number function detects two
identical values in the same position it
will assign different rank numbers to
both so the logic behind is that we'll
be assigning row number to each of the
records based on the employee ID and
then we'll find the third last you know
record from this statement
all right so row number and I'll be
using the over which is the syntax
and will order will sort the data in
descending order so order by employee ID
in descending order
from
the employee table that is employees
where you have to mention the row number
as well so row number
so let us take the row number
here as row number this is a basically a
subtable right so when you need to
mention the row number as well where row
number is equals to 3 since we are
finding the third last record from our
table so let us execute this and we'll
see the output
so there is an error which says every
derived table must have its own layers
uh so I think we forgot to mention the
Alias name for the table here so let us
take the Elias name as employees e here
and
let us take it as X so it will basically
be x dot RN
so I think it is correct now
so as you can see in a result instead we
have got the resultant uh table which is
of Herman's buyer record whose employee
IDs do not forget just as we discussed
previously which is the third last
record in the table Who belongs to
Department ID 70 and is salary is ten
thousand dollars so in this way you can
simply use the window function row
number to find the third last record
from the table so similarly you might be
asked to find the uh you know second
last or fifth last in different context
so the scenario might be different but
the order and the approach to solve this
query is the same
all right moving ahead let us now
discuss the second query now the second
query states that from the Olympics
table fetch the details of all athletes
who belong to the same country but have
participated in different Olympic games
all right so let me just open another
tab
so firstly let us uh retrieve the
details from the Olympics table which is
Select star from Olympics
so the Olympic table has various uh
attributes like ID name sex age height
weight country NOC games year season
City Sports and event so what the query
States is from the Olympics table fetch
the details of all the athletes so we
are concerned with these column which is
name which is the details of all the
athletes who belong to the same country
but have participated in different
Olympic Games now in the resultant set
we need to have the resultant table
which has the details of all the
athletes who are who are from the same
country but have participated in
different Olympic Games here like the
1992 summer uh 2012 somewhere so
basically they have to be from the same
country but different games now The
Logical approach to write this query is
basically by using the self join to
solve this problem which is
uh used to join a table to itself to
compare the values within the same table
all right so let us discuss the query
now
so again though in order to solve this
query you have to be uh thoroughly you
know knowing the joints concept so we
also have a dedicated video on that as
well where you have discussed are the
various different kinds of joints so
make sure you check that out as well
so let me just write the query select
now there might be you know multiple uh
you know athletes participating in same
or different games right so I'll be
using distant Clause here distinct
and since we are joining the two tables
we need to have a temporary name for two
different tables so the for the first
table I am taking it as D1 dot name
which is the average details next I'm
taking uh D1 dot country
comma D1 dot games
from Olympics
which is the first table D1 and then
I'll use the join keyword which will
basically self join the same table which
is Olympics again but we have to mention
a different temporary name which will be
D2 here I hope you are understanding
this on
D1 dot country equals to D2 dot country
so the condition that I'm specifically
specifying here is that we need to have
this in country here that is the
athletes participating in different
Olympic Games should be from the same
country but he should be it should have
he should have played different Olympic
Games so in that sense I'm using another
condition which is and operator where D1
games
I'm using not equals to operator here
which will compare two operators if they
are same or not if they are not same it
will retrieve all the values so D2 dot
games
and I'll similarly use an order by so we
can have in uh sorted order which is
order by name as well as let's say uh
country as well
all right so let us now execute this
statement and we'll see the output all
right we have the resultant Set uh as
you can see in a resultant set we have
the details of athletes who have
participated in various different games
but belong to the same country you know
if you look at uh a djang who's belong
to China has participated in 1990 to
Summer Games whereas a lamusi who's from
the same country again China but has
participated in 2012 Summer Games now
similarly we have this Abdul Latif it's
a big name let us just take another one
uh we have augustino abangil uh who's
from the country Italy who has
participated in 1988 Summer Games
similarly we have you know
who is from Spain first participated in
various different games are ranging from
1984 1980 and 1976 Summer Games so in
this way you can uh
find the details of all the athletes uh
who's from the same country but have
participated in different games
all right let us now move on to the next
query which is a writer SQL query to
display only the details of employees
who either earn the highest salary or
the lowest salary in each department
from the employee table all right so let
me just open another tab
and we'll retrieve the details from
employee table again so start from
employees
all right we have the employees table so
the question let us go through the
question again which says write an SQL
query to display only the details of
employees who either and the highest
salary or the lowest salary in each
department from the employee table so we
need to provide in the resultant set the
details of all those employees who are
either having the highest salary or the
lowest salary from each department now
The Logical uh approach to this question
can be is like we can write a sub query
which will partition the data based on
each department ID and then identify the
record with the maximum and the minimum
salary for each of the partition
department and you know you can finally
from the main query you can fetch only
the data which matches the maximum and
the minimum salary returned from the sub
query I know it is bit or confusing so
let us write the query so that we'll
have a clear understanding again so
select I'll just display all the records
so I'll use the select star operator
select star from
employee
employees so we'll give an alias name
since it will take a lot of time writing
employees each and every time so I'm
just taking it as e
foreign
where it will compare the records from
the same table
so I'm using the join table join
statement again
and I'm using a sub query and within the
sub query I'm basically selecting the
records again which is Select star and
now we have to create uh you know
the partition for maximum salary and
minimum salary in our employee table so
create a partition which is maximum
salary
over
Partition by
Department ID now since we want the
highest and highest and lowest salary
from each department so I am considering
the department ID here
now since we are using the partition we
need to give a name for this so we'll
take it as Max salary
and similarly you have to create you
know minimum salary partition as well
the syntax remains same guys just
mention it uh
Partition by
again Department ID
this will be minimum salary
all right
from the table which is employees
now since this is a sub query and it is
a derived table we need to give a layers
name for this table as well so we'll
just take it as X
and since we have used the join we have
to mention the join on which table we
have performed which is basically a self
join on the employee table itself so e
Dot
employee ID
which is basically the primary key which
has which will uniquely uh you know
identify all the required so that's why
I'm taking employee ID here is equals to
x dot employee ID
all right and now mention the condition
here
so the condition is basically it should
match the salary with the maximum salary
from the ER table that is employee or it
should match the salary with the minimum
salary from the same table that is
employee so I'll be taking e dot salary
is equals to x dot maximum salary
all right or the condition can be e Dot
salary equals to
x dot minimum salary
so it will basically find all the you
know details which has the salary which
is either maximum or minimum right that
is it and you can also use order by if
you want to uh get in a particular order
so order by
x dot Department ID
comma x dot let's say salary as well
all right I think we do not have any
error we can just directly run the query
and we will see the output
all right our query has been
successfully executed and we have a
total of 18 records so let us just
understand how the query has worked here
all right now we have various
departments IDs that are being uh
displayed in a resultant table now if
you look at the first Department ID
which is then the maximum salary uh is
44 000 and the minimum salary is also 44
000 in this department and the employee
ID or the employee details is Jennifer
Valen
so let us just discuss another example
here
so next let us move on to the department
ID 20 which has the maximum salary as 60
000 and minimum salary as 30 000. now we
have a total of two records here that is
uh basically Michael has done who is
basically having the lowest salary in
the uh Department Who belongs to the
department 20 and we have Pat say whose
salary is the highest which is 60 000 in
the department 2020 which is being uh
being displayed here with in the
separate section as maximum salary and
minimum salary and so on for rest of the
department IDs also it will basically
segregate all the details of the
employees who is having the maximum
salary and the minimum salary
so I hope you've understood how to solve
this query uh this isn't uh you know
rocket science or you know having a lot
of difficulty to solve the question we
have just basically used you know a
sales join and a partition by statement
now Partition by is basically an
optional Clause used in the row number
function basically which is a clause
that divides the resultant set into
partitions like you know group of rows
now the partition which we have created
is basically the maximum salary and the
minimum salary now when this row number
is applied to each partition which
assigns a separate rank number to each
partition right so in the same way we
can see that you know different Salvage
have been assigned to the maximum salary
partition that we have created
all right let us now move on to our next
query which is our query 4 which says
write SQL query to find the seventh
highest salary from a table without
using the top or limit keyword
now this is one of the most common SQL
you know interview questions is to find
the nth highest salary of employees
where n could be anything like 3 4 7 13
anything you know based on number of
records that the interviewer wants to
know like in order to find the let's say
13 highest salary in SQL uh sometimes
this question is also Twisted to find
the nth minimum or nth highest maximum
salary in SQL now since many programmers
only know the easiest way to solve a
problem is using the top or the limit
keyword which will directly fetch the
records now what if the interviewer
wants to know another
you know a case to solve this problem so
in that situation what you will do you
know you cannot use the top or limit
keyword for that so basically we use the
row number function on the rank or dense
rank function to find the nth highest
salary uh to find the inside of highest
salary from the table but in this case
we shouldn't we shouldn't use all those
and even the top and limit keyword so
let us now see how to you know uh write
this query so let me again use a new tab
now in order to find the nth maximum
salary from the employee table we have
to use a correlated sub query now the
question that is asked is to find the
seventh highest salary from the employee
table so basically a correlated uh sub
query is a special type of sub query
where the sub query depends upon the
main query and executes for each and
every row returned by the main query now
the only uh drawback of this that it is
a bit slow but it can solve the problems
which are difficult to solve for example
like to find the 15 20 or 100 like in
thousands uh you know highest salary
from the employee table so let us now uh
write the query so that will have a
clear understanding again so let's query
is followed as select
so basically first let us you know uh
find the seventh highest salary for that
I'll be using the maximum
select Max salary
from the
employees table
uh sorry guys there was a mistake uh we
shouldn't need the maximum salary we
just need the salaries and in the order
of which they are separated so order by
salary in descending order that is from
highest to lowest we'll be sorting them
right so let me just execute this query
so the highest salary in our table is 93
000 and a second highest salary is
ninety thousand so the query that was
asked for is to find a seventh highest
salary that is one two three four five
six and seven so eighty thousand okay we
have uh repeated value so we'll just use
the distant keyword as well so that will
have
a unique records
all right so one two three four five six
seven so the seventh highest salary is
basically seventy nine thousand eight
hundred so we know we need to now fetch
the details of the employees whose
salary is basically the seventh highest
salary which is seventy nine thousand
eight hundred so the query would be
followed something as select
uh you know star
from
employee
employees let us take it as E1 since we
will be uh you know comparing this same
table
where n minus 1
I'll explain in the uh at the last why
we are using n minus one here guys so
let's just uh continue with the query
now you have to write a correlated sub
query because we've uh discussed earlier
which is basically select count
distinct salary so I'm using distinct
E2 dot salary
basically we accompanying the same table
once again
from
employees
e to
where mention the condition on which you
want to perform uh you know the
separation now we need to find the
highest salary right so the salary in
second table that is E2
dot salary should be greater than even
Dot
salary
so this is what the query uh exactly is
guys so let us just understand how how
this query is working here
so as I said uh the distinct keyword is
there in order to deal with any
duplicate records or the salaries that
are present in the table so in order to
find the nth highest salary uh which is
basically we need to find the seventh
highest salary right we are only
considering the unique service here and
the highest salary means no salary
should be higher than it for example if
the second highest salary means only one
salary is higher than it that is the
first salary similarly the third highest
means no two Saudis are higher than the
first two salaries similarly uh for the
seventh highest salaries you can say
there are n minus 1 salaries that are
higher than it so for example if I am
taking seventh salary so n basically
becomes 7 so 7 minus 1 is basically six
right so which is finding the seventh
highest salary from the table so let us
just execute this and we'll see the
output
so as you can see the seventh highest
salary that we have already uh seen the
output table which should have 79 800 as
a resultant table and it is showcasing
all the details of the employees who's
having the seventh higher salary uh who
is payam kaufling whose employee ID is
you know 122 whose email is p kauflin
his hiring date is job ID and the rest
of the readers have been displayed so in
this way you can find you know the
entire salary uh you know from the
employees table so this is basically a
generic solution which works in all
databases including you know MySQL or
apple database SQL portion SQL and the
only drawback as I said earlier is it is
slow because the inner query will run
for every row possessed by the outer
query so do let us know in the comment
section below what are different methods
we can use for this same query and we
also have a dedicated video on how to
find the nth highest salary using
various uh keywords like the top limit
using dense rank functions so you can
check that out as well
so moving on to the final question guys
uh the final question is write an SQL
query to fetch the details of all the
shows and the countries and sort the
shows Made in India at the top and the
rest of them in ascending order uh I
think this is from Netflix table so from
the Netflix table so let us just uh
retrieve the details first and we'll see
how the query Works select star from
Netflix
all right so the Netflix table has the
show ID type title director country date
added release your rating duration genre
so let us go to the query again it says
that we need to fetch the details of all
the shows that is basically the title
these are the show names right and the
countries countries we have the
countries also which they are made in
and sort the shows that are made in
India at the top that is we need to
mention we need to display all the shows
that were made in India at the top level
and the rest of them in ascending order
from the Netflix table
so I hope that question is clear guys so
let us now write the query
all right since we are only concerned
with the uh you know the show name that
is the title and the country we will
just select those
now we may have the titles repeated so
I'm just taking the distinct values
visiting title comma
country
from Netflix
and will basically order by
country first and we'll see how the
output is
all right so it basically uh displays
all the shown details of all these shows
that were made in by different countries
for example you can see L Patron or
radrigo Dion criminal has
has been made uh from Argentina we have
a level 16 from Canada so the query that
was asked is we need to sort the shows
Made in India at the top and rest of all
the shows in ascending order so
basically we need to have the show names
that are in India solid let me just
check we have I saw yeah right we have
certain shows that were made in India as
well
so you can see there are list of so many
records of all the shows uh for example
anger Mali Diaries
gurgaon jeans minasara kanavu and so
many others so basically in a resultant
set we want all the details of all these
to be at the top and the rest of them in
the ascending order like for example
Australia and then we need Brazil and
then Canada and similarly France so
basically in the alphabetical order so
The Logical approach for this is using
the case expression guys now that is the
tricky part where you know the
interviewer wants to know whether you're
familiar with this concept of case
Expressions so basically the case
expression goes through the conditions
and return of value when the first
condition is met just like an if if an
else statement you use for other
programming languages like CC plus best
so the once the condition is true it
will stop reading and return the result
and if no conditions are true it result
it Returns the values in the else Clause
so basically we need to mention the case
condition here
all right
so the query is followed as
so mention the case keyword the syntax
is followed in this in this way which is
case when
country
is equals to India
then return 0 that is basically return
the True Values if there is any record
or the title name having India else will
mention it as one
and finally we'll in this statement
which is again the keyword we have to
use for case expression all right so let
us now just uh implement this and we'll
see the output
so there was a Minor error guys uh so as
you can see in a resultant set we have
the details of all the shows that were
made in India that is being displayed at
the top as you can see we have all the
list of all the shows of India and then
after that the query states that we need
to uh sort the rest of the other
remaining shows that were made from
different countries in ascending order
as you can see uh just like we have
discussed earlier the country names have
been sorted in ascending order like
Argentina Austria Brazil Canada
China Italy Japan Nigeria and so on
Pakistan United States right so United
States is the last country which is
being sorted in the alphabetical order
now the same question can be asked you
know uh when we have multiple conditions
to specify now for example if I want all
the shows that were made in India as
well as Germany to be at the top and the
rest of the remaining shows from
different countries to be sorted in the
ascending order after the shows that
were made in India and Germany so in
that case the query just Remains the
Same you just need to add another
condition now first which is which is
case and country is equals to India then
zero next the condition will be case
uh I don't think we need to write the
case again and again when country
equals to
Germany
then will will specify it as one
so if there is no country that is having
shows uh other than India and Germany so
will be basically will uh mention it as
two and we are ending the statement
so let us just execute this query and
we'll see the output
so as you can see in a resultant query
the firstly we have the case condition
which will retrieve all the details of
the shows that were made in India as you
can see in the resultant set and after
that we need to have the shows that were
made in Germany
so since we have mentioned the country
as Germany it is being displayed as
Germany that is the titles or the shows
that were made in Germany and the rest
of the remaining shows that were that
belongs to other countries and we need
to sort them in ascending order in the
form of their alphabetical orders like
Argentina Australia Brazil and so on so
this query is asked in general you know
when you want to give certain records a
priority that is you want to mention you
know you want to display certain records
at the top and the remaining at the
bottom so in that case this query will
be useful which can be done using a case
expression
and with that we have come to the end of
today's session guys uh these were some
of the top five you know SQL interview
questions and answers that would have
given you an insight into what kind of
questions could be asked in your next
interview and you need to be prepared
for it as well as discussed earlier uh
not just the theoretical questions you
need to be prepared for the uh
a real-time SQL queries where you have
to write the queries you know exact
queries so in that case you have to be
prepared for that as well so in this
session we only covered you know uh the
difficulty level from uh easy to
moderate level so in our upcoming videos
we'll discuss in the same way like the
top five or top 10 tricky questions
where the uh difficulty becomes a bit
more higher where we'll discuss Advanced
SQL queries that might be asked in your
next interview questions and with that
we have reached the end of this session
on MySQL full course overall the future
of MySQL looks bright as it continues to
be the popular database solution for
businesses of all sizes MySQL offers a
combination of ease of use high
performance scalability and reliability
which makes it an attractive option for
many users and organizations hope this
session was informative and helpful we
hope you had a lot to learn and if you
have any further queries regarding any
concepts or Topics in this tutorial feel
free to let us know in the comments
below and a team of experts will be more
than happy to assist you until next time
thank you and keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here